e
hey good morning folks uh state federal
relations and Veterans Affairs we
usually try to start right on time we're
missing a few folks there's a couple
that are inbound so we're going to be a
couple more minutes uh to let them come
in here and those of you that are here
early uh good on you and we'll uh the
first part we're going to do a quick
wrap around uh uh with our our new folks
and then um we'll get right into uh
General
bit
e
all right folks uh at
0905 uh is this is our custom in state
federal veterans we will start with the
Pledge of Allegiance and uh one of our
new members to the committee
representative Hemingway would you would
okay appreciate everyone who is here
early uh we're going to learn a lot
today uh even those of us who have been
here before um I want to start before I
forget uh with
our our new um researcher Davis Allen is
here uh Davis just if you want to just
stand up and um if you want to take a
minute and just or or more and just uh
explain to us tell us uh um where you're
coming from are because I know you're
new to the staff and then a little bit
position actually Davis tell you what
why don't you come up and if you don't
mind I didn't mean to put you in the
stand but I'm going to um this this is
uh this is on YouTube it's going to be
out there forever hundreds of people
will watch this before the end of the
day and uh we're here to urance so tell
us a little bit about uh where you're
coming from and and what you do what a
researcher does and that type of thing
thank you Mr chair um so my name is
Davis Allen I'll be the researcher for
this committee um I serve uh the
entirety of the committee um in my work
I'll be performing any sort of research
questions uh my understanding right now
of the position is that any questions
from the rank and file members of the
committee will go through the chair and
then on to me uh
I'll get confirmation on that from my
leadership just to ensure and then I'll
report back to the chair on that um but
I believe that's to make sure there's no
duplicate requests um no requests that
would be partisan in one way or another
as my position is nonpartisan I serve
everybody in the committee um in a
nonpartisan way um so if there's
questions about what current statutes
exist if there's questions about what
federal rules and regulations there are
if there would be conflicts that if
there are questions about a legislative
history of how many times has this bill
or this topic come up before Etc um
those are some of the things that I
would be able to assist this committee
with uh regarding research and Reporting
back to the committee that way they can
make more informed decisions um as to
where I'm coming from uh I am a graduate
of keen State College um I studied
history and Holocaust and genocide
studies with a minor in German
uh do not try to learn German during a
global pandemic they move it all online
you don't learn anything um but uh so
don't ask me how much German I know um
but I do know a lot about my other
subjects um and then from there I went
on to serve the New Hampshire Department
of Labor for the past two and a half
years until coming here starting with
workers compensation then boiler and
elevator inspections and finally wage an
hour
inspections boiler and elevator
inspections okay note to self uh you
never know what kind of skills different
folks have would you take any questions
if there are any that's our custom um
any questions for our our new
researcher seeing none uh Davis thanks
welcome aboard thank you
sir our administrative assistant again
is Karen Kaki uh Karen's office is just
down the hall she does a great job
prepping this room this room was packed
yesterday with people for the EFA
hearing uh and it's looking great uh we
are missing some folks who are excus
today they will be watching U catching
up uh online uh we we're going to have
two billing hearings this afternoon
which I uh have already told them and
will remind them that they really need
to watch we'll be executing those in a
week so anyway uh yeah Davis and Karen
were lucky to have them helping us to
run things here with the state federal
and veterans
and uh what I like to do now and we'll
start we'll go back to representative
Hemingway and the the members who aren't
here and we have a couple other new ones
that uh we'll give them a chance uh next
time to um introduce themselves but uh R
of H would take a a minute a couple
minutes if you don't mind and just uh
let us know uh where you're coming from
highlights of your life Journey uh
you're solven counter guy but I'll let
you uh tell us your your story
thank you Mr chair um so this is my
first term I um did 38 years Total
Service in the military army between the
active duty Army and New Hampshire
National Guard I retired as a full-time
active duty soldier from the New
Hampshire National Guard in uh 2020 just
before the pandemic uh from that point
I've been doing homeschooling with the
kids because of the pandemic they all
came out and one stayed out and one went
back to school
um but in that time frame I've been
deployed twice overseas well I actually
have five overseas tours but two to
combat zones um so that's about it I had
kids sounds like this is a good
committee for you given your your uh
your experience your your journey
um I'm going to guess your deployments
were to uh Afghanistan maybe in idd in
Iraq or uh yes CH I I went to Iraq uh oi
oif2 and then to uh Kuwait okay well
thank you for your service of
course did you when you in the National
Guard did you get to know the agitant
general at all or yes chair I uh I spoke
to him the other day at the inauguration
so uh with his level of uh where he's at
it was a vague familiar uh familiarity
familiar arity well today he did recall
me today may be your chance to um uh ask
him some questions absolutely and um
given your experience you you might know
some to ask so uh welcome glad glad
you're here representative Jones Phil
Jones has been here before as a sub uh
representative Jones take a couple
minutes if you would and tell us of your
your journey thank you very much yes my
name is Philip Jones uh I'm a Cheshire
District 3 from Keen New Hampshire uh I
work as an independent manufacturer
sales rep so uh I do a lot of traveling
and um uh it's what I like to do uh I've
been in elected official for many years
I'm I'm on the city council just start
in Keen just started my 28th year before
that I was on City Council in a New
Jersey Community where I served nine
years and also served as the mayor so
I've I've been unelected for a long time
my last term I did I did education
committee but I had the opportunity to
sub here and uh I like the way you do
things and I took the opportunity to to
sign up for this committee so uh thank
you for having
me thank you for being here
representative Jones appreciate that um
representative Gagney a a a veteran in
of many experiences uh in your journey
is taking you uh from where to
where well first of all I'm a Canadian
transplant came here from can from PQ
back in
1950 I still have my little green card
it's a little warped now but the picture
on
it um asked people to please help send
this kid to
Camp uh I've been married to my high
school sweetheart for 60 years this the
same
woman and
retired from the Postal Service
in 2006 I served in the Navy from 61
through
67 uh two deployments I guess you would
call it in uh Mediterranean the Red Sea
Yemen all all those areas that are now
Tinder boxes and they weren't much
better than either we just were not
heavily involved in
it uh
when I came home I had an collecting job
history
police iron
worker I ended up at the Postal Service
which because I I started looking around
at 40 years old I says I need something
with
benefits so I retired in ' 06 from there
after that I was hounded to run for
office and I refused to run for office
until will infantine represented will
infantine uh talked to me he says you
need to put your money where your mouth
is well he knows my background I was a
martial arts instructor back in the day
in the last
century and so when he said something
like that I says okay and I ran in 2008
I was elected by nine
votes and the rest is pretty much
history I served in various uh
committees and I ended up here I have
some expertise maybe not I can feel some
I've never I was never in combat not
against an enemy against maybe an
opposing ship when we hit Port right the
first bar you went to get a
different ship's name there right so I I
kind of got involved in things like that
and I won most of them so here I am in
in this committee and uh hope to be able
to help out with the veterans
thank you representative gagy who I just
learned won his first election by nine
votes and I think he won your last
election by like two votes or something
10 so represent gagy is a very efficient
campaigner he he gets enough votes to
win and and um there you go glad so glad
that you're back uh her of
gagy our vice chair uh representative
skip Rollins is back glad he's back uh
representative Rollins
thank you Mr chair uh representative
skip Rollins representing Newport unity
in Charlestown uh this will be my
seventh term down here I got roped into
it as Larry did years ago and got
hounded to run and said well we'll see
if we got a shot at it I was surprised
got elected and uh and here I am I've
spent the last Almost 21 years at L
Valley Building Supply in Newport a
full-time job
um that's about that's about
it thank you representative uh my name
is Mike Moffett uh I'm chairing this
committee I'm originally from the North
Country uh gron originally uh went to
UNH Plymouth uh Sports Guide
basketball uh Guy taught high school for
several years up north and at Trinity my
department chair of Trinity was a
retired lieutenant colonel from the Army
um he'd been in World War II Korea and
Southeast Asia and he had all these
stories that he told in class I had no
stories so uh my brother was a marine T
you had me go and just talk to a
recruiter and the recruit I just went in
to get a flyer and I ended up coming out
having signed up so uh I did uh 25 years
active and reserve duty with the Marine
Corps U Desert
Storm um I was on General Frank staff
after 911 at centcom in in mcdill and
then 2010 I was like the oldest Marine
in Afghanistan I went back on duty for a
year uh did some special assignments um
in
Afghanistan um I this my fourth term I
did a couple terms on House
Education uh given my background I also
spent 20 years in community college
system and 12 years in the University
system so education is another part of
my journey um I served as Vice chair
here before becoming chair and uh very
happy uh to be uh back in the
mix uh our new clerk uh represent mandle
bomb welcome and um you have uh five
minutes if you need it all right great
um uh thank you Mr chair so I'm Jennifer
Mandel bam I represent Portsmith and
Newington um in my day job I work as a
healthcare researcher for a health tech
company and I generally study these new
and emerging Trends within the
healthcare industry so things like Ai
and physician burnout and value based
care um and I was I was telling our our
chairman how fortunate I feel to be able
to to think and write about the things
that that matter to me for a living I do
not have any experience with the
military um but I I thank all of you for
your service among those those who do um
but this is an important issue to these
are important issues to my district just
given um that that peas is um is within
within Newington and I'm eager to to
all thank you representative a ranking
member representative cbrt welcome back
thank you um so my name is Christine
cybert I am from
Manchester um Ward one Manchester and um
I'm excited to be here in this ranking
position it's a little new to me but uh
I'm just going to start with what I said
the last time we came here um is that
you know I think we all have family in
the military I do my husband was in the
Navy he was on in masawa stationed there
from 2004 to or 2000 to
2005 um and he actually worked in
intelligence there so I don't
technically know what he did he'd have
to kill me right um but yeah so I think
we can agree that despite you know the
reasons we get into conflicts all of
that we might totally disagree on that
um we really owe it to our veterans to
take care of them um you know I've
recently been looking up a lot of
research on my family because a
constituent was talking me into joining
the
DAR and you know I'm finding that I have
upbs of that qualify about you know
probably at least 40 is what I'm out
right now of people who fought in the
Revolutionary War and I believe their
service is really important and it's
touching me a lot by looking at all of
that and again to this day I appreciate
every veteran that is in this room for
their service so um with that said um I
am happy to be here today as ranking
member and uh and thank you for being
here thank you represent cybert D is the
Daughters of the American Revolution
correct yes and um I'm also I taught
history when I taught and uh care about
military history history and um my four
fourth great-grandfather was at
Bennington with John Stark so I guess my
daughters would could be uh da members I
need to follow up on that I'm more I'm
more excited about that than they are I
think but uh yeah uh not everybody loves
history but they should uh thank you
representative our Deputy ranking member
uh back from last year welcome back
representative Lloyd thank you um I'm
very happy to be back actually this was
my first request for an assignment um so
I'm pleased to be back here with all of
you um I grew up in Kansas and I moved
out east and probably 06 I believe um
and then moved moved up to nsha in 2017
when I bought my house um and I have not
looked back since um I wanted a state
that had mountains and here I go um I
have a number of family who have also
served I myself have not served um my
mom's side both side actually goes back
to the Revolutionary War as well um and
most recently comes up to my uncle who
was um in the Marines and he was a
tunnel rat um in Vietnam um and then uh
my dad was uh in the Air Force working
on the sr71s um doing maintenance so uh
so yeah it was uh I've got a lot of
people in my family as well that um are
touched by what we what veteran services
are available in our state and
throughout the country So
yeah thank you representative Lloyd
Nashville this is a state that does have
mountains Nash's mountains aren't that
big I don't think
but um there's a a rep from Nash named
representative Kevin Scully you must
know representative Scully who was in
then he was out now he's back in and
he's from Nash and he visited uh Senator
Pearl's Farm here in in Lowden just up
the road where I am from uh which is up
on a little Ridge and representative
Scully from nashv said wow look at the
view it's so great to be up here in the
North country and I said to represent
Skully Lowden is not the North country
uh that's north of the Naes so uh yes uh
as you as I said I'm from gron and that
is in the North country and there are
mountains up there rupo Manion welcome
back thank you Mr chair yeah I'm Tom
Manion I'm from uh Hillsboro one pelum
uh I've only been in New Hampshire since
2000 since 2020 moved up here during the
pandemic um my history is like I joined
the Marine Corps after 911 uh in high
school I was chomping at the bit to go I
wanted to go get those responsible uh
join the Infantry uh despite having a 99
on the ASVAB um
The Shame of it all is I ended up in
Iraq I never had a chance to go after
Bin Laden or anybody responsible uh with
the al-Qaeda in in Afghanistan uh those
experiences have uh taught me to pay a
lot better attention to US foreign
policy and it has crafted my uh
political leaning
sense thank you repr representative
Manion for the many people watching who
will be watching who may not understand
you mentioned 99 and the ASVAB uh ASVAB
is an acronym could Ju Just So that
everybody yeah it's the arm Services
vocational aptitude battery uh some kids
take it getting out of school and 99
means that was in the top
1% so rep may or may not be a genius but
he's close to it U given that ASVAB
store I'm not I can't remember what mine
was but uh I don't know if it was 99 but
anyway ripson of beler uh new to the
committee but a veteran uh lawmaker uh
welcome representative
Belcher thank you chairman Moffett uh
good morning everyone I'm coming to you
after my first term was in the House
Education committee um I am not a uh
veteran though I certainly have much
respect and appreciation for those who
have served my background I've done
quite a few things I was a paramedic for
quite a while I was a teacher for quite
quite a while um now I'm primarily
interested in education politics and
this was likewise My First Choice
committee for this term uh largely
because I want to significantly focus on
the issues of federalism of Republican
form of
government um and domestic and foreign
security threats to all of us so I look
forward to working with you all thank
you thank you representative beler
representative Bud budak um did I get
that pretty close that's
correct thank you uh Mr chair for giving
me this opportunity and good morning
everybody um my name is shaj
budhathoki
I 16 years ago uh I came to this country
as Refugee from
Bhutan uh the reason was Bhutan has One
Nation one people policy meaning the
king had is you know uh Buddhist and all
other diverse Community needs to follow
his you know belief so as I was from you
know ath think Nepali community and and
we revolted against it said no we have
our own belief on system so we going to
you know uh be with it we going to
follow it so at the age age of nine I
became Refugee uh for 19 years I was in
Nepal as a refugee so for fortunately uh
in
N uh I was able to come to United States
as Refugee and I've been living in New
Hampshire men New Hampshire uh since
then so um I represent Manchester
Hillsboro County District 40 and then um
I have couple of businesses uh two kids
and wife in
Manchester um I'm also a researcher
doing my PhD in transformative social
change peace and Reconciliation is my uh
main study research
um and I'm here to listen learn and and
contribute thank
you thank you represent buak and for
anyone watching online who maybe doesn't
know where Bhutan is if you could uh
just give them uh a sense of
geographically where that is so uh it's
in in between uh India and China or
Tibet it's a very tiny country uh it's
in Southeast Asian country
what it has is gross national happiness
which we don't have it so they measure
the development through uh gross
national happiness not gross domestic
product okay and um it's m mountainous
is that correct so if if representative
Lloyd's looking from mountains uh she
could find them in Bhutan that's fair to
say thank you welcome glad that you're
here and uh finally uh representative f
a little bit easier for me to say uh
welcome you surprised
but uh thank you uh good morning
everybody my name is Lily Foss I
represent Manchester's Wards 245 and 7 I
am from Manchester I grew up in
Manchester my mom's family has lived in
Manchester since 1905 my
great-grandmother was a longtime nurse
at the VA in Manchester and then on my
dad's side uh my dad is from Portsmith
where his father was a veteran in the
Air Force and then a longtime employee
of P's Air Force Base now Air Guard base
uh so my background I have a degree in
politics and international relations
after I graduated from college I came
back I did americore I moved to Philly
for a little bit discovered that
Philly's not as good as New Hampshire so
I moved back uh in my day job I work in
housing advocacy and anti-h housing
discrimination advocacy so since there's
such a high rate of homeless and housing
and stability for veterans and just
discrimination against veterans uh based
on various you know disabilities things
that people may have gotten in the
service I'm really looking forward to
being able to use that experience in
housing to make an
impact thank you repent Foss okay that
brings us to 9:30 it's just uh just
after 9:30 just about on time uh the
agitant general is in the house I see
him uh General mtis welcome back great
that you're here uh one of your former
soldiers is is is now uh is now your
welcome all right thanks sir uh uh Mr
chair members of the committee thank you
for having us here today I'm for the
record I'm Major General David mtis I
have two jobs the Adent general for the
New Hampshire National Guard and I'm
also the commissioner of the Department
of military Affairs and veteran services
so a quick background of myself I sort
of chule maam F and representative
Manion um I actually grew up in
Manchester uh manchest Memorial High
School a proud graduate uh was very
fortunate to go to United States
Military Academy at West Point was
branched infantry served on active duty
I chuckle because uh I did so poorly in
mechanical engineering that I was
branched into the Infantry for about
five six years on active duty uh after
that time I uh uh transitioned to the
National Garden reserves I became a
Green Beret from Special Forces and I
joined the New Hampshire National Garden
in 2007 uh lifelong New Hampshire
resident other than on active duty and
deployed uh three deployments Iraq and
Afghanistan I currently reside in
Portsmouth enough of
that so I handed out some um information
packets when you open it up generally
speaking the leftand side is about the
New Hampshire National Guard the right
hand side is really about uh Department
of military Affairs and veteran services
so let's just talk through a few things
for those new Representatives here take
this as sort of national guard
101 Ur New Hampshire National Guard is
approximately 3,000 people there's
almost 2,800 Uniform service members in
the state of New Hampshire just in the
guard that has that has nothing to do
with the Army Reserves an active duty
Air Force squadron at peas generally
speaking your New Hampshire National
Guard is approximately 3,000 strong when
you break it down for the Army and air
the Air National Guards approximately
1100 and I'm just giving you round
numbers to just keep it simple um 1,00
Airman at paser National Guard base it's
the only place you'll find an air
National Guards person um we fly the KC
46 refueler which is is the most modern
refueler of 18 Air National Guard Wings
in the country we are the only one with
a KC 46 refueler what does that mean
strategic relevance 17 other states have
was called the KC 135 which is which is
an Eisenhower a refueler we have
strategic relevance and guess what we
have about 150 Airmen deployed right now
to the Middle East they're on a 90-day
deployment and they'll be coming back uh
early next
month we also because of the geographic
location of the training flights uh the
sorties that go overseas we also have
150 active duty Airmen a complete it's
called the 64th air refilling Squadron
also stationed at P's so we can get the
maximum amount out of that airplane to
support Global combatants around the
globe so it's a big deal we have
strategic relevance that we're the only
Air National Guard Wing in the country
with this
plane let's transition to the Army guard
the Army guard generally speaking is
about 1800 strong you will generally see
as you open up that brochure there's a
trifold and it'll give you the
geographic location of all our
facilities when you look at that
facilities just conceptually think of
this 1,800 soldiers 18 armories in 18
different communities so generally
speaking a week and a month you have 100
soldiers right
when you might go buy one of our
armories the challenge for us is there's
only three to four full timers so
generally a lot of our facilities look
empty but on that week and a month 97
other soldiers show up there's very
simple broad terms the Manchester Army
has significantly more people we have
about 250 soldiers in there but
generally speaking when you're out in
your communities and you see an Armory
there's three to four
full-timers and a week and a month an
extra 75 to 100 soldiers will show
up so there there number reason people
join the military of the New Hampshire
National Guard um a sense of purpose to
serve their Nation right when I talk to
our recruiters and when I talk to our
Junior soldiers who come in and we bring
them on sort of like an hro 101 the
number one reason they continue to join
is for a sense of service or purpose of
their Nation number two reason is
generally the education benefits the
biggest benefit the the state gives to
the New Hampshire National Guard is free
tuition at the University system of New
Hampshire as someone once described to
me were the educator uh were the
escalator to the middle class we are all
about educational opportunities whether
it's white collar or blue collar it does
not matter the biggest benefit the state
uh of New Hampshire this legislative
body RIT large gives to us is that free
tuition waiver either through the
university system of New Hampshire with
the community college system of New
Hampshire there's other benefits as well
but generally speaking what we tell our
soldiers and Airmen is um you know you
got to be a good citizen right it's all
about education you know and trying to
get those younger soldiers in or Airmen
into the job market for New Hampshire
we're a very young Force approximately
20% of our Force are college students so
a lot of them at P their National Guard
base will go to UNH get your degree Serv
in the guard free tuition waiver so
that's the number one and two reasons so
when you go back to the left-and side
you'll also see sort of like a small uh
piece of paper and it list our
accomplishments so what has the New
Hampshire National Guard been up to both
Army and air once I is the
accomplishments of the Guard one side is
the accomplish the accomplishments of
the Department of military Affairs and
veteran services so generally speaking
what are the National Guard do last year
your number one Mission as an
operational force is to fight America's
Wars we welcomed home approximately 280
soldiers from our field artillery uh
Battalion um from the Middle
East we activated uh 15 soldiers in
support of the governor to go to the
Southwest border for 60 days on a state
active duty mission in support of
operation Lone Star we also sent five
soldiers to Florida to support them
during Hurricane Milton and we also
supported Vermont during a recent
flooding event last year with two
blackha helicopters provide search and
rescue opportunities or um you know U um
capabilities to
them distilled into this state in New
Hampshire U we did eight search and
rescue operations last year and you say
okay what did we do for our communities
you know we were aggressive and pursued
this program called star base the
military loves this acronyms we like to
confuse both yourselves and ourselves
because the Army and a don't speak the
same language generally speaking in
simple terms is this it's a fifth grade
stem program for underprivileged kids we
compete amongst the Department of
Defense we able to be selected for a a a
one of these programs and what it is is
the Department of Defense you know sort
of grants us money to provide a a
dedicated classroom in pem where we've
hired two teachers an administrator and
an administrative assistant to all they
do is teach fifth grade stem um it's a
25-hour curriculum to UND uh serve
children and so any school within
probably like a 30 minute um bus ride
from Pam Brook can participate and last
year we did the entire Manchester Middle
School school district so those are just
examples of what we try to do for our
community outreach um we also do what's
called Innovative Readiness training and
what that means is a soldier or Airman
does their military
job uh in support of our civilian
population and so last year what we did
was we did three training events where a
dental hygienist and our dentist went to
Manchester worked out of their Dental
van and provided free uh service um for
dental cleanings and hyi hygienic uh um
for Manchester school children so those
are some of the things that the
Hampshire National Guard does let's
trans ocean uh transition over to the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services I think most of you are
aware that in
2019 the governor signed an executive
order and it was codified into law that
established the mil Department of
military Affairs and veteran
services it was trans uh
transformational and what it did was it
broke down all these silos and state
government and Consolidated all veteran
services into one entity so one of the
lines I like to say is we're uh we all
things veteran except health
care Department of military Affairs and
veteran services is not the Manchester
VA and we are not the Veterans Home in
tilted those are separate and distinct
entities that we partner and collaborate
with but we don't have a part of it but
what did it do in 2019 it it it
essentially brought in three separate
divisions underneath the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
one as you're all aware of as a state
Veteran Cemetery we've always had that
um we continue to support that there was
a division of veteran services that was
on a separate survivors Island um we
brought that into the fold there's
approximately 10 veteran service
officers they're the ones your
constituents as a veteran will most
likely interact with us for veterans
claims and
compensation the third branch we brought
into it started at Health and Human
Services with two employees and we're
now up to six and it's our community
outreach so we have to have a long
acronym and a long term but it's our
community outreach we typically call it
the Division of Community Based military
programs so think of this in the Last 5
Years we're able to partner with
Employment Security to establish a
veteran friendly Business program what
does that mean it means 81 employers um
throughout the state of New Hampshire
have come to us to fill out an
application to say we are a veteran
friendly business we want veterans we
value what they have as an employer and
we want to employ them with a low state
uny employment rate you this outc coming
year you'll see you know one of the
standard things we typically do is
called ask the question and think of it
like this there's 990,000 veterans in
the state of New Hampshire only 30,000
30,000 of them receive Care at either
the Manchester VA or a White River
Junction so 60,000 veterans in the state
of New Hampshire are going to their
primary care of Provider so ask a
question what does it do if a veteran
goes to their primary care provider
they're simply supposed to ask the
question is have you served and if you
serve then it generates a different list
of questions to try to make sure that
veteran gets the appropriate level of
care that he may he or she may
need there's other programs and
initiatives um before I bring up the
staff of each each of our um directors
of each of our three divisions of of
veteran services um do you have any
questions of
ma'am um so thank you for that
information Major General meles um uh P
Air National Guard bases in my districts
that's certainly important to to myself
and my constituents and I have heard
about this incredible refueling aircraft
um so you mentioned that the
um the the VA provide VA provides
Healthcare the National Guard is
separate from that if
a if someone were looking for mental
Health Services would they go through
the VA and or are you providing support
Guard both okay so a National Guard
service member can get Mental Health
Services through our um behavioral
health program and we call it beyond the
yellow ribbon where we have a sort of
significant group of uh individuals to
support guard members um and I would
also say if that uh person is eligible
for the VA they can do that as well
you R
gagy thank you Mr chairman General uh
not really a question but I was one of
the last uh ride alongs on the old
tanker and I had a nice conversation
with the boom operator whatever their
designation is not very happy with the
new ones as far as uh they wouldn't be
able to everything was was going to be
on computer am I correct
yes and I just want you to know that
this Airman was not very pleased with
that because they like to get right on
their stomachs and really look at what
was going on so I I imagine they had to
adjust yeah so what the representative
is alluding to is
um like it's not as fun like if we were
to give you or sorry our Airman like a
flight on one of our refers the old
Eisenhower refueler there's a back glass
sort of bubble that a boom operator
would lie in and he would have a toggle
switch to sort of guide the uh the fuel
boom into the receiver and it was all
visual um you know modern technology
it's now uh a 3D screen so it's almost
uh like a computer game and I don't say
that to denigrate it um it's it's
follow up just a comment from me that
I've never been so high in my life
yeah I asked them how high we were and
they they wouldn't tell me how high we
were but I know I flew at 33,000 ft and
we were not at 33,000 ft yeah he gets
called to an old PL I suppose so
yeah you've never been so high in your
life that that got my attention
represent of u g um other
questions Ron Rollins thank you Mr
chairman thank you general for taking my
question couple of things we've worked
on a number of bills to help the uh
National Guard with with Recruitment and
and I want to know how how are those
programs working and how is the
recruitment going right now how many are
you down that you can still use Etc
thank you um thank you representative uh
for bringing that up because I forgot to
uh address that so thank you um
International Guard were're 100% fully
made of the 1,68 positions we have every
single one is filled so recruiting and
retention the International Guard is not
an issue I think part of it is the
educational benefit and proximity to
being a UNH because we employ a lot of
young college students on the Army guard
is somewhat of a challenge um we have to
be exact
1,757 positions and we have about 170
vacancies so we have about a 10%
unemployment rate what we're finding now
is postco is you were over the
recruiting assession challenge you our
recruiters are getting back into high
schools uh there's L there's more of the
youth are coming out again and so we
actually in the Army guard had one of
our best years ever in a sessions of
what we call non-prior service which for
you means a kid who's never served
before um we Pro prob approximately
brought in about 200 soldiers last year
the challenge for us is um for those of
you like probably remember is um a lot
of people don't make the military career
you know a lot of people serve they'll
do their that first term enlistment and
then they they get out because they got
the college they got the GI Bill and
they're happy they serve their nation
and they just move on to their next step
stepping stone so the challenge for us
is we're unlike a probably private
sector civilian employer we have
constant CH in our fors like every year
we have to recruit about 10% of a new
force and then every year 10% of the
force leaves so it's not like you have
you're a stable employer in a sense that
um you know people like what they do but
it's just it's the nature of the
business when an 18-year-old person
joins they typically will join for the
service and the college
benefits and the challenge for us now is
is retention how do we keep people in so
the legislature has been extremely
invaluable to us over the past couple of
years are trying to expand some of our
retention
uh um opportunities to try to keep
service members in and there's two or
three that have been exceptional one was
if you reinlist in a Hampshire National
Guard we were the second state in the
nation you can now transfer that to free
tuition waiver to your
spouse you it's it's helping um it it
hasn't had a significant impact as we
thought it would but the whole point is
like you know sometimes we'll say like
the service member volunteer well the
service member joins but the family gets
drafted and so how do we uh cater or
accommodate military families for their
support of that service member so the
free free tuition waiver transfer to
your spouse has been good it hasn't been
a cure all the next challenge we have is
um there's no more 20-year golden
handshake there's no more 20 year go on
active duty or go on the garden 20 years
you get this retirement 50% of your
retirement pay um we're a 401k now so
Congress changed this about five years
ago that there's no 20y year hey stay
this long and this is a retirement that
you get it's it's called Blended
retirement system uh it's a 401k program
so any service member can get out with
that 401k in that match so it's the
challenge for us now is keeping the
junior Enlisted the sergeant into a
second term Of
Enlistment and last year you all
supported us with coming up with what's
called a state retention bonus and what
it allow us to do as we're trying to
finish the policy like now is if you're
in a specific job for instance an
infantryman and you do not qualify for a
federal retention bonus we will give you
a uh State retention bonus and right now
it's nominal it's $44,000 for two years
if you reinlist but we feel like that's
a bridging strategy to get him to some
sort of other uh additional benefits so
to answer your question is 10%
unemployment rate in the Army guard um
we're doing better in recruiting we
struggle with retention of the firsttime
kid who comes in and then doesn't want
to
reinlist representative
Belzer thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for being here and for taking my
question um I'm looking for a little bit
of information regarding the over all
outlook on recruiting and retention of
uh of our soldiers and I'm looking for a
little information I don't know if you
have it on hand on both ends on the end
of is there any surveying done of um the
young people who were to see what the
top reasons are that they might not be
joining and particularly any data that's
broken out um among those who are
otherwise inclined or likely to be
joining as well as on the other side of
the coin um what are the top reasons for
rejection of anyone trying to join and
have there been any changes in numbers
uh percentages of rejected
candidates so generally speaking the
biggest challenge we have with
recruiting is a childhood
obesity uh only 17 and 19% of today's
youth is eligible for military service
because they can't pass the fitness test
and they're overweight so it's a
challenge and then like sometimes you'll
hear the to serve that's been a
decline uh I would offer to you that uh
I believe every service met the
recruiting goals last year the active
duty Army Navy Marine Corps Marines I
believe and you might have to fact check
me on that but I'm pretty sure like the
Army was activ Army was in a hole on the
Marines always make their numbers um
because they're a small service um but
generally speaking there's been an I
would say an uptake in ass
sessions I would say for the retention
pieces we try to do surveys to say you
know why are you getting out um you
generally speaking um they've served and
they' they did their
time and and that's it and you got to
realize
um a week and a month gets old to people
when you start missing like birthdays
anniversaries and family events so and
sometimes what we ask of our service
members because the different units have
different um what we call operational
Tempo so for example if uh like field
artillery so New Hampshire has this this
rocket system called the high Mars High
Mobility a mobile uh artillery rocket
system you probably hear about them in
Ukraine um that is a lethal uh weapon
system that is in high
demand our soldiers will deploy every
four to 5 years like clockwork to the
Middle East um The Challenge is um most
volunteer and like are willingly and
happy to go but then it's almost when
you come back been there seen I've done
it I'm I'm going my I need to finish my
college education I need to like I get
establish in a civilian career and so
there's just there's there's nothing
specific and I'm not trying to answer on
the question but there's just a lot of
little variables that sort of impact
then you might go to another unit that
says uh I've never left my Armory in 5
years um you know we have two state
partnership programs with foreign
countries one in Al Salvador and one
with Cabo Verde the West African island
nation why because it's a global chess
board it's all about allies and partners
and a terance for China so right you got
to be on the field to compete so every
month we're sending soldiers and Airmen
to those two countries and almost like
exchange programs so the challenge is
like soldiers and Airmen want to do
something um and it's always trying to
find that balance of too much or too
little
representative the representative from
Portsmouth
please thank you Mr chairman um could
you just elaborate a little bit more on
what those Partnerships look like what
the purpose is and what they
do so the uh National Guard Bureau
the um in the fall of a the the Cold War
um of the Eastern block nations in 1993
National Guard Bureau established with
the state department a partnership
program and it started as a military to
military engagement with Eastern block
countries to not to sort of um you know
upset Russia immediately and um so it's
just trying to bring in like sort of
Western Doctrine and Western standards
to a lot of developing nations that
partnership program has explained around
the globe so of the 54 states in
territories uh there's probably about
110 Partnerships right now so New
Hampshire um get his partnership with El
Salvador in 2000 for the reasons why I
cannot tell you it's just way before my
time and in 2022 we got our second
partnership program with Cape Verde Cabo
Verde and part of the reason why is um
with those is
um they're generally Western leaning
democracies that either support the
United States either in the United
Nations or in in in other Arenas and um
it's all about just uh deterrence in
This Global chess board against our
adversaries to ensure that that you know
they're sort of incorporating sort of
like us Doctrine and opportunities the
beauty or value is we go hold of
government and so the previous governor
came with us uh with the commission of
econom business and E economic Affairs
and we brought them the Cabo Verde to
engage with sort of Business Development
and since that time like we've developed
when we've had Dartmouth tuck School of
Business do actually case studies
through their MBA program for Cabo Verde
and it has been utterly exceptional and
the last one they just did was um leanx
Sigma so the biggest botling company in
Cabo Verde wanted to improve its Energy
Efficiency and sort of waste
reduction and the dartman tuch School of
Business did a case study for that that
business so those are the opportunities
of H of government when we talk about is
expanding um you know those Partnerships
and that's why we do it thank you
General excellent presentation we could
do this all morning I there a lot of
things that I would like to ping you on
but we we need to let some of the other
folks wash over us with some some other
some other uhu orientation information
but I before we lose any saved rounds as
we say anything that you really want us
to hear uh while while you're while
you're there uh s it's rather the simple
thank you for your continued support of
our men and women in uniform it is
sincerely
appreciated thanks again uh joh is your
Deputy here uh uh yes sir uh I I thought
she was yes uh uh and would you like to
introduce her yeah so uh you know we're
fortunate enough that uh most of you
probably knew Mr Warren Perry um Warren
retired uh he was an exceptional Public
Service think of it like this he did 20
year 28 years active duty Army did a
year and a half for the state um came
for us nine years as Deputy agent
General turned 60 had his first
granddaughter he said I want to retire
and go hun and fish um we're privileged
of getting Nicole I'll let her talk to
herself about herself uh the here though
is um I went to West Point she went to
Air Force Academy and it's a little bit
of sibling rivalry the only thing we
have in common is we both don't like the
[Laughter]
Navy that's uh that's excellent our new
governor as you know I'm sure uh her
daughter goes to the academy at uh out
in Colorado Springs uh and uh their
football team had great trouble against
both Army and Navy but anyway uh uh
Deputy agitant General Nicole
um let me sure deset Bixler correct Des
Bixler welcome thank you thank you
members of the committee uh as as uh tag
has introduced himself I am the deputy
agitant General and I'm also the Deputy
Commissioner for the Department of
military Affairs and veteran
services uh I come from a 30-year career
in the Air Force I'm an Air Force
Academy grad as he said I grew up in
Connecticut um then I went out to uh
Colorado
and I decided to live in New Hampshire
when I came through Peas on active duty
with the KC
135s um and uh and I and I joined the
guard in 1993 after eight years of
active duty I retired in 2014 after 30
years of service and I'm delighted to be
General and uh I'm trying to think of
how to uh
refer to you Deputy tag uh um if if you
take a just a couple moments and tell a
committee in in Your Capacity as Deputy
you know Warren is the general said was
wonderful uh he and I go to the same
Parish here in conquer and he was here
often uh answering questions and doing a
great job um so if you could take just a
maybe a minute or so and and tell us a
little bit about the deputy role the
deputy role really is the number two for
the tag so in in his absence then I act
in his stad um obviously I would confer
with him and uh I also oversee the um
Department of military Affairs and and
veteran services I we have um three
different divisions as tag has uh
delineated we also have a business
office who takes care they're kind of
like the um administrative umbrella for
the Department so they take care of
administrative duties they do budgeting
and they also make sure that the
contracts get executed for the state for
the for all of davs so we have a
spattering of state employees throughout
the state so we have some at uh as at
peas as well so it's not just so you
know that business office oversees all
of those state employees and then I have
my three divisions that tag went through
and the division directors will be
speaking the folder handout uh is
wonderful whoever put that together P
pass on our appreciation for that uh
questions for the uh any further
questions for the uh general or the
deputy uh uh this is going to be about
the Navy I know go go ahead
Representative no about the KY 135s no
no I actually thought that that Navy was
going to be beaten by Army because of
the record but we were happy anyway no
my question is U the the
handout got one like this two years
ago is is it the same information or is
it
updated sir it's updated thank you I
mean some of it's similar just like like
the mission or purpose doesn't change
but generally speaking um most of the
handouts are updated to give you a
better like there's QR codes for the
younger generation to like be able to
anything
else uh thank you again uh I know we'll
be seeing you uh probably this afternoon
perhaps we're having a couple of our
first hearings this afternoon and and um
I see Kevin is here and Kevin grade does
a great job uh um representing the the
svac and the military perspectives and
positions on the the issues that and the
bills that we'll be hearing so we won't
hold you up thank you than you again for
being
here okay we're going to jump now right
on time at uh 1000 hours um division of
veteran services I've emailed Bill and
Jamie many times and in uh this is Bill
yes Bill GD uh welcome and and thank you
for the uh the help that you and and and
Jamie and others we thank you uh
we all get requests for uh Service
Officer type help and folks like uh like
bill um are wonderful about uh getting
answers and there are so many potential
questions uh that come up for veterans
so Bill what Bill gdo welcome and um uh
talk to
us thank you very much uh for having me
here uh for the record my name is
William GD I am the director for the New
Hampshire division of veteran services
I I served 30 years active duty in the
Navy retired in
2016 uh was a foreign Communications
intelligence analyst in the Navy and I
thought I was a smart guy until I sat
down to do my first VA claim and
realized I wasn't as smart I thought as
I thought I was and I needed help so I
turned to the office of veteran services
at the time uh Jamie Cummings who's my
number two she was my vsso and after
watching what she did I was like oh my
God that is my calling that's what I
want to do
I started off in the agency as a vsso uh
which I think is invaluable to uh my
position as a director and then shortly
after I got to the agency I became the
director um so what we do at veteran
services uh we we've existed since the
40s so uh Congress established that
every state must have an office that
helps veterans with the process of
filing claims prior to that there was no
assistance uh they could only turn to
lawyers and lawyers charge for their
services so uh Congress has that every
office every state must have an office
to help veterans uh so we came around in
the 40s uh we've been doing this work
for for a number of years we're really
really good at what we do uh when you
look at the VA the VA has three worlds
health care benefits and Cemetery uh on
the healthare side we're not Health Care
Professionals so we let the Health Care
Professionals take care of our veterans
in that world there's the VBA which the
benefit side and of course the cemetery
veterans know how to get to the cemetery
on their own they don't need advocates
to help them there so we focus mostly on
the VBA world now when you look at the
VBA we've got benefits like um the home
loan guarantees voke rehab uh things
like education but in those worlds
you'll have an advocate if you contact a
VA you have questions about home loans
you'll usually have somebody be able to
answer those questions for you and be
able to advocate for you when you start
talking about VA compensation and
pension unfortunately that's where the
advocation drops off there's no
advocates for that work you're filing
claims against the VA they're not going
to tell you how to win those claims so
you need somebody outside of that world
to help you that's why we were
established that's why we're there the
way that we do that as um the general
mentioned we have 10 uh an agency of 10
folks myself Jamie Cummins agency
supervisor seven service officers and a
receptionist uh we do a lot of
uh huge work we do a lot of valuable
work for for our veterans in the State
uh we have about 9,000 active clients
right now and we bring about $100
million into the state through the
pockets of those veterans by helping
them with their VA claims uh so we're
their Advocate through the entire claims
process from start to finish to include
appeals um so we do that through those
seven service officers and those seven
service officers have sites around the
state uh we have a site in Portsmouth we
have a site down in nashwa two service
officers we work out of Manchester uh we
have the veteran service offic in
conquered one in Kean and then we also
service the North Country in Berlin
Conway and
Littleton
so we do all
that we focus most of our efforts on
that but I will tell you uh as as me
members of this
committee um if you have questions about
something that is not claim related uh I
I provided my business card you you can
you can certainly contact me and I'll do
the best that I can to answer the
question uh our title is veteran
services though there are there is a
line in the sand as to what veteran
services we actually provide and what
veteran services we don't provide um and
that kind of get confusing to a lot of
veterans I actually had a gentleman call
me about a month ago asking me for help
with laundry it's really not in the
realm of what our responsibilities I'm
not resourced to help veterans with
laundry services um but I did have a
conversation with them and um I I I did
what I could to assist and that's
basically how I do it so um if you have
questions if you need some assistance
give me a call if there's something we
can assist with there's some resources
that I'm aware of uh I will help direct
you to those so that is me that is
us thank you so much William uh question
um for me to start here involves service
officers uh you know I've been a member
of the the legion and the uh VFW and M
league and a lot of posts have someone
designated as a service officer um some
probably better trained or or uh
knowledgeable than others so these Post
Service officers
do help help us in a sin do they have
anything to do with your office or that
that's just a separate service that the
post provides I appreciate the question
uh no they don't have anything to do
with our office they're usually with
that post so if it's American Legion to
be American Legion that would assist
them so typically I believe the way they
work it we have Paul Lloyd who's a a VFW
member uh I think the way they working
is the Post Service officers take those
claims from the veterans and they bring
them to the National level Service
Officer uh which is located in
Manchester so each of the the three big
names VFW American Legion DAV uh they
work out of the Manchester office on
Chestnut Street uh the same as my office
uh so it gets really really confusing
about the who's who in the zoo when
comes to Veterans claims um it's really
for me it's about who you find to be uh
basically who who who told you to go to
who right so there's a lot of veterans
that use these services and they like
who they speak with so for example John
Barrett with the VFW he's an amazing
Service Officer he's been doing this for
20 years you're not going to go wrong by
talking with with with John so if if
you're recommended to talk to John bar
go talk to John you don't have to go to
the the the state office uh so we all do
the same work we just we just do it
differently but but as as to the
question so those service officers work
for that
organization well again thank you for
what you do there are many veterans many
veterans who never ask for any help
there's a lot of help out there and many
who need it and deserve it never ask for
it never get it and on the other hand
there are some squeaky Wheels let's be
candid a few that uh are asking for help
with their laundry uh and that type of
thing and and I occasionally hear from
some of those and we try to help
everybody but I I know that occasionally
it takes some patience on on your part
to uh to uh explain to some folks what
you can do or should do and can't or or
or whatever so uh hopefully we can
somehow as we communicate with veterans
in our travels uh help them to
understand the ones who need help let
let's encourage them to get help and and
the ones who are looking for other
things to Define what's what's realistic
and reasonable questions uh for William
um we some manal bomb sure uh thank you
Mr chairman
um so I'm reading about this property
tax credit and I see this note that each
City must vote and improve this enabling
legislation is it the city or town
that's
determining what the amount of that tax
credit is or is that set by veterans
Affairs or some other agency and the
city is just voting to allow that tax
credit great question so essentially
there's a minimum and maximum amount and
the towns get to decide where in that
world they're going to be some towns
have gone and opted for the maximum uh
that they can grant sometimes or like
for seven to the up to 750 for the
standard tax credit uh you know there's
a lot of towns that they were given 200
they're given 500 I believe Manchester
has given 500 uh for theirs so it's
really up to the city to decide and a
lot of it they look at it fiscally you
know for every nickel you don't take
from a veteran you got to take from the
the neighbor of a veteran so that's just
the way they look at it all right thank
you I've got a quick question about that
um so do you guys have anywhere where
there's like a compiled list online
through I don't know one of your
websites or anything like that where a
veteran can go and see like if their
specific area has this credit or is it
they do they need to just go to their
local website or whatever and look
there's um thank you for the question so
the Department of Revenue Administration
the ra has a website and on their
website they do have a spreadsheet uh
they do have an Excel spreadsheet that
that talks about each City where they're
what where they are and all the tax
credits okay great thank
you anything
else to representative mandle bomb's
question uh she mentioned the property
tax credit there are is is Kevin
probably knows there there are several
measures in the house this term related
to property tax credits there's a couple
of them one of which I was asked to help
with um to get in the mix that have to
do with 100% disabled veterans and
there's a lot of confusion about what
that means uh not not that we need to
get into it here other than to follow up
on representative mandal bomb's question
in terms of veterans tax credits what's
out there and for those that are
watching at home or are we'll be
watching later the enabling
legislation uh that has been passed that
is in the mix right now enabling means
that should the legislature pass uh a
tax credit option for communities the
communities don't have to give veterans
a tax credit if we pass something uh
what we do in in there limits is it the
uh the segment that reps of manal bom
referred to uh eligible for a tax credit
of 50 to 750 on residential property
taxes so enabling means the community
can decide if they want to do that at
all and if if so uh how much uh of a tax
CED up to 750 do they want to give and
the uh the 100% disabled thing I'm not
going to get into here other committees
have heard and will hear that um but uh
that is something that this legisl this
term is going has already started and
will be addressing and talking about is
is property tax
credits all right William thank you so
much thank you for all you do thanks for
coming in here and we have your card I
already had your email I you hear for me
from time to time I'm usually passing on
requests that you're much more qualified
answer than I am so thanks for all you
do appreciate it thank
you okay
uh 10 15 and we have Sean Buck was here
early today from the
wonderful wonderful Veteran Cemetery
I've been there many times um it's
incredibly beautiful if any if anybody
has never been there they should go um
my brother is there and uh anyway uh
Sean welcome and
um uh tell us about the wonderful New
Hampshire Veteran Cemetery you stole my
thunder a little I was going to ask if
is anybody who has not been to the
Veteran
Cemetery oh okay I highly recommend that
you come and visit us it's up in bosin
it's a gem for the State of New
Hampshire it truly is uh the staff at
the cemetery I'm blessed to work with a
really a bunch of amazing folks I'll
keep it pretty short for your
constituents the most important thing is
if they're a veteran they can they
should apply and if they've ever served
in the military should apply I it would
bother me if somebody self selects out
like oh I'm not sure that if I'm
eligible let us make that determination
in all likelihood if you've served in
the military you are probably eligible
as long as you don't have a dishonorable
discharge in New Hampshire we passed in
2022 the burial equity for guards and
reserves act which means members who
previously were not eligible meaning
they served in the National Guard or the
reserve component but were never
activated or did not retire they would
not have been eligible previously but
now they can be eligible and new
Hampshire is one of the first States uh
shout out to our legislative Folks at
the federal level who really pushed hard
to get that passed um we've buried as of
last month exactly 100 folks under the
burial Equity guard for guard and
reserves act so for your constituents
encourage them to apply I run around the
state quite a bit and I I give a lot of
presentations in various locations and
various clubs I want it's the most
important thing for me is to for
veterans to know that this is a benefit
they've earned as a retiree I retired
into 20 2008 after 21 years of active
duty I never thought about my burial and
that this was a benefit that I earned um
it's just not something that we like to
think about so encourage folks the
Veteran Cemetery is not a sad place it's
an awesome place it's an honorable place
it's a great place to come and visit and
reflect and honor those who serve so
encourage people to apply and also by
the way in case you're wondering
dependants are also eligible for
interment at the Veteran Cemetery so uh
a spouse or a dependent children not any
child but a dependent child is also
eligible so four
things apply visit encourage your
constituents this is their Veteran
Cemetery this is a a place of Pride for
the State of New Hampshire encourage
folks to visit and walk around learn
I've I handed out a couple of brochures
this is one of them it's a visitor's
guide this is kind of this has the whole
deal about this got an application in it
it's got all the information on the
cemetery this is a visitors guide we we
host schools and classrooms all the time
we want folks to learn about New
Hampshire military history the the
veterans Heritage Learning Center is on
the back of the administration building
at the Veteran Cemetery it has got all
kinds of tidbits and history and
interactive displays to learn about New
Hampshire military history and it's
focused on New Hampshire military
history we also have an amazing Memorial
walkway with mon over 100 monuments and
benches and things like that honoring
New Hampshire veterans
and then lastly volunteer we have a ton
of volunteer opportunities we are always
looking for young people to come up we
have started a program called stories of
service where we're trying to tell the
story of every veteran buried at the New
Hampshire State Veteran Cemetery over
17,600 are interred there since we
opened in November of 1997 was our first
uh burial so we've up to as of right now
we're up to 150 stories of service and
we're looking for high school kids or
people that want to do community service
come and learn and research and make a
little video so that we can post it on
our on our website stories about people
from your community we actually have a
person from uh NASA who's actually
written tons of stories about New
Hampshire veterans um that are from new
NASA and are buried at their Veteran
Cemetery not all are buried at the
cemetery we want the story of any New
Hampshire veteran so that's us in a
nutshell it's an awesome awesome place
and I hope that you'll come and visit
often for your also um events Memorial
Day I would recommend you come we do our
veterans our Memorial Day ceremony on
May 30th always on May 30th at 11:00
a.m. and you're all cordially invited
and you will be recognized as such we
have wreaths for bosin is Al always the
first Saturday of December at 10:30 in
the morning we will put out wreaths on
the graves that's always a huge um event
and then we do the 100 nights of
remembrance which is we play Taps every
night from Memorial Day till 9:11 at
7:00 p.m. so volunteers play come and
play Taps at 7:00 p.m.
the rest of the year after 911 until the
next Memorial Day we play every Sunday
at 1:00 so you can come to any of those
and we have other events to feel free to
reach out I'm open to your questions
thanks for having
me I very much support the traditional
May 30th day for recognizing U uh those
that we've lost uh because I'm a
traditionalist and it's also my birthday
May 30th and I so I certainly support
that and that you mentioned the history
I mentioned earlier being a history
person the history there in the walkway
but those uh those pillars or those
monuments with uh the go going way back
to Colonial times uh how how many of
those are there
that it's 20 pillars um and it starts
from the founding of the militia all the
way through to the global war on terror
and they are right on the circle of
flags are the 20 pillars you can also
find a lot of that same information
inside the veterans Heritage Learning
Center um so yeah it's uh there's a to
learn and the other the other one that
people Overlook is the Gettysburg
Address is posted it's right in the
middle of the we have a little island in
the center of the cemetery and that
Gettysburg addresses at every Veteran
Cemetery throughout the country it's uh
powerful and you've spoken also once as
a guest speaker at the Memorial Day
ceremony or Veterans Day I can't
remember which one it was it was May
30th it was my birthday and and my
mother was there and some Navy people
gave me a cake afterwards and now you'll
never forget that so uh questions uh yes
repres the representative from NASA or
Manchester Manchester Sor Manchester yes
uh first of all thank you for your
service sir uh my question is if I want
to come next week do I have to make an
appointment or would there be anyone who
could tour me give a story anything like
that thank you sir for the question we
are open uh Monday through Friday 8:00
a.m to 400 p.m. I'm almost always there
um uh you can contact us on that on the
brochure I handed out you can send us an
email or give us a call if you want to
make an appointment I would be happy to
give you a tour um anytime anybody
anytime you're up you can make plan or
not if I'm there I'll I'll stop whatever
I'm doing and give you a tour because
it's important what we do there is
important there's a lot to learn and I
can get it done in it won't take out
your whole
day please do come thank
you representative
Foss I thank you so much for your
presentation I've marked on my legal pad
to look for volunteer opportunities and
then to plan on being there Memorial Day
uh so looking at the map here um
Memorial Graves for individ uh people
whose remains are located elsewhere
would that include people who were you
know buried in another state but still
served in New
Hampshire that's a good question no it's
a memorial the memorial section is for
folks whose remains were lost at sea or
been scattered and they cannot be
memorialized any place else so so when a
when a veteran passes their entitled to
a flag military honors and a grave
marker yeah um so the memorial section
is for example we have a state employee
whose uh ex-spouse was killed at C and
that remains never recovered so there's
you uh repal
bomb thank you Mr chairman um so just I
have a clarifying question about the
application process can spouses or or
dependence of someone who served who's
passed away apply on their
behalf absolutely so believe it or not
spouses are eligible even if the veteran
chooses not to come the spouse as long
as they're married to the veteran at the
time of either one of their passing the
spouse is eligible they've earned their
way in by being a spouse of a veteran so
uh they can apply on behalf of the
veteran we all we have uh Powers of
Attorney as long as we get the proper
paperwork and the remains we can get
that taken care of thank
you quick personal comment there was
recently a veteran who passed away a
World War II veteran um and he had no
family he had uh nobody and so the he
was obviously eligible to be buried at
the state Veteran Cemetery so the word
went out for the veterans community that
this uh this individual had had nobody
no no family uh for whatever reasons I
think he was over 100 years old so uh
there were a couple hundred veterans who
showed up at his ceremony uh including
myself and um just a wonderful example
of uh how you folks could accommodate a
sudden uh what do you call it a flash
mob is that kind of that type of you
suddenly 200 people show up at a u in
the in the to handle all those vehicles
uh was was wonderful I have I do have
one question it has to do with capacity
and expansion um how much room uh do you
have are you are you good for for quite
a while or what's how's that look two
things I forgot to cover that so first
of all regarding uh unaccompanied
remains it actually happens more often
than you think probably about twice a
month we get unaccompanied remains
delivered to the cemetery we do have a
group you can find it on our website
it's called standing with falling
comrades we have about 300 folks on that
list so if I'm given any kind of warning
I'll send out an email to that group we
never bury anybody alone so at a minimum
myself my staff will go out to be with
those remains and the military always
does honors we they never take shortcuts
they fold the flag they play Taps
everybody gets honors um but that's
standing with falling comrades that that
one that you're talking about Sir that
one was done by the folks I think it was
a uh VFW or American Legion Post down in
Brookline or something that got it on
the news and things got a couple hundred
folks showed up not just veterans just
friends of veterans and it was an
awesome service but we do those pretty
frequently regarding space we have
plenty of room at least another 80 years
of space we're actually currently
starting in fact on the 29th of this
month we will break ground a $5.3
million expansion which will put in a
little over 3200 columbarium Niche
spaces and a little over 4200 inground
cremation spaces we do about 80% of our
burials are cremation burials we offer
full casket inground cremation and
columbarium Niche Wall burials um but
about in New Hampshire it's about 80% it
doesn't matter to us oh by the way
there's no cost for a veteran to be
buried at the New Hampshire State
veteran SE it's a it's a benefit that
they've earned so this $5.3 million
expansion is starting it's paid for by
the federal government through the
Veteran Cemetery grants program um but
yeah we have plenty of room we have uh
60 acres of developable land and we've
only developed about 19 so um and as and
as long as the trend for cremation
continues to go the direction it's about
last year it's about 81%
will last even longer than the 80 years
that I projected out I would say we're
probably good for another hundred years
at
least well that's a comfort because I
have a reservation there and I uh I I
don't want to I don't want to I think it
sounds like I'll be fine anything else
for for Sean uh yes representative uh
from
Manchester thank you Mr chairman uh just
a I'm the humor guy I guess
it's not a sad thing to inter your loved
ones in that Cemetery it's unbelievably
peaceful I've done it a couple of times
will War I people and and some from my
generation uh my wife and I a couple
years ago if I remember right we just we
signed up online uh we sign in person we
went there in person and signed up with
my DD214 and all that and we decided to
just walk around a little bit and just
and
if I remember correctly somebody kept
their sense of humor to the very end on
the little plate where there's right
this it it's it's quoted as saying that
the dying individuals said I told you I
was sick and that
was we both cracked up in the cemetery
we just were laughing our heads off yeah
there are a lot of those actually I walk
around and read those quite a bit a
couple things I'll encourage um first of
all come to a of military honors at the
Veteran Cemetery whether you know the
individual or not it's powerful and to
your point it's not sad it's Noble and
honorable and I you're going to hear
from the comedon at the veterans home
yesterday I was really privileged to go
to their final salute and I'm sure
she'll talk about I don't want to steal
her Thunder but that was powerful as
well um and so I encourage you I know
you're busy but it you'll feel renewed
and refreshed in in many ways if you
come to a service also will be on time I
was late for one just at the very end
and they were all already doing Taps we
run a military operation sir we start on
time yes that is true people need to
know that the uh Veteran Cemetery is on
a schedule and they keep to it and that
is impressive um and as I said before um
there are there will be CU I check uh
depends on what the bill is or whatever
but there are always several hundred
people who are watching or or you can on
YouTube you know 250 people of once so
those other folks who obviously aren't
here um I know we have at least a couple
several members of the committee who
have not been to the Veteran Cemetery so
those folks watching at home uh the uh
director Buck uh welcomes you to come
and visit and and it sounds like you
encourage that quite
clearly I love it I've been called
loquacious and I will talk to them about
the uh Veteran Cemetery and be
respectful of their time but please do
come
and Epitaph I think is the word that uh
represent gy was referring to and I I I
I love cemeteries because I'm a history
guy I used to live in Campton there's a
cemetery there with there Civil War
veterans and and uh now my my my
brother's Monument is a little Epitaph
and uh or the words that that are there
forever and uh wonderful to see uh thank
you Sean really appreciate your time uh
yes uh represent
Rollins thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to comment that your cemetery is
absolutely Immaculate I I I tell
everybody when I talk about it I said
it's like a mini Arlington you you'll
never go to a place more hering than
that place with a quick qu it's awesome
quick question is could you tell us
briefly a little bit about the memorial
walkway
so so the memorial walkway sponsored by
the New Hampshire Veteran Cemetery
Association so that's a 501 1c3 that
raises money on behalf of the Veteran
Cemetery and what it is it winds through
the woods right there at the veteran
Cemetary it is meant to honor veterans
from various conflicts groups uh
organizations and it uh it's all private
it's all money that is raised privately
it's either through donations to the
association or through other private
means uh The Monuments are built and
then donated to the state um so that the
monuments then become State Property so
it's just a uh
you have to come check it out I mean
it's hard to it's hard to explain it's
over a lot of benches and it's got a the
Air Force Monument for example is a 17th
uh replica of what's at the Pentagon uh
there's an army Monument that's got
pictures of New Hampshire veterans it's
just uh it's awesome and and thank you
for all the great comments we really are
we're
grateful represent
Jones Thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here um just a quick question
do you honor family special requests or
uh religious traditions for instance if
somebody didn't want to use a
vault
or we all we stay within the confines of
the rules and regulations but we always
do our best to honor so for example we
had a a Muslim burial and they um they
they require specific things with the
Imam and we did honor that so for
example with the Vault for some Jew in
the Jewish faith as well as the the
Muslim faith the the remains have to be
on the ground um not on the concrete of
a vault and we do allow for that um we
sometimes will the Vault will be turned
upside down so the remains are on the
ground and then the Vault so we don't
allow for the remains to not be covered
but we do make compromises to allow for
them so for example in the Jewish face
sometimes they'll go to the pre-placed
vaults and we'll put dirt on the ground
inside the Vault some for some of them
that suffices um but to answer your
question we will do what we can to honor
that veteran to their religious
Traditions thank you very
good thank you Mr chairman um I just
want to say I want to steal a page out
of Larry's comedy book that I do appre
first of all I do appreciate being let
in when we do the ree at Christmas time
uh because I do have a handicapped
veteran that I have to get in there he
can't walk very far and I just want to
make a promise to you that I will never
Park in the ambulance parking spot again
okay yeah I got tuned up don't be doing
that with legislator plates
representative Rollins PE that always
there's always a picture taken thank you
so much
Sean okay uh Kevin Grady is in the house
you saw him there he is
uh legislative liaison for Veterans
Affairs and has been here uh numerous
times before does does a great job
tracking legislation of which there's a
lot uh so uh welcome back uh
Kevin uh thank you Mr chairman um with
your permission we'd like to to go
together because I'm sort of an offshoot
of the state veterans advisory committee
so we can wrap this whole thing up in in
probably 101 15 minutes and then that
way you can get back on on track and
that way if you want to do military
Community Based or Community Based
military programs again is that Leo
pacquin of the the head of esvac yes I
was at your meeting recently in fact I'm
gonna I'm going to let him start with
kind of the overview and then I'll just
sort of chime in at the end with what we
do and a little bit about myself go
ahead sir sure sure why don't you both
just uh lay it on us however you want
all right and then we may have questions
so little background on me I served in
the 82nd Airborne uh in Army
intelligence and then uh in the reserves
down at Fort devans I lived about two
miles from skip uh I'm sorry
representative Rollins for 20 plus years
uh and uh um Newport I now live in
Penacook um I have a bachelor's degree
in Business Administration and I have a
master's MBA in international business
um veteran service side I'm the
immediate past uh State Commander for
the American Legion um I'm an insurance
guy I have a property casualty firm in
in Franklin so that's pretty much about
me um esvac State veterans advisory
committee where the volunteers that's
why you don't have any shiny cool
handouts um well yeah kind of yeah um so
we were established by RSA um uh
115-a 8 in 2002 it it compies of uh two
state senators um that are appointed by
the president of the Senate and two
state representatives appointed by the
speaker of the house um it started off
with uh 10 uh various veterans
organizations as members that the majors
you know the American Legion DAV and um
uh VFW um it increased to 14 in 2007 and
now in 2009 it got brought up 20 but
it's capped at 20 um however we do
encourage every New Hampshire veteran
service organization or any State uh
stakeholder to show up to meetings and
and most of a lot of them do uh our
primary focus is to provide a common
voice for the 90 plus thousand uh New
Hampshire veterans and their families um
I usually tell people on the coordinator
opinions I'm not really the opinion
Setter but I coordinate the opinions of
all the veteran service organizations so
we're all on the same page um we our
primary focus is legislation especially
in the state of New Hampshire we highly
encourage you to reach out to us for
proper nomenclature is a big a big deal
but legislation or even policy changes
we give veteran Healthcare updates and
we schedule events uh and we brief on
scheduled events for benefit uh veterans
uh leaderships from the state agencies
that are all sitting behind me except
for Kevin because he he got uh deployed
to Massachusetts um provide uh they
provide advice and briefings on theirs I
I will tell you you have an outstanding
team in the state of New Hampshire
uh every single person uh Deputy tag to
tag uh davs uh common out of the New
Hampshire Veterans Home my friend Kim
McKay uh director VA Medical Center
which is Kevin Forest who can be here
today and director of New Hampshire
State Cemetery Sean Sean does an
excellent job and please go please go
check it out um and also the state
veteran C Council uh Jim Adams um a sign
a significant number of advisers guests
and representative from Congressional
Delegation also participate so both both
National Senator or members of Congress
basically and there either they or their
representatives show up and brief us on
uh Federal bills that are going on or
things that they're doing at the federal
level which gives us a good Avenue um to
Congress um which works out pretty good
um we continue to work with the members
of New Hampshire State uh state house
and the Senate um we we are here to
support and testify on agendas for
legislative action on behalf of the
veterans again we I coordinate the
opinions a lot of times we do
legislative stuff this healthy
discussion usually it's about an
unanimous whether we support um uh
follow or um oppose a bill um but a lot
of discussion good discussion it's all
technical not emotional so that works
out pretty of course there is some
emotional discussion because you can't
have a a quorum without that but uh
mostly it's a technical uh we highly
encourage uh uh to swing by and have
this review Bill language that's what
Kevin excellent at um during the filing
period like uh you represented of Mafia
had mentioned something about the 100%
veteran cuz the 100% disabled veteran
they're not the same as they totally
disab if if you're gainfully employable
at 100% rating doesn't mean that you're
the same thing as a 100% veteran who
can't you know had a traumatic brain
injury or something it can't work um
hopefully we can avoid unintended
consequences because everything that
happens in the world has a cause and
effect so sometimes the spirit of the
bills always seem very good um sometimes
the nomeclature inside there are the
definitions just need a little bit of
help so that's why we're here um
committee we encourage all invitees and
legislators especially the prime
sponsors any veteran related Bill to
participate and exchange views with the
members of the svac and uh developing
positions on matters important to those
veterans sorry to read to you but I
forget what I'm going to say if I don't
you okay I'll jump in with with my
portion here uh a little bit a little
bit about me uh uh like Colonel just
like Bixler I'm I'm also an Air Force
Academy grad looking forward to going
back this fall uh to my 50th year
reunion uh to see a bunch of people that
I've I've known my whole life and uh
spent most of my time in the Air Force
as a fighter pilot flying the F-15 see I
did have one tour for two years eight
months and 17 days with the US Army at
Fort Hood Texas working with the first
Cavalry division um and I spent my last
assignment in the Air Force sitting on a
big on a staff on a big steel desk in in
Ramstein Germany and if you want to ask
a fighter pilot to sit behind a desk the
only thing that matters is the location
of the desk okay I'd rather be the snow
removal officer in Europe than the chief
of staff and the Pentagon um so I I when
I retired from the Air Force I actually
flew uh 737s for United for about five
and a half years got tired of being gone
all the time so I started up The Air
Force Junior RC program down at alurn
high school and I taught there for 11
years and finally retired in 2014 and
I'm failing miserably at retiring okay
the the cautionary tale for retirement
is is that work does expand to fill the
time allotted for it it's one of those
Murphy's Law Coral are so um one of the
things I do and I literally inherited
this job when the guy before me passed
away the guy before me was from my
organization uh the air force uh now the
air and space forces Association a guy
named ed Josephson and some of you maybe
have been around a little while might
remember Ed Ed was one of the original
class of 1959 grads was really
knowledgeable about this and when he
passed away in 2016 they said would you
take on this legislative thing and I
said well okay I'll do that and I've
been I've been doing it ever since this
is my ninth uh session rolling through
here um we have uh 17 bills that we're
following this this go around that have
some measure of Veteran impact some of
it's kind of obscure like we look at
like a there's a a licensed dietician
comp compact but there's a little
section in there that says you know that
applies to Military and applies to
military spouses so we're you know we're
going to go uh testify on that one of
the things that I've always tried to
tell people when I when I testify is
that number one I represent 20
organizations okay and and sometimes
what I tell you is not necessarily my
personal opinion but it's their opinion
and I think that's what you need to know
is it's their opinion and I also tell
them that and and and general molus
alluded to this a little bit earlier
you know we believe that when one of us
serves the whole family serves so things
that we can do for spouses and families
we are all over trying to help out with
with those kinds of things and the last
thing is I can't be in a position where
every time that I see you I've got my
hand out looking for money okay we are
taxpayers too we have to be cognizant of
the fact that every time you give a tax
break to a veteran somebody else has to
make up the slack for that in the in the
community Okay so we we pick and choose
this very carefully and sometimes you
look and we might oppose like a property
tax increase we might oppose that by
just saying you know we're we're our our
civilian counterparts are already paying
their fair share all right let's let's
try and keep this uh uh reel here uh the
last thing that I'll tell you is we I've
been involved in this for a while and
and one of the real success stories we
have and I I want to just tell you the
story because you probably wouldn't hear
it any other place um when Governor
sonunu first became the governor uh he
came and and and visited one of our svac
meetings and talked to some folks and at
the end of it he posed a question that
we could not answer and that question
was if I have a veteran who has an issue
where do I send
him and we all looked around at each
other and went well you know the answer
is probably in this room somewhere but
you know there's not one single agency
and that's why we have the department of
military Affairs and vet services today
we started the legislative process we
had a guy some of you may remember named
Al Bal balero that worked this problem
very hard uh we had to get past the uh
uh the previous chair of this committee
uh Colonel Russ over um you know he he
had specific feelings about how this
needed to go but what we have now we
think is great but you will see things
like for example House Bill 120 uh
transferring to statute author uh and
will hear this bill in this committee
the statutory Authority from uh
Department of Education to the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services for uh dependent
children educational support issues
those kind of things what these are
you'll see some of these in the next
session or two we're cleaning up trying
to still find those places out there
that belong under dmabs that that aren't
there yet and we want to we want to get
them there okay so you you'll see that
we do some of this I I look forward to
uh to testify for you I'm I'm I'm pretty
Frank I have I have some opinions some
of the bills particularly some of the
ones we're going to hear today have a
long history and uh I've been associated
with that history so uh I will I will
stop talking and I'll I'll talk more
this afternoon but uh I'll pass that
back to my
Chester thank you so much um I'm sure I
can find this online but just in the
interest of getting it into my calendar
ASAP when's the next meeting I can go to
do you know off the top of your head
yeah it's the first Tuesday of each
month at 500 P p.m. thank
you and it's at the cross training
center in
pimbrook very well-run meeting oh thank
you bang bang
bang other questions uh Ron Rollins
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question yeah um what are the
20 there's 20 I believe 20
organizations that comprise CAC right
representative I'm glad you asked that
question we have a hand out we have a
hand out for
that do you have it or do I have it I
have it oh I'm sorry I I don't have time
to look at a hand out my apology oh no
we we have a handout for that now that
has our committee members and got I'll
give you a copy but if you want me to
read through it representative Rollins
i' do it real quick if you could read
through because people watch watchingg
would be won't be able to see the hand
out okay uh Air Force Association Air
Force Sergeant Association the American
Legion the a USA uh Catholic War
veterans combat Veterans Motorcycle
Association Disabled American Veterans
Korean War veterans association Marine
Corps League military office Association
of America uh military order of the
Purple Heart National Guard Association
of New Hampshire New Hampshire Army
retiree
Council uh uh New Hampshire National
Guard en listed Association and New
Hampshire veterans association uh uh
Camp resilient Patriot resilient
leadership in Institute uh Reserve
Officers Association Rolling Thunder uh
Veterans of Foreign Wars and the Vietnam
20 representative from Manchester
representative gagy thank you all all
these Services is there a phone number
that we could uh if if somebody would to
call me and say I've got a problem and I
would want to send them to one of those
organizations is there a phone number
that we can give them uh we don't again
we're volunteer organization we have no
budget but we do have a an email address
that works pretty well uh to get to me I
have my personal uh cell phone that I
use but I'd rather not say it on TV hear
that um but yes okay thank you yeah and
we do get some interesting emails and
questions and there's some people we can
help and some people that you know
sometimes it's like this not really
under our purview but I we the nice
thing about having a common voice is we
to
else great job thank you we'll see I I
guess some of you this afternoon at our
first
hearings
okay okay uh we're 13 minutes ahead of
schedule but I I think Julie I saw Julie
okay sure if you could just hit the make
sure the and then uh let everybody know
who you are and and where you're from
and who you repr presenting uh
absolutely Mr chair and committee
members uh for the record Brent Frasier
director of the community based military
programs is part of the Department of
military Affairs and veteran services uh
retired army veteran 25 plus years uh
for uh operational combat deployments
originally uh born and raised in New
Hampshire uh after the Army did about
six plus years in the department of the
army civilian in Virginia and then
returned back about a year and a half
ago and I'm now living in sanwi it's
great to be back in New Hampshire uh so
um in terms of uh the opportunity today
to talk about Community Based military
programs our mission uh is the tag
talked about earlier in the folder that
you have uh it outlines what our mission
is it's essentially to collaborate with
military and civilian providers veteran
service and support organizations
nonprofits uh and businesses federal
state regional and local leaders and
subject matter experts really
stakeholders from across all domains and
sectors uh and developing Partnerships
to get after development of
operationalizing approaches and
solutions to improve Granite State
service members veterans and their
families and as a couple of uh people
have already testified this morning it's
the service member veterans and their
family members uh we're not a large
organization we've got uh six full-time
employees uh and they're focus on
developing team of Team approaches
because it's not something that we can
do alone it's a a team sport uh as we
get after a number of different lines of
effort that include employment housing
stability well-being uh both physical
and mental health uh the mental health
side including Suicide Prevention uh the
New Hampshire asked the question uh
program um housing stability ending
veteran
homelessness um military skills transfer
licensing
certification uh and training as well as
the educational benefits that uh uh Mr
Grady touched on in term terms of the
upcoming bill as we transition uh those
efforts from the Department of Education
to to davs as well as some efforts in
support of Justice involved veterans
some of our Key Programs include the
ending veteran homelessness in New
Hampshire project the New Hampshire
asked the question campaign as I alluded
to uh the New Hampshire veteran friendly
business network uh that the tag
outlined uh supporting mental health
initiatives access to mental health
reducing social isolation uh through
Partnerships with the Veterans Affairs
largely uh the VA Manchester healthc
care system and partnership for public
health uh as we work to establish uh
maintain and grow the the coalitions the
regional veterans coalitions across the
state and also uh the support to Easter
Seals New Hampshire uh and their
veterans count effort uh in in
Manchester uh the New Hampshire veterans
freedom to smile initiative uh the GI
Bill educational benefits that we talked
about raising awareness and facilitating
navigation as we're able to benefits
earned by service members veterans and
their family it's come up a couple times
in terms of who do I call is there
someplace on a website is there a QR
code that I can perhaps look at how do I
follow and track and understand and have
a good common operational picture of
what services and and support systems
are available for veterans and that's
something that we try to facilitate
today's agenda highlights just a few of
these programs initiatives but certainly
standing by to to talk about any
questions that you might have uh in
terms of of any of those areas uh and so
uh while I had uh planned on talking
about some uh in more detail uh they are
outlined uh in in the folder that you
have in terms of uh veteran friendly
business uh network uh mental health
Suicide Prevention uh ending veteran
homelessness so if if there are any uh
questions that you might have prepared
to talk about those either now or in the
future and and look forward to working
with this committee thank you Mr Fraser
and from my notes I just want to make
sure I have the correct title of your
organization if you could say that one
more time no absolutely sir it's
division of community-based military
programs
yeah yes thank you I have uh I'm looking
at all the uh members and and the pieces
of this and uh I was more familiar with
esvac uh than the Division of Community
Based
military uh
programs so the
information would you be the best
contact person uh for this organization
or for Community Based military programs
uh absolutely um we at work with uh the
the state veterans advisory committee as
well as the state veterans Council uh as
part of our uh military civilian uh
collaborative and if I could get maybe a
card before uh before you leave just
pass that up that would be great I want
to make sure I have uh have this in the
fil along with everything else if you
look in the file somebody talked about
it there's a a QR code uh card that
lists most of our programs and
initiative as well a lot of the programs
and initiatives of the the people we
collaborate with whether it's New
Hampshire employment security on veteran
friendly business or the office of
professional LIC insure and
certification on some of our uh military
skills transitions uh Department of
Health and Human Services as we work to
integrate veterans efforts into New
Hampshire Care Connections and a lot of
great Partners on there as I said we've
only got six full-time employees and so
a lot of the work that we do is is part
of team a team approaches and
collaborations of the Willing on behalf
of veterans
well this this is great thank you for
this I from what I had from last year I
didn't have this part or this uh this
hand out from from your organization so
this is a I'm looking at the resources
and the people and and um want to make
sure I get you know fully familiar with
who you are and where you are and what
Fraser all right well so glad you're
here thanks for leaving this off uh
inbound um members uh one
clarification uh the biggest thing you
get to know for your constituents is
Google NHD
Mavs not Dallas Mavericks NHD Mavs no
I'm serious it we have an up-to-date
modern website uh it's it's a good thing
for state government but no seriously
though um if you have a veteran
constituent
and you need to inform them to try to
get services or some um support that
they need NHD mass will generally get
you to the right website with the right
phone number to contact the appropriate
sort of entity within our portfolio that
they should get their services that they
need is that
dmas or
ma uh n 5 gun is going off my years back
long time ago uh D Mavs Department of
military Affairs and Services New
Hampshire NHD Mavs
General great thank you for that and I
will be Googling it I'm a sports guy I
can remember DMs I think representative
gagy is from C Canada
and
okay that brings us to uh 1055 and yes
Julie uh do you mind starting five
good last term Kevin for or two years
ago Kevin Forest the head of the
Manchester VA or the the best way it's
correct and Julie Vos uh you can confirm
your title and uh we're we're so glad
you're
here and if you could hit that
yeah good morning is that better yes it
is hi I'm Julie Vose uh my permanent
role at the Manchester VA uh Healthcare
System as the associate director I work
alongside uh Mr Kevin Forest our
director who is currently detailed uh
and so I am here representing our
Medical Center and um I did want to um
uh introduce myself I've been at the
Manchester vas uh for 25 years now I am
an occupational therapist by trade and
had the honor of serving and and
providing clinical care to our New
Hampshire veterans in the rehab medicine
Department uh for quite some time before
transitioning to our administrative
offices so um certainly consider it uh
my view VA uh despite myself not being a
veteran so uh for all the all of you who
are veterans who receive Care at R VA I
thank you for entrusting us with that um
it is an honor and um we certainly have
a great staff that is there for the
mission every day um with that if I
could it might be a bit unorthodox but
um this came across my desk yesterday
it's a testimonial from a a daughter and
so if I could take two minutes and share
this with you all
was worth it so um my name is Lori my
father is an 88-year-old veteran I
recently had the honor of accompanying
my father to the VA Manchester Medical
Center he had been bragging about the
wonderful people and the services at the
VA I had to see it for myself to be a
second set of ears when speaking with
the doctors and nurses so I went with
him for the first time this past
November it became apparent to me the
minute we entered the VA that it was a
very special place when I first arrived
my dad was already in a wheelchair with
a very kind gentleman waiting to take
him anywhere he needed to go the people
at the information booth greeted us and
smiled
brightly on this visit my father was
meeting his primary care doctor for the
first time to check in with him after
having been in the hospital for a few
days we first met with Jacqueline
Blackman RN she was professional but
also very kind listened intently to his
stories which I believed he had told her
before and made my made me feel that I
should be there and was pleased I was
getting involved in my Dad's health care
we were then introduced to his new
doctor Dr Martina derva I was blown away
when she talked about her credentials
and did her very best to sell herself to
us most doctors that I have dealt with
have made me feel as if I am lucky that
they were willing to take me on as a
patient this was a wonderful change she
then went through his medical records
discerned how he has been doing now and
what needed to be done next she made
sure that all of his and my questions
were answered we never felt rushed or
that we were number I have never been so
impressed all my fears for my father's
healthc care vanished that day at
another appointment this week we again
meet with many Fantastic employees of
this VA one of them was nurse Lauren
Crowley LPN just like Miss Blackman she
was professional very kind and very
understanding obviously this is not the
norm for this facility this is the norm
for this facility not a rarity every
single person we encountered throughout
the VA was a pleasure to talk to
everyone from the minute you Walkin the
check-in and out Ladies as well as the
volunteers have been wonderful and on
one visit we got turned around and got
lost but we met a gentleman in the
hallway who worked there but was not
part of the medical team and he couldn't
do enough to help us find where we
needed to go you don't find that
everywhere my father loves to laugh and
he does that a lot when we are
here
so this type of experience is really
what we feel um our Medical Center does
well um providing great great healthare
care is a must but providing it with
fabulous customer service and respect is
um really what we embody at the
Manchester VA so I just I this came
across so timely um just two days ago
and so I said I've got to bring that and
share um with you all so thank you for
allowing me to take a couple minutes
extra um I do have um some information I
can share with you to orient you to the
services we have at Manchester uh the VA
overview page is just uh a review of
what our mission statement is probably
not new to you in the room to fulfill
President Lincoln's promise to care for
those who have served our nation's
military and for their families
caregivers and
survivors as some of our um uh previous
presenters shared uh the VA does have uh
several branches and so um in order to
fulfill the priorities of the VA which
are providing all veterans timely
worldclass Healthcare ensuring veterans
and their families have access to the
benefits they've earned and honoring our
veterans with a final resting place
that's a lasting tribute to their
service so collectively as a VA on the
VA overview um number two page uh we can
see that the VA is a very large
organization and we are at the
healthcare um at the healthc Care Center
uh one of three Partners to um provide
priority provide successful uh
achievement of the priorities that I
we have uh great uh collaboration
throughout visin one so we are part of
the network of vas that uh service the
whole New England area and if you um
look at one of these uh pages that are
the on the VA overview section you'll
see uh uh pictoral representations of
each site uh one of the comments that I
have later to share with you is
regarding our development and just
ongoing growth of our clinical resource
Hub which is really a fabulous uh
integration of specialty care throughout
New England um utilizing uh CVT VVC
telea Health technology uh we have
Specialty Care providers that are you
know from institutions throughout uh New
Hampshire um medical medical areas that
um you just don't have uh all in the
state of New Hampshire but we're able to
access them through our Integrated
the vision uh uh vision statement is to
be the premier integrated academic
healthc care system in New England and a
highly engaged team providing
serve I included our uh permanent
leadership team uh many of you have uh
worked with Mr Kevin Forest a veteran
himself who is our Medical Center
Director our our chief of staff is Dr
Robert zolak he is a vascular surgeon
and prior to his role as Chief of Staff
he was our chief of surgery Miss Winslow
Jennifer Winslow is our nurse executive
she has been um within the VA system for
uh with with some longevity as well um
maybe 12 or plus years pre previously
our patient safety manager and last but
not least we have our chief of quality
Goodrich we really try to instill our
expectations for um great customer
service at the onset of all of our new
employees as they Orient in in um
onboarding um and really we share what
our intent is as a leadership team and
that is to do the simple things well um
you know in a government agency of
course we're going to follow the rules
but we're going to also um make
decisions that make sense for the
patient um and take care of each other
take care of them um and just
communicate in many different um many
different forms because communication is
uh just key for um uh running a Health
Care system that is of um uh high
quality
so our values and uh philosophy we we
call them the ey care values Integrity
commitment advocacy respect and
Excellence uh all of our staff if you uh
run into them in the hallway can
probably tell you about these um we we
really empower our staff to make
decisions at the Frontline level and and
tell them if you're if you feel that you
need to follow your gut and your gut is
in alignment with these values there are
there are rarely times you will go wrong
so um we really we talk about ey care
values a lot in our um leadership um
meetings and and working with
staff on the location section for those
of you who aren't familiar with all the
different sites where we provide care in
New Hampshire so in Manchester we
actually have two Loc s the main
location that most are most familiar
with um the main campus although it's
looking different these days we've had
over the past 5 years new additions and
um taken down older buildings to get
ready for more new additions and more
parking um but second to that we also
have what we're calling the Manchester
West VA Clinic which has a wellness
center for veterans um housed within it
uh the Manchester VA West uh
administrative spaces um really support
a lot of our admin of departments that
do not provide direct clinical care so
that we have um appropriate space to
provide that clinical care uh up the
road at the main campus uh within the uh
Whole Health Center and Wellness Center
at Manchester West there's a veteran gym
uh there are whole health coaches that
provide Health coaching for um
preventative U medicine and we also have
mental health services down there so um
it's a great new addition we broke the
in addition to the Manchester locations
we have four community- based outpatient
clinics you'll hear them called
seabox uh we've got one way up in Conway
and then we have two on the Sea Coast
one in Portsmouth and one in
summersworth and lastly there's one up
93 in Tilton those seab box really
provide comprehensive Primary Care some
Specialty Care Labs um mental health you
know we we really try to get as much
care as we can into the seab boox to to
allow veterans who are more rural to get
home our um Journey for to to become and
and continue to sustain uh our um
reputation of being a high reliability
organization really has been uh
surrounding three pillars um one of them
being uh leadership commitment um
running a culture that it really
surrounds and embodies safety um at
every level not just patient safety but
staff safety as well and just continuous
process Improvement so you know you'll
see um these principles of hro are
really embedded into our health care
decisions um we don't probably have many
meetings these days without starting off
with a safety story you know sometimes
they're they're um reactive because
something that we did not want happen
happened other times they're proactive
and they're near Miss and we talk about
them and we don't assume that oh it's a
near miss so we're good right no we have
to stop and pause and assess the process
and see have we really set up our
employees for Success um and so uh these
are the pillars that we really um are
committed to and and we've just had a
lot of success in the realm of um hro
organization we have quite a bit of
specialty care that we offer through our
healthc care system I won't read them
all to you unless you'd like me to
they're on um the VA Manchester
excellence and Healthcare page uh other
than the um primary care teams that I
already mentioned uh which also includes
uh specialty uh women's health clinics
with Gynecology Services we also have uh
a realm of other specialty clinics um
you know within uh Manchester and and
offered face tof face on tella health in
various different forms sometimes
through the CR um where we're able to
tap into other sites where they have
Specialists that are harder to find in
New Hampshire um and so we're really
proud of how much we've been able to
grow in the realm of specialty medicine
and you know we were really lucky when
the pandemic hit because we were already
uh much farther ahead with telea health
technology than some in the healthcare
industry so we've just been able to take
our tella Health appointments have
increased every year they they increase
this past year from um in from 23 to 24
they increased to nearly 15% and they
delivered
43289 teleah Health
appointments um and we've got I didn't I
wasn't going to list all of them here
it's probably a list of 100 or more
teleah Health type clinics that we
actually have um but the the most
information some of our significant
accomplishments uh we started a what we
consider to be a really Innovative
program um we call it the community
Navigator program where uh we started
sending um partnering with our our um
Hospital Partners in the community we
started embedding nurses in the
inpatient units of the hospitals and so
where we do not have an inpatient unit
at Manchester we have a nurse that is
out at these Community Hospitals and
when our veterans are in patient they
are um visited by this nurse and this is
whether or not they're enrolled in VA
Healthcare or not all veterans are
visited and basically you know we really
want to enhance the discharge process um
Hospital readmissions are are huge um
distractor to our health care System
across the board and so if we can be
there to handhold and make sure that the
discharge team um communicates strongly
with our discharge team and that we have
medications um ready to go any durable
medical equipment follow-ups with their
primary care that are timely um we've
really had great success with this
program the latest addition is we've
been able to embed a hospital list on
our side so if you are being discharged
from inpatient and then um going back
home um you will very soon have a
hospitalist appointment that is um
timely as recommended by the hospitalist
who was treating you while impatient and
um just the transition of care and um
back to home is so much stronger uh
we've had a lot of stories since we've
started this program as well of veterans
who were not enrolled in healthcare some
who are 100% service connected and just
did not know what they could get from
our system we've been able to pull them
into the system and educate them on
their better benefits and and now
they're um you know getting Primary Care
through VA Manchester so it's it's a
program that we'd like to see expand uh
it's just we we haven't heard enough
good things about it and it's just the
clinical outcomes are are so impressive
so uh we did receive the national 2023
service to Citizen Award for providing
teleah Health Audiology healthc care
services to rural patients uh one great
benefit in the VA are our hearing aids
are provided and and for those those of
you that don't know hearing aids outside
the VA in the healthcare system can be
quite costly although I've I've heard no
pun intended that that there's some
newer technology out there but um you
know for a lot of our veterans that are
remote um or rural um tra traveling
because you have to have your hearing
aids um molded and it requires more than
one appointment traveling from all the
way from Conway down to Manchester more
than one time for for a a population of
veterans that most often are older is
difficult and so this is an example of
something where we have built uh
effective telea Health Services with
technicians on the patient side
audiologists on the home side the
Manchester side we can have a veteran in
Conway um sitting with the LPN tella
Health um technician and our audiologist
in Manchester can be adjusting their
hearing aids to their to their needs so
it's it's really amazing what technology
has provided us and and we're really
proud of that program
something else we were celebrating not
so long ago I think it was in
December uh we surpassed the 30,000
veteran marks so we now serve um and
have 30,000 or well more than 30,000
veterans enrolled within our Health Care
system so you know between the packed
act the compact act and really
aggressive Outreach that we have uh
throughout New Hampshire as well as many
of the partners that are in this room
who have previously spoken uh we've just
been able to grow um in in in an
environment in New England where not a
lot of vas or not all the vas are
growing right so um there's a lot more
growth in the southern states within the
VA I wanted to share um that a couple of
our staff members were awarded New
Hampshire Magazine's nursing excellence
awards uh one of them is the Frontline
leader recipient and that is Crystal
Joffrey she works for our nurse case
management um department and also the
nursing informatics and innovator
quality recipient who is Mona lavalier
and um she is one of our informatics
nurses so we're very proud of
them we are 75 this year we opened back
um in 1950 so we're going to have a
party um you are all invited it's June
7th and um it's going to be an open
house from 10: to 2 there will be a lot
more details coming coming out but just
a heads up that um you know it's been uh
it's been a great few years and we want
to celebrate all the the work and and um
the campus changes that have happened as
well so it'll be on the Manchester
campus last and I hope I didn't take too
much time um last is a new uh talk
medicine show that's coming out our
chief of staff is going to be hosting uh
we're going to have all those Specialty
Care providers that I talked about on a
couple of pages before we're going to
have a Power Hour of a medicine talk and
so every hour that um they are on the
radio they will have two uh specialty
medicine providers on they'll talk about
General um medical things that are our
veterans may be interested in uh they
will be um breakout rooms we'll be using
the Microsoft teams app and so if there
are spe particulars that a veteran has a
question about with their own healthare
they'll be broken off into a teams room
where they can consult after the fact um
and we're just we're excited for this
it's it's um it's kind of our 2025 live
uh um project so it's going to be uh the
second Tuesday of every month and the
first kickoff is February 11th uh the
social media for faceb uh Facebook and
Twitter uh which you've got the um the
platforms here on the last page we will
put the information out on there so
anybody can join and and listen in
they'll actually be Visual and audio so
um if a patient maybe uh needs a certain
Specialty Care um service or is
interested in them they can not only
meet uh one of our physicians but see
see them face to face so um we're going
to have fun with that so that's what I
had for you today and I will turn it
over to you for any questions that I can
answer thank you Julie outstanding uh
presentation and and wonderful handout
uh we kind of used to slides in the
military and uh this is very well done
it's even dated January 17th 2025 uh
beautiful um you might have touched on
this real quick just the employees
full-time part-time how many folks uh
are and and I know you have these
satellite operations too so it's kind of
hard question to answer but about how
many people uh work for uh the let me
get this right the VA Manchester Health
Care System we currently have
[Music]
1,25 employees last count
um so dispersed throughout those those
you questions or comments um represent
mandle bomb thank you Mr chairman so I
see that um included in one of your
priorities is providing veterans with
timely health care and I've heard that
weight times at the VA can be fairly
long I'm wondering to what extent your
seeing that at the Manchester ba
Healthcare
System we're not struggling with that
terribly we have uh initiatives where
we're um scrubbing each individual
service and looking at next available
weight time specifically um that when we
have struggled it's been for new
appointments and so um looking and
scrubbing the days and the workload and
the productivity of every provider
really has been the way that we're able
to sustain access as far as access in
the community versus access through the
VA most often with specialty care we
have sooner access um we try to sustain
that it's not always possible but um you
know we've got clinicians that um uh
scrub these referrals and make sure that
if there's anything timely that it's
prioritized and um we're doing pretty
well you know we've had our blips where
we've got you know you've got staff that
maybe became ill and or had to go out
for longer term and and naturally those
things um affect your weight times but
we're able to really engage with HR and
get recruitments um um moving in at a
timely fashion uh which wasn't always
the case it was a struggle uh years back
but they're doing a great job for us so
you reps and f um just real quick uh I
think we ran out of hand uh handouts oh
yeah thank you because I would really
like that for my future reference yeah
great
you representative budak a quick
question um we often hear that veterans
are not getting Mental Health Care uh
could you please share light on
this so we have mental health care in um
various formats at our within our health
care System there's a good amount of
Health Care since the pandemic hit us
that has been transitioned face um over
over VVC uh tella Health Services
however that is driven by the patient's
um desire to have that so if a patient
wishes to have face-to-face mental
health care we will organize that to
occur whether it's at Manchester or one
of the um Community Based outpatient
clinics uh we have uh a great staff of
uh psychologists we've got four
psychiatrists on staff um they have open
access the Psychiatry team right now so
if we have some urgent um uh issue to
handle we've got we're able to get them
in same week at this point um with the
the scrubbing and and ongoing cleaning
of uh workload and productivity clinics
that that really the administrative
officers throughout the system have been
tasked to do as a regular work weekly
work um so I hope that answers your
question
yeah representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here um just a quick question
do you have like an outreach program
like where guest speakers will come
visit a VFW meeting and explain the
benefits to them and how they can yeah
get to them absolutely we have a
full-time Outreach coordinator his name
is Michael Bist I'm sure some in this
room know him well because he is really
all over New Hampshire but we partner
with VBA quite a bit on Outreach events
as well uh and then we have several
members of our Medical staff that are on
the Outreach team with Mr Bist so yes
and if there's a site that you know um
is interested that we haven't become
engaged with yet please um share with me
and I will get it back to him um I think
he told me at last count when he was
wrapping up his fy2 24 numbers he the
the staff and him his team per um
completed over 200 Outreach visits in um
fy2 24 so they're very active wonderful
answer thank you you're welcome
anything
else Jo I have one F final question I
had asked you about the numbers of
employees before uh in terms of Staffing
and recruiting are there any areas that
you're really struggling with in terms
of uh uh nurses or Specialists or
whatever we do pretty well with nursing
uh we've got a great culture at our
Medical Center we've been able to on
board nursing of various Specialties the
one area that we'd love to um see more
of is
psychology um we have recruits out there
right now we're we it's not that we
aren't finding psychologists but frankly
um you know we probably can um pull in
some more um there's always a a need for
um filling some vacancies there um to
balance out our Psychiatry psychology um
workload
okay thank you for that great job thanks
for being here wonderful handout as I
now the wonderful
commandant who's been here before I saw
Kimberly McKay down at esvac
recently um Kimberly thanks so much for
coming back and uh welcome thank you for
having us uh my name is Kim McKay I'm
the comod New Hampshire veterans home um
a proud state employee as of this month
18 years prior to that I was at spear
Memorial Hospital as a medical social
worker for 14 years so a lot of healthc
care I have had the honor of being the
commod at the New Hampshire Veterans
Home this month three years and it's
gone by in a Flash I'll let Brian Baker
introduce himself my name is Brian Baker
I'm the chief operation operations
officer at the veterans home I just
finished my 23rd year at the veterans
home and my role of operations officer I
oversee what I call the hardworking
departments the facility services
maintenance safety security laundry
housekeeping and dietary unlike Bill
goodro I've had many conversations about
laundry um and in in my time at the
veterans home I've I've either worked or
helped out in pretty much all the
Departments I oversee which helps me to
know what they're doing and also to help
hold them
accountable um what I just want to make
one statement about the veterans home
that kind of Echoes what Shawn said
luckily Shawn was there yesterday to to
witness the final salute that the
veterans home it's not a sad place it's
a on the contrary a very happy place we
have kind of an Unwritten model there
that a lot of people think of a nursing
home as a place you you go it's your
final stop you're going there to die so
what we we kind of push as a staff is we
don't want people to feel like they're
coming there to die we want them to feel
like they're coming there to live the
rest of their lives and we're able to do
that by giving them not only the best
Services the best care but we do a lot
of a lot of things that maybe they
weren't able to experience in their
lives uh going on trips uh different
activities and we're able to do that
with the help of a lot of the veteran
service organizations the people behind
me uh through donations and fundraising
so we we do we have to be very careful
with with using taxpayers money on our
budget to give the veterans their needs
so but because we want to give them the
best care and the best Serv services
that that we can give them we have a lot
we want to fulfill a lot of their wants
and again we we do that through the help
organizations all right I have a
slideshow here and I want to just Echo
what Brian is saying is um our motto is
they we they don't live in our workplace
we work in their home and so it doesn't
matter if I am touring um which has
happened when I've been touring a US
Senator and someone wants the newspaper
we're going to I'm going to stop that
tour and get them the newspaper because
the veteran is the most important person
in that facility um so if you come I
hope you do come don't feel um at all
like bad if I stop a tour and get a
newspaper um but it you'll see the
slideshow I'll try to be quick because I
know that we do have a a tight time and
we're starting late um but in 1889 to
take advantage of the federal assistance
Governor David Goodale established the
veterans Board of managers um and it was
made up of prominent citizens and we
have a lot of the artifacts from them
and um interestingly the commant the
second commant only made $100 a month so
we have all of their time cards it's
quite interesting uh the facility was
opened and dedicated to the Civil War
soldiers unable to care for themselves
and this past December was um a a big
anniversary um I will point out in 135
years which I don't think a lot of
people can say this but in 135 years
there have only been 11 commants 11
commants in 135 years so 10 people held
my job before I was there it's quite
quite an honor to be there um we have a
board of managers so I have two bosses
two sets of Boss the governor is my
first set um and then the board of
managers is made up of 12 members who
are appointed by the governor and
confirmed by the governor's Council um
the commanders from the American Legion
the veteran Foreign Wars and the
disabled American veterans and nine
citizens make up the board of managers
TW two of the 12 members are residents
of the New Hampshire veterans home and
you'll see the photo in uh in that
PowerPoint and the board has oversight
of the veterans benefit operations um as
well as appoints the commant so they
choose me they can dismiss me but the
governor chooses my salary it's a very
unusual event but um really works well
because it's not a political appointment
it's about who can do the job you have
to be a licensed nursing home
administrator and so um I was honored
three years ago to be picked and I just
want to recognize a couple of the board
members who are here right now who are
my bosses um Paul Lloyd is our chairman
and has been on the board for years AJ
um cororo is there as well um Leo was a
board member last year and Bill goodro
who is here is Al was here is also a
board member um so we meet uh once a
month and and um talk about the facility
and how we're going to spend the donated
Monies to f u fund the quality of life
um the New Hampshire Veterans Home is an
what do they call an ICF it's an
intermediate care long-term care
facility um we are licensed for 250
residents we are budgeted by the state
for
225 um we have a budget of 384 staff by
the state of New Hampshire we are all
state employees um and we do have some
contracted Services through our our
medical team recently our greatest
challenge has been recruiting and
retaining staff in both our clinical and
support services um the New Hampshire
Veterans Home uh is in is um the program
is paid for we don't take Medicare
Medicaid we actually are through the VA
grants we are paid for by the grant the
VA the state and the veterans themselves
and I've added the CFR that's here that
over sees us so if you are interested
it's 38 CFR
5141 any government CFR is quite lengthy
but you're welcome to look at that um
veterans receive either a partial or
full cost living reimbursement um so we
have to have a uh annual certification
to maintain our VA certification to be
able to build them for each resident
that lives with us the mission statement
at New Hampshire Veterans Home is to
provide the best quality of life for New
Hampshire veterans with dignity honor
and respect and you will see that no
matter um when you come to our facility
if it's for a ceremony uh or a coffee
hour the staff are there for the veteran
uh some of the achievements I just want
to push out there this past year we um
well in 2022 we created an LNA program
we as of now uh have 30 new lnas that
have either enter they some of them have
left in that time um um but most of them
have stayed with us and we have another
LNA class that just began on Monday with
eight more uh LNA candidates we also
created something called a licensed
medication nursing assistant program in
conjunction with the Board of Nursing so
we can train those who are lnas to pass
medications as well and we have uh had
two uh 10 uh people who are now lnas
that help us relieve some of that uh
nursing shortage that we
have we were awarded um and mostly for
Brian's hard work the 2024 outstanding
energy efficient project uh where we had
a lighting Improvement project that was
for our entire facility we replaced I
would say almost every light bulb uh
fixture in our facility at really no
cost to us with eversource and uh Das
and we are seeing Energy savings cuz all
of the lights were changed over to LED
we have a lot more control of when
they're on and when they're off you do
feel like a movie star when you walk
through CU lights will come on as you
start walking through cuz they motion
detect but we're we really are seeing
some savings with that for our monthly
energy costs we also were able to
approve security uh we all know the sad
situation that happened at New Hampshire
hospital which brings forward always
Security in our facilities and we were
able to add additional cameras so that
there are no dead spots in our facility
as far as uh cameras with the exception
of bathrooms and bedrooms and we were
talking talking common areas uh if we
had a missing resident we can put in uh
blue shirt brown pants and it will show
us everywhere on the camera where
there's somebody that's wearing that
that clothing color combination so we
know have outside view as well uh we
were able to uh with enhance New
Hampshire and some of the arpa money
improve our uh Wi-Fi efficiency if you
were in our building before there was
very it was very hard to get service and
um our average age is 83 but they have
phones they have iPads and they are
connected and they want to be connected
so if they went from one place to
another place in our facility they often
were not connected so that has um been
resolved so we're happy to uh report
that and they're very happy about that
the big piece that we want to share and
please pass on to the people that you
represent is that our admissions uh
process did you was uh up to a year
sometimes longer if people wanted to
come to the New Hampshire veterans home
but we have actually been able to
streamline and add some resources in our
admissions office and so we're seeing a
3 to six month uh process instead of
year or plus uh we actually are now
experiencing where it's moving so
quickly some families say oh we just did
it in case we needed it um so we have
some people waiting on our wait list
that are just waiting for the right
moment and then we have we are working
on uh really building up our rehab
department and we have now a full-time
physical therapist and we're working on
on taking a position that we weren't
using and reclassing that to an
occupational therapist you'll see some
of our challenges and achievements and
again our staffing is is big the biggest
issue we have an overall vacancy rate at
the New Hampshire Veterans Home of
almost
35% some of those are purposeful because
we're not at our full census so we
should not have all of the staff if we
don't have the full census but it's a
catch 22 if we had more staff we could
have more residents um right now our
vacancy rate for lnas is about
41.7% and our nurses is almost 40% um so
we're seeing that as really been a tough
piece there is just so many resources in
the private sector to offer sign on
bonuses uh bonus monies if you work so
many shifts or uh just a higher rate of
pay and we can't do that we don't have
those options as a state
employer uh right now we're we're trying
to we're going to have to cap our
resident um census at 150 to meet the
need of the veterans and do that well
it's it's something really important to
us can I fill the beds yes I can fill
225 beds but the quality of care would
be horrible and we're just not willing
to move on that quality of care for our
veterans um so we're trying to still go
to job fairs um be on uh different
platforms like handshake for colleges uh
local newspapers uh Word of Mouth we
have Consolidated some of our our
departments or uh neighborhoods that had
some residents here some here we put
them on one uh neighborhood so that we
can consolidate our staff we're
expanding our light duty in the past we
haven't let people come back light duty
if they weren't fully D fully ready to
come back we would ask them to sit out
now we know that we can do other things
um we do mandating we have increased our
volunteer opportunities and we're adding
a learning uh system which will offer
continuous educational opportunities for
people who have licenses and that sounds
like a small thing but if you have to
maintain 40 cus every 2 years and we can
offer that on the site at work and
there's no cost we know that that will
be a recruitment benefit for
us uh strategic key strategic priorities
continue to grow our resident C uh
census reduce our number of State uh
vacant staff positions meet the VA
requirements we have to do that every
April they come out and they uh do a
full survey um really address some of
our life safety initiatives we need to
upgrade Vehicles we have one that one of
the residents told me is embarrassed to
get in because it's so Rusty uh we're
replacing those Vehicles as we can with
the budget that we have uh it
infastructure that I spoke about
building maintenance and and we have a
new addition that will be going uh it's
out to bid right now we're hoping that
we will be breaking ground in the uh
summer months that is money that was a
lot of from the state in 2016 and we
were waiting for the federal portion to
be approved which they approved uh last
year so we are working on a 20 bed
private bathroom with nine of those
rooms being bariatric and just giving
them a better quality of life and
infection prevention instead of four
people sharing one bathroom it's just
not the best quality and I think that
most of our veterans have probably done
all of the community living they want to
do as they went through basic and in the
military so um again 20 we're licensed
for 250 beds budgeted for
225 as of the 15th we have 13 people on
our wait list that have been approved uh
with four of those already having beds
offers over the next few weeks and um so
this is a really small number than what
we used to see we had a huge number
previously and we have 30 applications
in process so that may be from day one
or were they're getting medical
information um we're getting their
financial information whatever that is
um so we are confident that we could
definitely fill 225 if I can get the
staff there because a lot of people who
have to go to a placement of a nursing
home level placement they sometimes wait
to the point where it's in crisis so
they have to go to other facilities in
the community and then switch over to us
but our goal is to just be able to have
an open list you qualify you did all the
work we're going to uh offer you a bed
that's our goal um this was as of uh the
15th we had 133 residents 123 men 10
women I will tell you yesterday we had a
final salute which um we spoke a little
bit about that is a a ceremony that's
held at our facility uh if you are
coming in our front door as a veteran
you are going to go out our front door
not at a loading dock or something uh
that's secretive they the person who
lived with us is part of our family and
we need that closure so um yesterday we
did have a final
salute happening at the same time in the
Next Room we were celebrating a 100th
birthday um of a uh member of our our
family so uh the average age is about 83
years old and you'll see the census
graph here shows we were pretty high up
before uh the covid and now we're just
struggling to get back up to where we
were prior to covid which I think a lot
of healthcare facilities are doing as
well I always talk a little bit about
the branch of military Ser uh service
because because it's a topic at our
facility um so the Army is 56 residents
uh the Navy falls behind them at 39 the
Air Force is at 24 the Marines are at 8
which I've been told by marines that you
only need one um and National Guard is
three National Guard is three and the
Coast Guard are three as well um so then
we have the conflict era we're seeing um
a lot of our veterans right now are
Vietnam era uh we have five World War II
veterans still with us um and um but
we're seeing that larger pool we do have
a very young resident who is a golf War
veteran as well she is uh 64 years old
she's our youngest
resident revenue streams which is really
important for people who are saying how
do you get how do we pay for this um so
uh you'll see the graph here the federal
funds um from the um VA pays for a p uh
portion of that it depends on your
disability rating to how much they pay
so if you're over 70% disabled through
the VA they're going to pay us what's
called um a prevailing rate and that is
$587 120 a day if you are under that 70%
Watermark then it is a basic rate
payment and that's
$144 a day right now we have six
veterans who are over that 70% or higher
the other uh way we are paid is the
actual residents if they have resources
over $30,000 they are U paying us a
portion of that that until they've
reached their 30,000 um and then the
rest is General funds which we are lucky
that we have that to fall back on we're
very aware that these are important
funds and how we spend our taxpayer
dollars we will try to get everything we
can out of everything like I mentioned
the vehicle that is rust it's solid as
far as a safety wise but it is Rusty um
so right now our breakdown is um 46% are
General funds 30 are federal funds and
24% are from our rman board funds we
have a few capital budget requests this
year we need to replace some rooftop air
handlers we need to replace um resident
veteran uh tubs in a bariatric uh shower
stretcher trolley we have very old
elevators we have had a staff two staff
members get stuck on an elevator and
have to be pulled out um which is
terrifying and uh so we need to update
two of them and replace one and then we
have some really old sections of our
building building that are are not Ada
requ uh they don't meet the ADA
requirements and they also have really
narrow doors so some of the wheelchairs
literally can't fit in the doors so
we've closed those units and tried to
move to other units while we're waiting
for some rehab dollars to at least uh
widen those uh to accommodate the lar
larger
wheelchairs uh quality of life programs
that Brian spoke a little bit about they
are all supported all of the quality
life residential activities are
supported by the people behind us some
of the people probably sitting at this
table the veteran service organizations
the community Christmas everybody uh
comes out and they sponsor of Veteran
for Christmas gifts uh they go to uh
sporting events they do the things that
you and I would do we go out to dinner
we go to shows we go to things that we
want to do and they are treated so well
they go to the air show uh in Portsmith
and they are um asked to come during
family day and they have a tent for them
everybody honors the veterans uh I've
been at restaurants where we are
intending to pay with um our monies and
someone will pick up the whole bill for
all of the veterans at that table so we
respect that and we um we know that this
is a blessing and uh we thank everybody
publicly uh there are so many things
that they can do in our activities um so
one of the things I want to say is we
have coffee hour every single day at
10:15 and so anybody who's in the room
or anybody who's watching please stop by
please come and visit with them they
will give you a little razing probably
about what service you Branch you serve
served in um but you can take that you
can take that um and so uh please stop
by see how wonderful our facility is
again we are supported by the governor
the house the Senate and if if we didn't
have that support uh we would not be
what we are today so thank you very much
open for
questions thank you Kimberly thank you
Comon wonderful wonderful presentation
and I can tell uh I can sense the
affection and and the uh the love that
you have for your job and for your uh
your people questions uh uh yes
representative gagy Mr chairman with
your uh permission I've got a couple not
too many but a couple uh getting back to
the uh the staff yes uh how are the
wages are they competitive for the area
they're it's so tough because I know the
governor is probably watching me too
right now um they're better with the
raises that we experienced over the last
two years um however what happens is
when we become somewhat equal to the
private sector the private sector has
the ability just to increase the
salaries so right now we're seeing a lot
of loss of uh licensed nursing
assistance to contract companies private
companies that do contract and they're
paying quite a bit more than we are we
uh are dietary and our laundry workers
are some of the lowest paid um how how
much is it hourly so typically laundry
and dietary we start around between 12
and $14 an hour which which is tough to
recruit when and I don't want to put any
uh facility down but they could
literally go to McDonald's and make five
to $6 dollar more an hour for for a lot
less work for Burger flippers right so
it is it's been tough they were somewhat
better um but they're we getting outm
marketed again well follow up follow up
my second question would be uh we're
getting back to the LNA question is that
in-house teaching yes so we have staff
that um teach the LNA program and then
we have the state comes and does the
testing to uh test them and then once
they pass they can be licensed do the
lnas pay for that or is it or is it paid
for by for them it's it we pay for it
with a commitment so they have to commit
to us um 12 uh excuse me I wish I could
say 12 years I want to say 12 12 months
or the equivalent of a full-time 280
hours so what happens is if they leave
and they choose to leave before that
commitment is done then it's pro-rated
and they must pay that back to the to
the state of New Hampshire um the
majority of time people stay for the
whole time and then they may leave again
to go somewhere else where they're
getting offered a lot more money thank
you R manal bomb thank you Mr chairman
so I'm looking at your census and
certainly we know that the co pandemic
disrupted nearly everything um but
between 2020 and 2021 there's a decrease
of nearly 70 residents yes and I'm
wondering if you could explain more
specifically why that was your resident
leaving or an unfortunately High
mortality rate yes so it was um it was
before me um so I know that both Paul
Lloyd and Brian were there on the front
lines with that uh that was covid uh
there was a huge loss of veterans at the
facility before the vaccine was
available uh early on they made it quite
a while um right before the vaccine came
before the co had actually uh entered
the facility so you see a big drop there
related to the covid and we've been
struggling to get up there again with
the average age of 83 we do lose a lot
of people so this number looks like it's
stayed the same but that's a lot of
residents who have come in and gone out
um and uh but that's that's the
explanation that all right thank you
you're welcome anything
else um coming on hopefully the eight
Marines are working out staying in shape
and staying out of trouble uh I don't oh
I don't know about staying in that
trouble
but all you need is eight they'll
they'll make a mess all you need is one
right that's true that's true yes thank
you so much great presentation thank you
for your time and last but not least a
new uh a new part of our orientation uh
thank you representative Rollins I'll
let you uh introduce and and recognize
the the folks from Rolling Thunder um
glad you're here uh in uniform looking
good rson Rollins can you kind of take
it from here sure thank you for coming
down with us today it's it's good to see
the group here I hope you're getting
something out of this and uh I'm looking
forward to the committee is looking
forward to hearing what you have to say
what Roland Thunder is all about explain
what we do for our veterans and uh what
we do on the national level and I will
let we have Bill D for and L St
Pierre here with us today bill is the
president Les is the Mi a expert that we
have on our committee take it away thank
you Mr chairman for allowing us to speak
on behalf of Rolling
Thunder good morning I'm bill duor as
skip said or representative Rollins said
president Rolling Thunder chapter 2 New
Hampshire and to my right is Les St Pier
United States Army and Vietnam veteran
first and foremost I want to thank every
veteran for their service to this
country and the Vietnam veterans welcome
home Rolling Thunder started with two
Vietnam veterans in New Jersey Ry
Mueller and Ray
Mano in the fall of 1987 they were
sitting in a diner discussing more than
10,000 reported sightings of live
Americans living in dismay captivity
they were deeply troubled by the neglect
of attention given to those who did not
make it out with their lives or their
freedom so they decided to do something
and they started Rolling
Thunder and which grew to what it is
today the first demonstration ride in DC
was 1988 and the last was
2019 right now each territory they do
their
own demonstration rides like us here in
new New England we meet down in PL Ridge
Park Casino they let us use the parking
lot to line up and then we do a uh
police escort to Fall River Vietnam
veterans memorial wall in Vice
Centennial
Park Rolling Thunder the name came from
a 1965 bombing campaign against North
Vietnam dubbed Operation Rolling
Thunder Incorporated in 1995 Rolling
Thunder is a 501c4 nonprofit veteran
support organization
in 2007 Rolling Thunder Charities
Incorporated was established as a
501c3 we're not a motorcycle club we're
an organization that helps local
veterans in need and to educate the
public of the prisoners of war and miss
and actual
issues our mission statement is as
follows the major function of Rolling
Thunder Incorporated is to publicize the
pmia issue to educate the public that
many American prisoners of War were left
behind after all previous Wars and to
help correct the past and to protect
future veterans from being left behind
should they become prisoners of War
missing an
action we are also committed to helping
American veterans from all
war we do fundraising throughout the
year um all kinds of events we do and uh
just to help out veterans with either
groceries rent car payments even gas to
get to back and forth to the VA um
groceries any anything they need we also
do flag lines at funeral homes and grave
sites and for different events football
games whatever whatever invited to we've
also done escorts for Our Heroes to the
final resting places mostly to bosow and
the New Hampshire State Veteran Cemetery
also there there are 90 chapters
throughout the country with
approximately 10,000 members there are
nine chapters in New England and three
chapters right here in New Hampshire
chapter one New Hampshire is based out
of eping New Hampshire chapter two we
are based out of Claremont New Hampshire
and chapter three is based out of
Hinsdale New Hampshire chapter 2 was
ched December 14th 2010 we just had our
14th anniversary and we're still going
strong we have 45 members 16 being
veterans there a total probably around
580 in New England
totally our website is Rolling Thunder
the number2 nh.org on that you could
find a hardship form that we help out
veterans with uh you can make donations
our emails are on
there and if you wanted to find out
where all the chapters are throughout
the country you could get on Rolling
Thunder National and then it'll just
click on the chapters and then it'll
show you where all the chapters are you
don't need a motorcycle to join Rolling
Thunder you don't have to be a veteran
I'm not a veteran my saying is I didn't
serve my country I'm serving my veterans
that's why I joined Roland
Thunder we have old members young
members junior members veterans non-
veterans we also have a gold star father
that is a State Rep and that's
representative Rollins it's an honor to
have him as a
member we are all United in the cause to
bring full accountability for pmas of
all wars reminding the government the
media and the public we will not forget
there are dedicated groups still looking
for any remains to bring families
closure one is jpac j- Pac jpac is joint
P Mia accounting command which is a task
force within the US Department of
Defense whose mission is to account for
Americans who are listed as P Mia from
all past Wars and conflicts jpac is made
up of military and civilian
people another way for everyone not to
forget is we have donated several P Mia
chairs through throughout our community
like then Newport Town Hall the senior
center moose lodges and
schools and also Flags too P MAA Flags
we donate them one more thing I'd like
to bring up before Les's speaks is
Claremont is hosting the wall at heels
it's a 3/4 inch scale of the Vietnam
memorial wall in
DC we are escorting the wall from in
Claremont to madno park where it will be
set up and we will help break it down
also there's 40 slots per year and there
are 140 applicants to host the wall
Claremont being one the wall has only
been in New Hampshire four times in its
history the arrival date is June 24th of
this year display dates are June 26th
through the 29th and it's going to be
can be observed 24 hours a day while
it's still there
um yeah anything else on that you think
no
so if if you get on our website you can
just keep on you know what what's going
on with the wall so keep up the date
with that all right here's Les remember
veteran thank you Mr chairman and all
our state representatives Le St Pierre
Vietnam veteran uh few years ago bill
came up with an idea to uh recognize the
misas that have been identified so
monthly at our meeting I go through
during the month and put together a list
of M that have been identified the
identification
process is achieved through the dpaa
which is the defense P Mia accounting
agency which was established in uh 2015
prior to that there were four other
organizations with this project and all
it did was tread water so in 1973 from
World War II there were
73,74
Mias from World War II they're now
71,9 186 so we have identified from
World War II 169
one
Mias Korea there's been was
7,446 that's 711
Korean veterans have been
repatriated Vietnam there was
2,634 we are down
to
1,573 so we have identified Vietnam
1,61
members the Cold War which lasted from
1945 through
Mias they have accounted for 126 from
the Cold War we are down to only two Mia
from the Cold War the gulf Wars in
Libya there were six Mias all six of
those have been
identified a highlight was in September
the 700 Mia from Korea was ided it's a
long slow
process to ID uh some of the IDS take
two to three years once they start
working on
it uh New Hampshire itself has 319
Mias 273 are from World War II we have
40 from Korea
and we still have six from Vietnam it's
a long slow slow
process uh it's had most of these have
come through a lot of work uh they have
to get approvals from they first they
have to find sites where
these individuals might be uh then once
they get orientation of where these
sites are they have to go through
the governments of that country where
they are get permission to uh search the
areas so it's a it's a process that's AP
to Take 5 10 years sometimes but it's a
slow process and we're proud that
Rolling Thunder that we're supporting
this all the way through to identify our
Mias it's uh I got a whole bunch of
cards here but I can't go through them
all uh one of the things they have
accomplished was from uh World War II
the USS
Oklahoma when that was
a attack during Pearl Hab day October
1941 there was
429 Sailors killed on that on that ship
through 194 47 they were able to
identify
35 that left
394 individuals unable to be
identified they were buried in Mass
Graves throughout
Hawaii uh and they start exhuming they
exhumed them in
57 they started and they were reburied
again and in 197
five they started the whole process all
over
again since that time since 2015 since
the dpaa took
over they have now
identified everyone from the USS
identifications due the fact they had no
DNA or ways to identify the bodies they
have done a Mass grave of just
30 individuals that have not been able
to be identified they know that they
have their names and they were all
buried together in one Mass grave but
individually identified as
unknown uh so the Mia thing will never
go
away uh most of the ones from World War
II about 75% of those
41,000 are going to be as unrecoverable
because they went down at
Sea
so forever our country will have
masas uh for that fact other than that
uh
it's it's something that uh we want to
always keep in mind
that family members
never have
closure because their loved ones are
never going to be found but the good
thing is that organizations keep it in
the Forefront that we still consider
them family and
Mias and we're keeping the government
accountable for
that Mr chairman committee members thank
you very much for your time I very much
appreciate it
thank you so much Bill and and Les I I
did not know I had no idea that you
folks did what you do do what you do
with the Mia uh issue and and to think
how many thousands especially from World
War II and just never it's just
something to ponder questions or
comments
for the
speakers uh represent
Rollins yes thank you I notic I me heard
you mention that you have some of the
cards with you I know we read these at
our meetings um for the sake for the
committee to understand what we read
what is on those cards do you have a say
two of these cards that you could read
so that I I didn't bring any of the
cards with me uh when they're
identified uh some of some of the sites
I have to go to will just have their
name and when they're
identified but I put together the cards
um I try to do the individual's name
their age their
Hometown where they served whether it be
on a ship or whatever units they served
with and possibly where they were uh Kia
which killed in action I try to keep
that on all the cards and an update of
when and if they were buried whether
they were buried at a national cemetery
buried overseas or uh came home to be
buried with their family uh so these
cards uh I put them together 3x5 cards
and we pass them around the room and a
member will read
it and I what gives
uh feeling to that is saying the missing
man's name man or
lady saying the name
brings the to Forefront of what the I is
and so uh it's it's a good thing I I I
enjoy doing it and like uh
representative Rollins said he always
when I pass the cards around he's always
sure to grab at least one or two to read
the names to highlight what our mission
and what we're staying and around
for maybe represent Rollins could bring
a couple cards to uh some of our future
sessions uh if there's no OB ction in um
in read read them here that would be
good good to see it will bring a lot of
feeling to you anything
else thank you again thank you for your
service and thank you for all that you
do so glad that you came in thank you
rep Rollins is a nice addition to our
program and with
that uh we are adjourned until 1300
hours 1 pm and we'll have a a he two
hearings two Bill hearings this
for
e
okay 2 minutes warning about 2 minutes
started
e
okay we'll come into order here uh it's
just after 1300 hours just after 1M um
we're doing two Bill hearings this
afternoon uh HB 55 and then HB 104 hp55
will'll start with right now this is an
act repealing The Selective Service
compliance act the analysis line uh and
there are there should be some copies of
the bill available uh this bill would
repeal The Selective Service
registration awareness and compliance
act the prime sponsor is here he's from
this committee represent Manion welcome
and um have at it thank you Mr chair
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Tom Manion I'm
representing Hillsboro 1 pelum uh United
States Marine Corps infantry combat
veteran with two deployments to aaq with
Third Battalion sixth Marines Uh current
RSA precludes individuals from being
employed by or achieving higher
education in the state without first
registering for Selective Service with
the federal government I have not found
any information suggesting we are
financially compensated for enforcing
this unlike most other federal laws and
programs that states cooperate with the
feds in enforcing it should be noted
there is no fiscal
note in addition with regards to higher
education as of 2025 the free
application for federal student aid FSA
has removed its own requirement that
applicants be registered for the draft
to apply for federal student
loans as with many private sector
Industries the state is having trouble
filling many roles we have a bill right
now to form a study committee to look
into the problems with hiring law
enforcement The Selective Service
compliance Act is a hindrance to this
process we limit the talent talent pool
unnecessarily by putting hurdles in our
own way the federal government already
has steep penalties should someone fail
to comply with the draft should it be
started up again it doesn't make sense
to me that we as a state put ourselves
and our citizens at a disadvantage when
the draft has not been active for 50
years I ask that you vote OTP on hp55
questions representative
Foss yes so I did a lot of reading on
this one and on the uh Selective Service
act in general I know that Most states
have a similar law which is um a
variation of amendments in the actual
law and that some don't do you know of
any instances where as would be the case
here a state had a law like this in
place and then repealed it I don't know
if any that have repealed it but I think
it's like 30s something states have this
on the books right now and like it it's
probably one of those things that was F
I know in New Hampshire was filed in
like the late '90s and it's one of those
things where I'm sure as guys from the
Vietnam era that felt like you know uh
people were draft dodging and they you
know probably had some remorse or or not
remorse but you know they they wish that
more people would have stepped up and
would been filed so they added extra
penalties on top of the already like
draft Dodger penalties that may come
down from the federal government so I I
I think like in in in light of the 21st
century conflicts that have occurred I I
think we should be a lot more skeptical
about just like blind adherence to
allowing the federal government to just
snatch people off to send them off to
war zones that may not have uh the the
greatest outcomes for the United States
including a you know future blowback
that could occur down the line
especially a decade from now um so
answer other
questions representative Lloyd um in
your testimony you stated that uh s
thank you chairman by the way um in your
testimony you stated that uh this is a
hindrance to law enforcement um and and
they're getting their numbers up for
candidates and everything do are we
hearing any testimony later today from
law enforcement agencies to I was just
so just to clarify we I I know that
there I just bruising through the lsrs I
know we have at least one study
commission to study why we're having
trouble recruiting law enforcement and
like while this may not be a a even on
the radar of what their problems are
it's one more thing that it's like okay
well we have this perfect candidate like
he's a like you know whatever and then
oh wait he's a conscientious objector he
has no he doesn't want to register for
the draft well can't hire him
like we're not allowed to hire them
that's what the the RSA currently says
we we're not allowed to each department
this representative F kind of asked a
question I made a note about so just to
uh follow up on what she said to be
clear uh is there a single other state
that has repealed not that I'm aware of
I haven't looked into seeing who has
repealed it okay so to your knowledge
there not a single other state that has
done this not it's my knowledge no okay
qu other questions for the prime sponsor
I do represent of cyber yeah I just had
a question in regards to um hold on one
second no I think you cleared it up
sorry okay before we lose the prime
sponsor I I do have some pink cards and
some uh people who uh want to testify
that the as a history guy the purpose of
the draft you know it came about Civil
War and then was gone came back World
War I S uh The Selective s the draft was
brought back like in 1940 and then it
was by one vote in 1941 the year we went
to war they almost did away with the
draft and by one vote in Congress they
kept it uh and then it's been back and
forth up and down uh it went away in
1973 I know that because I turned 18
just at that time purpose of the draft
is to come up with people um Manpower
person power in a time of uh War uh in
time of uh need I think we needed the
draft certainly after Pearl Harbor as it
turned out or else we would not have had
the Personnel we needed to win the war
in my view so given that that purpose of
the draft and the reason they kept
selective service was to have a
mechanism or structure in place if we
had to go back to it uh what if we did
have a another massive uh War start
where we needed people uh without the
Selective Service would we be up the
creek without a paddle or so how would
you what do you say to that you mean in
general or in part in regards my
question is what if there was a big war
and we don't have selective we don't
have a draft oh okay so uh my bill
doesn't touch that for the record it
doesn't stop the draft it just stops
like us penalizing ourselves for people
not registering for the draft so to to
go follow on from that I believe that in
the times of need people will step up
when it's required and what what that
definition of is required it depends on
the context of the conflict if we are in
being invaded I believe that many people
will step up
like there's that famous quote I think
it was like uh from World War II from
Japan this say a gun behind every blade
of grass I believe that type of thing
would be unnecessary to start a giraff
because people would just step up and
defend their neighborhoods uh then we
move into the great the greater scheme
of invading foreign countries and my
question would end up being currently
like looking at the conflicts of the
21st century for what purpose uh are we
invading Iraq again are we invading
Northern Africa or you know Russia
because of Ukraine uh China because of
Taiwan like I'm I I I struggle to find a
situation where a draft would be
necessary in the current uh geopolitical
climate Okay represent
Foss actually just occurred to me while
you were speaking so uh there's no uh
like exception for somebody who is a
conscientious objector no currently the
only exceptions to the rule are people
who are previously enlisted and
physically aren't in unable to register
for the draft because of mental
disability physical disability
conscientious objector status does not
apply okay thank you yeah actually okay
so I was going to ask another question
about the states in
particular um is that okay oh I'm
sorry uh representative cyber yeah sorry
I should have asked
you um so um when it comes to you had
mentioned about other states receiving
compensation for enforcing
the sign up for the draft is that what
you were talking about or I was I was
talking about other programs whether it
be like drug enforcement agency or ATF
cooperation or border patrol like things
like that we get compensation for
helping the federal government with
their Federal programs oh I see what
you're saying there's no compensation
for us enforcing The Selective Service
and we're not even like in an active
draft right now so we're getting nothing
out of this and just hindering
ourselves are there any may I ask
another question sorry follow up um with
saying that you know we don't receive
any comp compensation are there
penalties that are possible for that
yeah I I don't know off the top of my
head but there are very steep penalties
for not complying with the draft they
include the prison time and and several
thousand fines if the draft were
activated yes and you didn't muster all
right thank you other questions for the
prime
sponsor saying none uh
uh representative Hemingway
yes thank you Mr chairman
so representative um you said that the
law enforcement were having problems
getting uh recruits because of the
conscientious Observer I'm sorry to
clarify the only reason I mentioned that
is because it's a current study
committee that is in an there's an LSR
that was filed uh on to study a
recruitment hurdle that they're running
into they don't know why I just say well
if we're going to be studying why we
can't hire people why are we have all
these laws on the books that already say
we can't we literally are not allowed to
hire a certain subset of people based on
this flag for flag you didn't sign up
for the draft and we can't hire you
because of that even though you're like
potentially the best candidate for this
like that seems like we're putting
roadblocks in the way that shouldn't
exist as a state follow up
followup so if they object to do their
job and carry weapons in a
combat how are they going to carry guns
in a law enforcement environment they
they may be perfectly fine uh helping
their neighborhoods they may may be
perfectly fine carrying a firearm to
defend the lives of the people around
them but they may not be okay with going
to foreign conflicts to take the lives
of people that did nothing wrong to
them other
questions uh who was first uh
repres representative Lloyd thank you Mr
chairman um so a question for you
basically this would this would not
cancel the national draft for purposes
of the the federal government however
for uh the repercussions here in New
Hampshire would no longer be on file
with this legislation that's correct as
I said I'll clarify again this does not
stop the draft this doesn't even get in
the way of the draft this just removes
hurdles that we've decided as for
whatever reason 25 years ago put this in
R RSA to make it so we can't hire people
and children can't go to higher
education unless they say I'm okay with
thank you for that clarification that
that helps reps and fos uh yes I just
wanted to make sure that uh we're clear
um so when you we're talking about the
penalties earlier in including the
that's penalties for the individual and
from the federal government yes um are
but are there are no penalties to the
states right no no we're the state
doesn't penalize people for not this is
our only penalty that exists for failure
to comply no I mean there would be no
penties from the government to a state
for not having no as far as I have seen
no there's like the fiscal note says
nothing like if we fail to uh enforce
this law we just took this upon
ourselves to enforce the draft thank you
representative mandal bomb thank you Mr
chair um could you please repeat what
you said about the FAFSA so FAFSA is uh
you you used to when you applied for
federal student aid you'd go through the
fasta form and there used to be a
component on there that required that
you would registered for the draft very
similar to the New Hampshire law that is
phasing out this year I'm not sure when
that started but that it officially ends
this year when you file for federal
student aid you no longer have to comply
draft followup so to clarify so what
FAFSA is doing doesn't have any is not
related to this bill it's just saying
that it this bill wouldn't interfere
with faf's process that's correct the
reason I brought it up is because it's
pretty fun that the federal government
is saying we're not going to enforce our
own law and then the New Hampshire is
still going to enforce their law on
their behalf for no
upside other
questions seeing none uh thank you Mr
Prime sponsor thank
you okay I have a card here chairman
um yes could you pass that up because
otherwise uh this
meeting yes yes uh Pink cards let them
meltis in opposition to the bill uh
General midus is the agitant general for
the New Hampshire National Guard
uh welcome
moment okay welcome back General thanks
sir Mr chair committee members for the a
Major General David mtis the agent
General FL New Hampshire National Guard
and the commissioner Department of
military Affairs and veteran
services uh on the the the bottom line
on the front as we are opposed to this
bill I wear two hats as the ad general f
New Hampshire National Guard I don't see
a sort of in a direct impact that repeal
of this legislation would affect their
recruiting and retention of men and
women at the New Hampshire National
Guard so on the on the Ed General side
of it I don't don't see a direct impact
other than the fact that one of the
punishments in state law is um your in
ineligibility if you do not apply if you
don't fill out the selective compliance
Act is you're in ineligible for you know
State financial uh Awards or incentives
for a second postsecondary education
that would sort of uh give us a Level
Playing Field unfortunately for service
members who don't want to serve versus
our biggest thing is tuition waiver at
the University system of New Hampshire
so but generally speaking um as an AG in
general we're sort of neutral in this
bill why I'm adamantly opposed to it is
is because I'm the commissioner of the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services so let's establish some
facts as uh the chair gave you a little
bit of history of The Selective Service
Act the B biggest thing I would give um
um offer to you is there's a
84% National compliance rate from
calendar the last statistic was uh
calendar year 2023 with the Selective
Service Act
in The Selective Service Act if you
don't um um apply or enroll in it you're
eligible up to a fiveyear a felony
conviction up to 5 years incarceration
and a $250,000 fine and in addition to C
certain uh Federal incentiv um you know
financial assistance that's Federal as a
representative alluded to 31 States out
of the 54 states in territories have
additional constraints or restrictions
or punishment at the state level if you
do not adhere to the federal selective
service act so when you look at the
three items at New Hampshire um has put
in statute two of them maintain the
education and one of them also maintains
to an employer in state
government at the state level in New
Hampshire there's about a 75% compliance
rate with the Selective Service Act we
or I am opposed to it as the
commissioner of Department of military
Affairs because of our dual mission of
supporting the men and women in uni form
and the 990,000 veterans in the state of
New Hampshire and as the bill sponsor
alluded to I do not want a conscientious
objector as a state employee who's
working as a veteran service officer to
give them the care and uh necessary sort
of services that a veteran deserves in
this
state so as a minimum I adamantly
opposed to this restriction being
repealed from state government as an
employer of and care of the 90,000
veterans in the state of New Hampshire
subject to the question that's all I
have so you will take are there any
questions representative
F uh so regarding what you just said
about conscientious objectors uh so
you're saying somebody who was a Quaker
wouldn't be as good at providing care or
me for example because I'm a woman and I
didn't have to register for the
Selective
um
if according to federal law 18 to 26
year old males must register so if an 18
and 26-year-old male to make the
decision to not want to enroll in The
Selective Service Act why would I want
them an employee to be taking care of
our veterans the requirement doesn't
apply to you or a Quaker or that's not
what the federal law is about doesn't
give you it doesn't matter to religion
and um gender I
would follow up yes but qu many Quakers
are conscientious objectors so that
would apply if you're saying you don't
want any conscientious objectors and
representative Manion said that there's
no conscientious
objector uh exception so that would rule
out a lot of people based on religion uh
all right let me I'll rephrase my
response to saying any male between the
ages of 18 and 26 who refuses apply or
sign up for the effective Service Act in
the future could be hired as an employer
in the department of military Affairs I
don't think if they if they can't do the
basic civic duty like pledge of pledge
of allegiance and it's a federal law
then um I would be concerned um with
their employment status how they want to
take care of our veterans who have
served other
General representative Heath
Howard is in support of the bill he's
asked for three minutes
and we have no time restrictions if you
go over that well thank you Mr chair or
under it than thank you represent thank
you honorable chair and members of the
committee uh my name is representative
Heath Howard I represent the towns of
straford and barington in straford
District 4 uh when I was 16 years old I
broke my back I had a L4 burst fracture
I had four rods and eight screws put in
and because of that i' I've always been
exempt for the draft I've never had to
worry about having to fight in an
overseas War
and is never something that I would want
to force upon others uh when I myself am
not subject to that our veterans uh make
such great sacrifices and I think that
we're very lucky to have a very robust
uh voluntary force and it is for those
reasons that I'm in support of hp55
because I don't think anybody should
have to break their back uh in order to
get out of military service or die in a
war that they don't believe in and I
don't think that they should be punished
uh for not consenting to the draft uh
like my good friend from pelum said you
know there are a number of restrictions
that are placed on people when they
object to uh submitting their draft card
it is something uh that I think is
egregious and limits people's individual
freedoms and Liberties uh I don't think
that we really have a future need for
the draft in our current geopolitical
state as the the the representative
palum had said and I truly believe that
this is something that will uh allow
people to exercise their rights fully
thank you so much uh I'm open to any
questions seeing none uh thank you
representative thank
you Kevin Grady of state federal as you
were Kevin gr of esvac State veterans
advisory committee was here this morning
he's in opposition to the bill he's
asked for 5 minutes uh welcome back Mr
Grady thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee once again
for the record my name is Kevin Grady uh
I am a 25- year Air Force veteran and I
am a 27-year veteran of the town of
hookit New Hampshire and today here I'm
speaking on behalf of the state veterans
advisory committee that we talk to you
about this morning who we are and and
what we do um during the last
legislative session there were two bills
that dealt with social with the
Selective Service act the first would
have required that we post uh some
statistics and other was 1247 if you
want to look it up some statistics and
other data at recruiting stations in the
DMV that would have been really
detrimental to
recruiting um and that bill was found
inexpedient to legislate as well as
House Bill
1338 which would have uh restricted
information flow back to the federal
government for Selective Service would
have provided a a a check form at the
DMV where somebody could register as a
conscientious objector which is not the
process at all there is a process to
become a conscientious objector that is
not it there's a board process for it
okay and then also remove the penalties
which is kind of what you see in front
of you today has been scaled down from
1338 to just removing the penalties here
in New Hampshire for failure to register
with Selective Service
to be honest and and and representative
man you probably back this up we didn't
discuss this for very long at our
meeting he was at the meeting where we
talked about this um to us it just feels
like when you take the penalties away
from this Selective Service thing at the
federal level what you're doing is
you're sort of trying to enable people
to do the wrong thing and that feels
wrong to us and that that that was a lot
of what the the sentiment was that was
coming out of the room is it's just it
it it's like you found a lot the federal
level and you're you're really
essentially at at the State House level
kind of powerless to affect that so what
we're going to do is we're just going to
sort of chip away at it and we're going
to give people an opportunity to
potentially ignore this and still
qualify for higher education in the
state still qualify for state jobs those
those kind of things so that it just
kind of felt like you know we're not
doing the right thing when nobody's
looking you know we are that's that's
kind of our Mantra in the military you
got to do the right thing all the time
even when nobody's looking um if you
wanted to encourage our Congressional
Delegation to say we haven't draft
anybody since 1973 okay I was a
sophomore at the Air Force Academy when
we last drafted somebody if you wanted
to say that this thing is a time is come
and gone we've got an all volunteer
Force as general told you this morning
we're currently making our recruiting
quotas and all those the chances of this
being used are very small very small the
chances of a World War III scenario in
my opinion as a military professional
lasting more than a couple three days
are are are remote they're really remote
okay I I noticed the chairman LEP and I
think he might agree with me on that a
World War II scenario is is not going to
last long at all not long enough to
recruit not to to draft and train people
okay so if you wanted to say that this
this is is a law that's come and gone we
could have that discussion at the state
veterans advisory committee and if you
wanted to say that you know what fair is
fair and if we're going to make our
young men register for Selective Service
we ought to make our young women
register for Selective Service as well
we could have that discussion as well
but this just to us feels like we're
trying to do the wrong thing and that's
that's really I'm trying to convey to
you sort of the the feel that I got from
the room that day and that and that was
it so subject to your questions
that's all I wanted to tell
you are there any
questions uh I have one miss gr which
you may not be able to answer maybe
someone else can um I'm wondering about
the current infrastructure to uh
maintain the Selective Service uh
Administration or whatever again we've
said several times it ended uh 52 years
ago which and I which I remember that um
are there any Selective Service Federal
Personnel types in New Hampshire I I
don't know that's that's what I'm
wondering is well you may not know
either but Leo does know um as as chair
I'm gonna uh ask him to come up and
answer this question because uh I think
it's of interest to more than just
myself H how how big is this Selective
Service infrastructure that's
maintaining the a skeleton operation in
case we ever need it and are there any
New Hampshire employees of that uh yes
sir um so the answer is yes Leo pin uh
uh State Venture advisory committee
chairman um I'm actually on the local
Selective Service board so if there were
to be a draft um on one of the people
that would sit on the board that you
would sit in front of to become a
conscientious ejector so there isn't
like you just one day say I'm a
consciences ejector what happens is you
register for the draft that that starts
the process and then once there is a
draft then you can say I'm a
conscientious ejector and it's not I
don't want to fight or it could be I
want to do non-competitive services so
you can do something you have choices
there are different tiers of uh
conscientious obor it's not what you
think like I just don't want to ever
touch a gun there could be people like I
I would love to be a medic I never want
to touch a gun but I'd love to be a
medic in the military there are people
that say I don't want to serve in the
military but I'm willing to do a mar cor
or something like that so there's
different tiers and
the boards still exist my most of them
are volunteer but there are uh federal
employees as well if I could ask are you
a volunteer or are you paid by the no no
I'm a volunteer okay yeah most of the
now most of the positions nowadays are
volunteers do you know how big the in in
presumably in DC how big the
infrastructure is of the structure of
the selective service operation he you
know we're we're we're small fish in a
big pond in New Hampshire but I happen
to know I mean the board I was the
training I did recently about every two
years they do a whole training and the
and the scenarios are extremely
interesting and they're actually prior
cases of people becoming Cons projectors
but on the on the WebEx I was on just in
a local area I had 80 people and they
were all
volunteers thank you I guess I drafted
you to come up here and speak and thank
you for answering the call I did my
eight
years thank you uh any other questions
for uh Mr
Grady sing thank you so
much Aubrey Freeman
Aubrey is here he was here early Aubrey
is in support of the
bill from Bridgewater New hampsh welcome
ARS for three
minutes Mr chairman committee members uh
Aubrey Freedman living Bridgewater
private citizen I speak in support of
this
bill we already have a volunteer um Ser
uh armed services so why do we have to
why are we coercing young men to sign up
um in the last 100 years when we've had
attacks on the US soil there's never a
problem with you know Pearl Harbor 911
people were signing up like crazy when
it comes to overseas interventions
people are would obviously be uh would
it would be you know they have to think
about it a lot more they wouldn't be
volunteering so I don't think there's a
problem the volunteer army works now now
the question really becomes does your
body belong to you or does it belong to
the state if you believe that it belongs
to you then we should not limit uh young
men's opportunities to go to a state
college or university apply for a
tax-funded uh student loan or to apply
for a state or I even a municipal job
because they did not want to basically
sign your life away um any part of the
selective
service is um it's anical to the 13th
Amendment which
says neither slavery nor involuntary
servitude except as a punishment of a
crime whereof the property the party
shall have been duly convicted shall
exist within the United States or any
place subject to their
jurisdiction so and I know people might
say
well you're just signing up for it it
doesn't really mean that you're they're
not taking your body yet that's the same
as gun registration why do they have
people sign up for gun they're not
really going to take your guns it's so
they can grab on to it if they need it
that's what it's there for we don't need
it it's evil you either your body
belongs to you or not it does not belong
to the state we should not comply New
Hampshire should not comply period
That's why I support this
Bel thank you thank you Mr Freeman would
you take any questions yes yes are there
any
questions saying none I thank you again
I have one more card here um
from Eric uh
Eric Eric brei from Dover uh welcome
my name is Eric brai uh I uh very
recently moved to do New Hamshire where
I'm a resident now prior to that I uh
just completed my third term in the main
State Senate next door in the pine tree
state but I'm happy to be a resident of
the livre or die state today um I'm also
the executive director of the New
Hampshire freest state project but I am
here in my individual capacity not on
behalf of any uh organization
I I thought I might add a little bit of
historical context to uh uh to these
deliberations
today I think it's worth noting in the
context of military conscription that um
military conscription was not uh a part
of our um our federal government it was
not utilized by our federal government
since the establishment of the US
Constitution for most of the for
basically the first hundred years or so
um it was not until the Civil War that
conscription was first used though many
historians regard it as having actually
been counterproductive it led to draft
riots and there wasn't really difficulty
uh getting um volunteers during that War
I didn't really come into full practice
until World War I and I think that
history Bears out that conscription has
only really been necessary I mean I
guess necessary depends on your
perspective um for unpopular Wars um as
I think was previously noted when we are
attacked or when people feel that there
is a actual truly compelling threat to
American Security there there are no
shortage of volunteers willing to stand
up and fight for their country uh but
certainly at times like right now when
we have gone through 20 years of very
unpopular Wars with unarticulated
missions and no Declarations of war from
Congress certainly it is getting harder
and harder for the military to recruit
people to go off and fight these wars
and I think this is why today in
Congress you do hear more and more talk
about bringing back the military draft
uh but it is worth noting that the
military draft has not been an act of
use even though it is on the books has
not been an act of use since the end of
the Vietnam War there were actually very
famous debates about this between Milton
fredman and General West Morland on a
commission that was um commissioned by
President Nixon to study the
effectiveness of the draft I think one
of the um uh very enlightening moments
in those debates was General West
Morland saying uh to to Milton fredman
uh that I do not want to command an army
of mercenaries degrading the idea of a
volunteer service where people are there
because it's their job and they're paid
for it to which Milton fredman replied
better an army of mercenaries than an
army of slaves and let's understand that
that's exactly the you know the the Crux
of this right when we um when we are
talking about involuntary conscription
uh people being forced to uh to en
enlist and go off and fight in a war
that they have perhaps do not believe in
and do not choose to participate in that
is a form of slavery and I just want to
hearken back actually to um during the
War of 1812 I think there was a very
poignant moment of debate in in Congress
actually um and one of the preeminent
figures in this was a famous New
Hampshire Statesman uh Daniel Webster
uh there was a push to Institute a draft
for the first time under the United
States government for the War of 1812
when we were actually being actively
invaded by the British and the White
House was being burned down and yet even
still Daniel Webster stood up and I just
want to share some of his words and then
I'll be done and I'd be happy to take
any questions that you have so this was
what he had to say in Congress about the
proposed
conscription is this sir consistent with
the character of a free government
is this civil liberty is this the real
character of our constitution no sir
indeed it is not the Constitution is
Lial fouly Lial the people of this
country have not established for
themselves such a fabric of despotism
they have not purchased at a vast
expense of their own treasure and their
own blood of Magna Carta to be slaves
where is it written in the Constitution
and what article or section is a contain
that you may take children from their
parents and parents from their children
and compel them to fight the the battles
of any war in which the folly or the
wickedness of government May engage it
under what concealment has this power
Lane hidden which now for the first time
comes forth with a tremendous and
baleful aspect to trample down and
destroy the dearest rights of personal
Liberty who will show me any
constitutional injunction which makes it
the duty of the American people to
surrender everything valuable in life
and even life itself not when the safety
of their country and its Liberties May
demand the sacrifice but whenever the
purposes of an ambitious and mischievous
government may require it nor is it sir
for the defense of his own house and
home that he who is the subject of
military draft is to perform the task
allotted to him you will put upon him a
service uh equally foreign to his
interests and abhorent to his feelings
with his Aid you are to push your
purposes of Conquest the battles which
he is to fight are the battles of
invasion battles which he detests
perhaps and uphor less the danger and
the death that gathers over them and the
blood with which they drench the plane
than from the principles in which they
have their origin fresh from the
peaceful Pursuits of life and yet a
soldier but in name but he is opposed to
veteran troops hardened under every
scene inured to every privation and
disciplined in every service if sir in
The Strife he fall if while ready to
obey every rightful command of
government he is forced from his home
against against right not to contend for
the defense of his country but to
prosecute a miserable and detestable
project of invasion and if in that
Strife he fault is murder it may stalk
above the cognizance of human law but in
the sight of Heaven it is murder and
though millions of years May roll away
while his ashes and yours lie mingled
together in the Earth the day will yet
come when his Spirit and the spirits of
his children must be met at the bar of
omnipotent Justice may God and His
compassion Shield me from any
participation in the enormity of this
guilt they don't make him in Congress
like that anymore I will say Daniel
Webster was truly an amazing figure of
New Hampshire um thank you for listening
to me um and um and for hearing this
bill if there are questions I'm happy to
take them otherwise I'm happy to go sit
back down again thank you Mr brei the uh
Daniel Webster uh oration you just read
uh was very powerful he was born just up
the road here as you probably know as
you mentioned he is a granite stator uh
I do want to point out that most of our
NATO allies do have a draft or some form
of uh uh compulsory
Service uh some of the models in our
that our allies have involve uh
compulsory national service short of
they have options they can go into a
military area or non-military service
area um and there have been proposals in
our country to look at that type of
model if if we ever adopted a
compulsory a non-military uh compulsory
service option would that is exists
elsewhere would that make any difference
as to how you would would look at
this well I mean I guess if we're
measuring against the status quo I I
would say certainly it's it's would be
better for people have the choice not to
go into a a a combat role if they have
moral objections to it but I I would
still morally object to the underlying
principle that people should be coerced
and forced into um aversion of slavery
uh that is not that they're not
voluntarily choosing for themselves
again I think that history Bears out
that um when the public feels that a uh
a conflict is based on a real threat to
to America responding to a real Attack
on American soil or real American
interests are at stake uh in tangible
way and there is a mission that is
clearly articulated and laid out there's
no shortage of people who are willing to
stand up and fight for
questions Sani thank you again for your
time thank you Mr chair and your
testimony okay we have one more we do
have another U pink card for hp55
representative uh Perez welcome hi I
wasn't going to speak on this but a very
valid point came was brought up as far
as I'm concerned this requirement of men
is
discriminatory until we start making
women do the exact same thing and sign
up it's
discriminatory that was brought up by
the gentleman before me and maybe that's
how we me need to do it so it's not but
I think we should get rid of it all
together thank
you would you take any questions here
are there any
questions sen thank you
representative and that was the last
pink card for hp55 I will say that we
will uh we were scheduled to EXA this
and vote on it a week from today so uh
the uh folks who could not make it here
I've already told told them and uh
alerted them that I expect them to uh
watch the video of this and we'll be
talking about it this week and uh we
FYI okay I'll close hp55 hearing we have
one more hearing today we have a good
number of pink cards uh this would be
for House Bill 104 with fiscal note 104
FN the sponsor is again uh from this
HB
104 an act relative to requiring an
official declaration of war for the
activation of the New Hampshire National
Guard in a foreign State uh welcome back
representative uh have at it again all
right thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record I'm Tom
Manion representing Hillsboro 1 pelum
I'm also United States Marine Corps
infantry combat veteran with two
deployments to Iraq with Third Battalion
six
Marines it was my experiences there that
motivated me to learn about US foreign
policy and got me interested in politics
when I first heard about this bill last
term I was it was entirely within my
wheelhouse and I'm happy to bring it to
this committee this term HB 104 known as
the defend the guard act will prevent
the New Hampshire National Guard from
being deployed to a combat zone without
a formal declaration of war issued by
Congress pursuant to Article 1 Section 8
of the US Constitution I believe the
premise is one that just about all of us
can agree with so I'll focus on
attacking the fiscal note firstly it
mentions Federal funding may be put at
quote
risk which is intentionally
non-committal language and after a term
here and conquered I've heard many other
committees with regards to health
mandates education policy vehicle
inspections you name it whenever the
legislature files a bill the executive
doesn't like there's always they're
always likely to roll out the old
Federal money defense to try and stop it
Congress writes the checks and no
Congress person is going to commit
political suicide to defending a state
Guard unit especially with Senator
Shaheen on the committee both
Congressman gsar of Arizona and Massie
of Kentucky have affirmed that no member
of Congress will defund any state guard
when asked specifically about this
bill I'll be closing more with the
fiscal note but bear with me secondly
the fiscal note mentions what is known
as the Montgomery amendment of 10 USC
12301 F which which states the consent
of a governor described in subsections B
and D may not be withheld because of Any
objection to location purpose type or
schedule of such active duty we are not
objecting on any of those grounds we are
objecting on the constitutionality of
the deployment if the purpose of the
Montgomery Amendment was to completely
remove the governor consent then
subsections B and D would have been
amended to remove consent requirement
entirely would anyone here argue that
Governor Nome could withhold consent on
the grounds that his state is in
crisis next the FIS fiscal note reads
title 32 USC section 108 States quote if
within the time fixed by the president a
state fails to comply with a requirement
of this type title or regulation
described under this title the National
Guard of the state is barred in whole or
part as the president May prescribe from
receiving money we are not prohibiting
any title 32 activation the section says
under this title twice meaning
specifically title 32 activation title
10 has no such provision now more policy
time aums
authorizations for use of military force
are the very mechanism we are
challenging with this legislation
Congress has seeded its constitutional
authority over War declarations to the
executive branch without a
constitutional amendment to do so as
such the president has been granted
Powers our Founders warned against when
they specifically vested the power to
declare war with Congress the fiscal
note correctly points out that we have
not formally declared war since 19
41 opponents will say we need the
freedom to act
quickly we as New Hampshire have no say
in what the president can do with active
duty military forces who will be the
first to fight we are simply interceding
between the president and our Guardsmen
requiring him to first go to Congress
for a formal declaration of war before
he can take our sons our daughters our
grandchildren and our neighbors into
that
fight I want to add
the specific citing of the 2001 aumf as
justification for our military
Misadventures is particularly
absurd the war in Syria that we helped
instigate and have been supporting for a
decade has resulted in the overthrow of
Bashar alassad an installing of Abu
Muhammad Al jalani as deao deao leader
this man was a member of al-Qaeda in
Iraq the Insurgency that came to that
country to shoot at guys like me
he later folded into Isis then back out
into various factions of al-Qaeda in
Syria and until a few weeks ago had a
$10 million Bounty from the United
States on his head for his terrorist
activities National Guardsmen have been
attacked because of this conflict in
2023 the Louisiana guard came under
rocket attacks in northeastern Syria
while defending oil fields and last year
Tower 22 in Jordan right over the Border
of Iraq and Syria came under drone
attack that resulted in three Army
reservists from Georgia being killed
along with 41 National Guardsmen wounded
from Arizona California Kentucky and New
York and it is my understanding through
the lance corporal underground that the
new New Hampshire National Guard had
returned home from that base only weeks
prior to the attack it could have easily
been our guys coming home in
boxes in closing the most important
development has occurred since we passed
defend the guard out of the house last
year in a bipartisan fashion the
nomination of Pete head Heth for
Secretary of Defense a few days after we
took that bipartisan vote heg said on
his Fox and Friends episode New
Hampshire is simply pointing out that
it's supposed to be Congress that
declares war it has become an executive
branch function and as a result unless
Congress declare war New Hampshire
doesn't have to send its troops to
Foreign Wars to me it makes a lot of
sense I love this idea it's my
understanding he has in he has since
intensified his support for this bill so
the funding fears and are more unfounded
than ever when he is the guy that's
going to be in charge of the Department
of Defense and with that I'm open to any
questions thank you Mr Prime sponsor you
just mentioned uh Congress uh declaring
war uh so Congress uh
passed the tonin Gulf resolution in
overwhelmingly so do you see much
difference between
Congressional resolution in support of
military action as in the tonen Gulf
resolution or in
1991 uh I will I will tell I will share
1991 I was in a in a Hole uh on the
border of Saudi Arabia and we were
acutely aware that back here in America
there was going to be a vote um as to
whether or not to authorize President
Bush to use Force I heard later that he
said he was going to use Force either
way uh of course as it turned out he the
Senate uh vote the aumf they they passed
both houses right so my point and again
you mentioned 2001 so my you're you're
looking for Congressional sanction of
military force is how much of a
difference is there between declaration
of war last one was in 1942 against
Bulgaria of all people um so declaration
of war by Congress or authorization of
force by Congress is there a distinction
or a difference no I believe that there
is a very big distinction here with the
authorization for used to military force
what we're currently operating under is
it allows the uh president to decide the
start point the Endo the targets uh in
the case of the 2001 aumf we've engaged
in military activities in over 20
something countries uh and we're using
it even in in these cases where it's
we're literally in in Syria we're
fighting on the side of al-Qaeda who is
the target of the 2001 aumf we have
never passed an aumf to authorize
anything we've done in the Syrian
conflict and because of the broad
language of 2001 they just keep looking
at it like yeah sure that covers it and
every and this has been on the books and
has been tried to be repealed by one
chamber or the other but it never makes
it across the Finish Line the 20 01 and
2002 aums are still in effect in effect
to this day we're we're at what 10 years
since bin Laden died and we're still out
the 2001 aumf and we're helping al-Qaeda
in some of these countries and it's not
limited to Syria we helped al-Qaeda in
libia we're helping Al-Qaeda and Yemen
against the houthis like we decide who
our enemies are at you know the whim of
the day it's
ridiculous to be clear if there was a
declaration of war you would have no
issue with the National Guard
okay we just want them to follow the
Constitutional process because then we
can hold our legislators accountable and
we can vote them out qu questions other
cyber oh sorry sorry about
that um okay so while I agree with the
messaging this is aiming towards um I do
have to say that well you just me I
believe it was Pete head is the name
yeah I hadn't heard about that
appointment yet but um so if he's in
favor of this why would we not do this
as a
resolution and especially being the
sponsor of this bill try not to get this
done on the national scale so that it
goes into effect for everybody and you
know work with our delegation on that so
I love the question uh so the one thing
I would say is heg Seth won't be
Secretary of Defense forever we need to
make sure that we put these guide uh
guard rails in place now and once we
break the dam there are dozens of States
lined up with similar legislation that
are just waiting for the first person to
go I would love New Hampshire to be the
first state to pass this it is passed
out of uh the upper chamber and two
other states and we pass it out of the
lower chamber here it's looking like
it's probably going to pass the same uh
Chambers as before I would love to do it
again as far as the discussion about a
house resolution to either ending repeal
the War Powers Act or more specifically
the asking for repeal of the War Powers
Act is a big ask a smaller ask is uh the
20012 2002 aumf repeals as I mentioned a
little bit ago they have tried for the
last 20 years to try to repeal these a
umfs it goes nowhere begging the federal
government to fix this is why the defend
the guard act came about in the first
place because they kept the guys behind
it the veterans behind this have been
smashing their face against the walls of
Congress asking them to repeal these a F
and they have done nothing this it is
now time for the states to act in
whatever way we can to stop these
forever
Wars follow up yeah um so just to that
tune I mean I think it's worth a shot
though because right now you know
political climates definitely change
from time to time and right now it might
be a time when we have that chance to do
that I would be more than happy to file
a house resolution next term if you
would be my co-sponsor I would love this
for a b bipartisan house resolution to
and repeal the 20012 2002 a umfs I would
be happy to do that thank you thank
you representative HB 104 has an FN for
you folks watching at home or who will
be watching FN is fiscal note uh which
is attended it's looked into uh
researchers OLS office of legislative
services will look into the projected
cost of the measures that we put in if
there if there is a if there is one the
FN the fiscal note for this measure is
$55
million that's one of the that's one of
the bigger fiscal notes I've ever seen
can can you speak to to the significance
of the sure that would that cost us $55
million I I have held true since the
very first time I've ever testified on
this bill that that is a uh something to
scare us into compliance with the
military-industrial complex they want us
to be scared they don't want us to pass
this they don't want the states to
assert their rights over their National
Guard and to bring challenges to the
Supreme Court that would disrupt the
status quo uh I believe with the
incoming SE def who supports this bill
and multiple congressmen that have set
on record in specific reference to this
Hemingway thank you Mr chairman
representative so talking on the fiscal
part of this I know that having spent
many years in the New Hampshire National
Guard that my first years in there we
were always worried about whether we had
the fuel or the equipment to do
trading over the last several years 10
20 15 years the the money that we've
been getting from the federal has been
helped to get us the best equipment that
we can be using plus the facilities and
the proper equipment to keep our our
troops safe
you do not feel that this bill would
change that I do not believe so no I I
I've heard from multiple congressmen
with spe specific reference to this bill
and with the incoming Secretary of
Defense I don't I do not see that the
fiscal note it holds any water follow up
followup so on the back back of the uh
this here it says the money that comes
up to almost $400
million that could possibly be withheld
if so do desired you still don't feel
that no okay thank you thank you other
questions say on thank you Mr Prime
sponsor representative okay I will tell
you that we have a custom tradition of
sorts here in this body when we have
hearings we try to recognize or
acknowledge Uh current serving reps or
uh former reps and um try to give them a
bit of difference uh so I'll try to do
that maintaining with our custom uh if
the occasionally there'll be a newer rep
uh legislator um who will put a card in
and I we won't know that they are a rep
so I apologize in advance if there are
any uh serving legislators who uh I
don't recognize uh I recognize three and
uh we will go to them now we have about
12 cards and this is the the only other
Bill we're going to hear today so we'll
be here as long as it takes I don't want
to I don't see a need to put any limit
on testim time of testimony uh I just
simply would say if if a significant
Point has been made uh and developed uh
that you be careful about taking time to
say something or develop something
that's already been been developed okay
uh that said representative uh Henry
Jason III from gtown uh is in the house
uh welcome to state federal and Veterans
thank you Mr
chair so some of you may or may not know
I did 24 years in the Army myself I
retired from operations in the
Massachusetts National Guard I worked as
an operation Sergeant so I have seen
some of the effects of what happens when
the National Guard is not available and
ready when the when the federal
government calls and I just want to
speak to those things from that position
as a subject matter expert who worked in
the field again the last 15 years of my
career were in Human Resources
recruiting retention and in
operations um so once every quarter each
of your National Guard units has to
submit a report on their Readiness that
report encompasses equipment maintenance
Personnel Personnel health issues if
somebody's non- Deployable because of an
injury or pre or pregnancy or something
if somebody's still in the training
cycle if somebody doesn't have the
schools that they need to do their job
those are all reported funding for the
State National Guard 80% comes from the
federal government and almost all the
equipment belongs to federal government
so the things that I'll touch on real
quick are equipment maintenance and
Personnel Readiness and those are going
to be used as the excuses to make the uh
the cross- leveling transfers look like
it's non-punitive
we fly these helicopters on training
missions we put in for maintenance
requests if Parts get allocated to other
states because their states are on the
deployability Matrix we're not able to
keep those hel Ops in the air we have to
report that as a maintenance deficiency
we report that as a maintenance
deficiency too many times those
helicopters are going to another
National Guard along with the pilot
allocations if we can't get our pilots
in the air often enough they lose their
flight
credentials um that same thing is going
to be true of our trucks now in a
domestic state of emergency if we need
to respond to a flood in the state of
New Hampshire and get people off of
rooftops or out of a place we need big
trucks and we need helicopters those are
the first two resources we're likely to
see problems with in terms of personnel
we're talking about careers and we're
talking about real people it's important
to understand that through NGB the
Department of Defense owns these
training seats National Guard members
don't have anything on their uniform
that says National Guard they go to Army
basic training they go to uh Air Force
basic training for the air guard side of
the house I apologize to my air guard
companions I was in the Army so I
usually refer soldiers no disrespect to
the other side of there um but all your
training schools all your promotion
schools those are all DOD schools those
are all run by the Department of Defense
they are army schools some are run
through National Guard training acmy but
those are open to the Army Reserves and
the regular army or the Air Force
Reserves in the regular Air Force
accordingly so if we are looking at
these people as real careers and the
military starts to ration the training
seats to favor Deployable metric States
we're talking about stagnating people's
careers um so bringing that all together
if we are not able to out of our own
Pockets maintain the equipment and find
a way to get our our service members
into training we're going to lose
Readiness and if the federal government
decides that they're going to start
moving these resources because they've
shot Us in the foot in terms of
Readiness then we need to find an
alternate way to make sure that we have
our own resource within the
state so uh pending any question my
biggest concern honestly is that a
downsizing of the State National Guard
would cause us to not be able to respond
in a domestic state of emergency in the
state of of New
Hampshire so pending any
questions representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair and and thank
you for your testimony um the last
sentence you said could you repeat that
again I said my concern would be if we
lose for structure and equipment in the
state of New Hampshire that in a
domestic state of emergency we would not
have the resources to be our own rescue
uh to to expand on that that would put
us completely at the mercy of the
resources of neighboring states or of
FEMA if we overwhelmed our own emergency
response within the state and do you
think
it's changed by deployed to active duty
in foreign
States
um they are only is that going to have
an effect on it it can have an effect on
it um they're not allowed to deploy the
majority of the National Guard at the
same time there's I I believe the last
time I checked it was a two3 matrix
where two-thirds of the National Guard
had to stay in the state and the
governor also had the opportunity to
either say no or defer um deployments
based on the state's Readiness cycle and
the state's available assets that's
informative thank
you so representative what I'm hearing
and correct me if I'm not correct in
what I'm paraphrasing your testimony
stating you're saying that this measure
could conceivably degrade the guard
which would threaten the ability of the
New Hampshire National Guard to conduct
local missions is that is that that is
wheeler welcome representative wheeler
who is in support of the Bill thank you
very much chairman Moffett members of
the House State Federal Relations
Committee friends on the house state
federal Relations
Committee I'm here today in support of
defend the guard legislation for a
number of reasons that representative
Manion outlined but as the child of a
military family many people in my family
served in the military and as a student
of History which I know you know as
somebody who teaches Civics uh I am
deeply concerned by the United States
and its turn over the last 82 years
since 1942 as you mentioned in Bulgaria
when we declared war and congress's lack
of Courage around the issue of genuinely
debating any of the number of conflicts
that we've gone through over those last
82 years you asked a good question and
before I get into some of my other
testimony I would like to address it
about the elf of tonen resolution and
the War Powers Act that came after that
those two pieces of legislation
specifically the War Powers Act being
that that's still
used is different than the Declaration
of guard than the declaration of war for
the reasons that representative Manion
brought up but it's also because that
only requires Congressional leadership
to know about the actions being taken by
the executive branch and there have been
a number of instances in which
Congressional leadership doesn't let the
broader members in the United States
Congress know and and that puts us in a
dangerous position where the leadership
in congress has some level of
responsibility on these conflicts that
should be given to the broader Congress
and to the Congress as a
whole not to mention the fact that it
keeps us from debating these topics in
an open Forum in a public way for the
people of the United states to hear on
the house of the floor on the floor of
the United States Senate we haven't seen
that done in a long time um I would
bring up the issues
around many different veterans here in
this legislature who support this
legislation people on this committee who
I know have served in our military and
our Navy and who support this
legislation and some new members who I
haven't met yet freshmen who are here
who have served our nation as well well
and we're very thankful for their
service and they brought up last year
representative potuk who was the sponsor
of this legislation last year he's a
Vietnam veteran and in rewatching his
testimony I was compelled by his comment
around Vietnam was a war ask any of
these veterans who served in Vietnam or
Korea or any of these other conflicts
these were Wars and for congress not to
do its Duty as outlined in the United
States Constitution and debate these
issues and declare war before sending
our 1819 20-year-old boys out to the
Jungle I think is a moral travesty in
the United States of America and it's
put
us from a foreign policy perspective if
you were looking at it not from the
defense department perspective but from
the state Department's perspective in a
really hard position diplomatic when
Nations see that we are willing to
unilaterally go after Sovereign Nations
for no reason whatsoever such as Iraq
based off of a lie then they get worried
and the stability of the world is shaky
because the United States is the most
powerful country on the face of the
planet not just because of our military
our technology our people our prowess
but because of the land that we have and
its position on the world and uh our
geostrategic position is just unmatched
and when we do something the world
listens and if we are unilaterally
declaring Force against countries
Sovereign Nations the world is listening
and I think we've seen the effects of
that over the last few years with other
countries following suit we gave
congress the power to declare war
because the scholars who
wrote our constitution 248 years ago saw
over their history they were very well
educated men they knew that despots
Kings over the course of history had
used conflicts and Wars to Rally up publ
uh the public who if they weren't
rallied around that conflict might might
realize that they were being taxed to
the brim or uh under an authoritarian
leader as the people the United States
of America realized 248 years ago in
creating our
constitution I'm most concerned that
we've entered a period in this country
where it's uh or Orwell's Forever War
where as representative Manion outlined
we just find a new enemy wherever we can
look for one and the defense Contracting
agencies continue to make money the
executives I should say of those
agencies continue to make money and the
Congressional members who go into those
consulting firms after they're members
of Congress serving on the defense and
Appropriations committees in the United
States Congress make money and the
generals who have sold out their they're
boys they are men and women who are in
their brass who go on to serve and make
money in the defense Contracting agency
the military brass the veterans who are
on the around who the people who know
what it's like to be denied service by
the VA who are going through what the
effects are of the United States of
America doing these wars and then not
paying attention or caring about the
people who served in those Wars those
people who are directly facing the brunt
of of the government right now and
knowing what it's like to be a veteran
who served your country and to come back
only to find that nobody nobody knows
what you went through and isn't going to
help you those people support this
legislation and they they don't want the
forever Wars they don't want Orwell's
Forever War where we just continue to
find a new enemy and for me uh this is
personal legislation it's not going to
immediately solve the United States
congress's lack of Courage issue but it
does for what we can do here in the New
Hampshire
legislature take the first step forward
in New Hampshire to say this is how we
can get it done and to your app Point
representative CT about a
resolution as you know Mr chair and
members who have served here for a long
time house resolutions go into the
Congressional trash bin they they they
don't have any power they don't have any
weight and if we want this legislation
to have power and weight in our
Congressional Delegation seeing that the
state of New Hampshire is genuinely
looking at the fact that they haven't
declared war debated these issues for 82
years then we should pass this
legislation and one of the last points I
would make about the fiscal note for the
freshmen in the room and others who have
served not as long is the fiscal note is
not uh sacran it is not um sometimes
agencies and organizations when they are
against a particular piece of
legislation will exaggerate
or overblow a particular fiscal note uh
in the aim of being against this
legislation and sometimes it's it's the
job of the legislature to say I respect
your agency I respect your job here but
we are the legislature and we know that
this is an important issue and we know
that we need to move forward on this
issue the other states that have moved
forward have had no issue with Federal
funding or threats of federal funding
and have faced those threats when when
being proposed in committee so I would
see this as given the fact that the
United States of America has shered its
responsibility its constitutional
responsibility for the last 82 years to
declare war that it's time for the
states to start taking up its mantle and
urging and pushing the United States
Congress to do that by withholding our
troops if they're not going to take the
time to declare and deliberate War but I
would agree if if they did then those
troops would be ready and able to do
that work if they were declaring war and
and out there I'm happy to take any
questions and I thank you all for your
for your opportunity to speak here today
thank you representative representative
Mandel bomb thank you Mr chairman so our
colleague um Congressman Manion
mentioned that New Hampshire would be
the first state to pass such a bill but
from your testimony it sounds like there
are other states who have passed bills
like this could you just provide a bit
of
clarification I was under the impression
bill so the upper chamber had passed the
bill with no threats or problems in that
that instance thank you for the
questions repes go ahead representative
cyber no I just thought I had a little
bit of a clarification on that when I
looked at at the upper chamber that's
similar to like how it passed our house
initially am I correct on that and then
was tabled in the
Senate the last time around when we had
this bill you are correct that would be
a similar um comparison so it has not
fully passed in any state as I just said
to representative mbom thank you for
correcting me and I just wanted to did
pass in Wyoming and Arizona as I just
said to representative M Obama who asked
the same question that it passed the
state senate in both of those States
okay no but I want to clarify was it
signed into law by the governor I just
answered your
question right what what we've heard a
couple times is that two other states
senates have passed it but their houses
did not in this state our house passed
it last term but our Senate did not so
no State this this measure this type of
measure is not uh survive both houses to
get to any Governor's desk at least not
F Well I just wanted to to clarify since
it's never been signed into law you have
no way of knowing whether or not these
Financial penals would actually come to
pass is that
correct
well they have no way of knowing that
these Financial penalty I mean from your
perspective and the way that you're
asking that question they have no way of
knowing that these Financial penalties
would be imposed in fact the opposite we
know that the incoming defense secretary
has explicitly stated he supports this
type of legislation and would not
withhold funds and as I said in my
testimony sometimes fiscal notes are
wrong and state agencies don't always
know what federal government is going to
do and sometimes it's used as a scare
tactic to keep people from supporting
legislation which is quite common sense
that's that's my
testimony F what um but just to clarify
again uh perspective Secretary of
Defense uh ped H has also that said that
women shouldn't serve in combat and then
walked that back so are you saying that
we should just assume that what he said
before he got confirmed on Fox News is
what's actually going to happen I think
you're asking a question from a
political lens that I'm not going to
answer because it's uh frivolous and not
to the point of the legislation that
we're discussing here
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative wheeler good to see you
again always good to see you first of
all just one
comment I don't think the federal
government will ever get rid of the
National Guard because the going to need
us it's number one number two uh I know
you're a young guy but I was 14 in
1958 when the outgoing President
Eisenhower warned us about the military
industrial complex could you speak on
that I could representative gagy you
must I you and I didn't even coordinate
this that's beautiful but I forgot to
what I did forget in my in my testimony
EXC excuse me representative uh I want
to get into this I want to make sure our
focus is on the measure at hand and I
think I think I think it could be the
the I think I get representative gagne's
point it's a quick sure so let's uh
let's go ahead and develop that I think
what representative gagy was saying is
absolutely pertinent to what we were
talking about here and what President
Eisenhower said in 1952 in his farewell
address to the American public this is a
a piece to that uh one paragraph of that
address which I urge this committee to
go read it is pertinent in more than one
way to what this country is facing right
now he said quote this conjunction of an
immense military establishment and a
large arms industry is new in the
American Experience the total influence
economic political even spiritual is
felt in every city every state house
every Office of the federal government
we recognize the imperative need for
this development yet we toil yet we must
not fail to comprehend its grave
implications our toil resources and
livelihood are all involved so is the
very structure of our society in the
councils of government we must guard
against the acquisition of unwarranted
influence whether sought or unsought by
the military industrial complex the
potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists and will persist
and what he was discussing there is that
reality that we have seen over the last
82 years where a congress which has a
constitutional Duty as outlined 248
years ago in our founding documents have
sh that duty to defense Contracting
agencies which have gone about and
proposed illegal Wars that have killed
millions of people and left our service
members and industries feeling like this
country doesn't work for them anymore
and
questions representative cyber so um we
have multiple pretty large contracts
with companies here that reside in the
state of New
Hampshire um so we're going to be
stopping Sig sour from their contract
currently to create the new machine guns
and manufacture the new machine guns for
the military industrial complex
representative cyber that doesn't that
doesn't pertain to the legislation that
we have before us
here okay I think talking about my
concern from my previous comment is that
we're drifting a little bit into some uh
esoteric
areas uh which I understand the
connection that you made and and I let
you finish reading from uh president
eisen's farewell address which was in
January of 1961 to be clear but I want
to uh I want to uh not get redundant or
repetitive and we're getting there and I
want to move on to other speakers but is
there any other question for the
representative directly related to The
Measure at
hand and saying none thank you
representative much M Mr chair for your
time and uh representative Clayton wood
uh from Pittsfield is in the house
welcome thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee members uh as as the chair
said I'm representative wood represent
me 13 Pittsville and Chester I wasn't
going to um sorry I wasn't going to
address the committee today uh this
seemed to me when I first read it
something I would support uh who doesn't
want to file the Constitution do I
believe we're following the constitution
in the case of Nash God absolutely not
it didn't take me a lot of research to
come to that Co solution I must admit
the uh Financial part of this thing did
uh is uh concerning do I believe the
federal government will do this yes do I
I believe they'll do it in a way that we
won't even know it's happening we'll
we'll be because we don't have equipment
working we will not be able to to go to
a situation they'll pick another state
and keep their equipment working this
will be so clean it'll be surgical now
speaking about that uh that concerned me
coming in here but uh it must have been
Faith cuz I was while I was working on
this and looking through how the god
gets activated which is another another
bill that probably should be passed um
the several things came up I in the
background I have a computer on and uh I
find out that we you know we got
flooding all over the uh Carolinas
everywhere National Guard's not there
the National
Guard the previous testimony does a
great job saying how we get into
conflicts it seems like we help
everybody as well so the National Guard
in uh North Carolina they got three
battalions one that I could find is in
Africa working on infrastructure the two
others I couldn't find them I didn't do
a lot of research but they're not
available to the governor so we got
three battalions in this area definitely
have work to do there now do I think the
National Guard should be used as a First
Alert type of a measure absolutely not
but look around you um fires and and
North Carolina that didn't come up but
what came up was East Palestine Ohio now
do you remember that uh going to be
two-year anniversary next month it is
still a disaster it's unbelievable
disaster you may believe it or not but
it's not been remedy I look at this as
even being more than how we get
implemented I look at this as us
protecting us state if we have issues in
the state unfortunately uh I don't I'm
not aware of that require National Guard
even though I know National Guard is
used for a lot of things helicopter
rescues stuff like that that happens all
time in state I'm aware of that the um
we we need to to protect them and use
them am I against sending our National
Guard to uh the North Carolinas
absolutely not but I mean we just need
to know where they are we need to have
access to them should they be in Africa
I have no idea and I was actually
surprised that a uh that a state with
three battalions has none available
maybe I misread that and I will do some
follow-up work on it all I'm saying is
that this is not as complicated as a
world crisis uh it's as complicated a
day-to-day action that our federal
government is using our resources for
and and and you know they I know they
pay a lot for those resources but
they're not available to take care of
this of this country so I figured all
that coincidence I had to least pass it
on to this board thank you so much for
letting me testify and I will entertain
any questions I think the previous
speakers have done a great job by the
way thank you representative
mbom uh thank you Mr chairman um
representative would you would you mind
just clarifying your position on this
bill I will uh vote for the bill all
right thank you other
questions see uh representative
Hemingway sure sir thank you Mr chairman
um so you were saying that there was
three battalions in New Hampshire and
none of them are available not in New
Hampshire North Carolina North Carolina
okay um
follow um so in New Hampshire we have a
Balian unit and they have as from The
Briefing that we had this morning we
have the high Mars which is a highly
sought-after
weapon um and we also have the the
refuelers which has the newest uh
equipment out there so if we were to
take and say no defend the guard and we
start losing money as a previous uh
representative was talking about in the
Readiness status uh which is in fact
true um would you not see where we would
lose that ability and the the training
uh efficiency on that thank you for the
question is actually good question and
it does concern me I would be clear with
that
I actually think we need I love New
Hampshire we're the first at everything
if we could be the first one to pass
this bill I believe we will we will uh
create an environment where this bill
will we pass and we can use our troops
this only threatens us if we're the only
state as more states do it that threat
is less and less cuz I agree with one
gentleman said I'm sorry if I I didn't
remember the name they need us may have
been you they need us I know that that
but uh they will I know well that's my
answer thank
you follow
up yes sir thank you chair um so if we
were to pass defend the garden it would
go through where do you see New
Hampshire being as far as their um and
I'm interested in how this would be what
would be our primary Mission I mean our
our primary mission is to defend New
Hampshire and the United States with a
fur with a further on uh overseas as as
directed but as as we take this and
we're no longer focusing our training on
the artillery the mil the military
police the the metac unit that we have
the air guard unit that we have where do
you see that mission running yeah
another good question uh just a little
bit of uh uh research on this there is a
way of of activating the God and the go
federal government is involved is
clearly they they use training Advanced
Training uh code to implement them if
they stay in this country and part of
part of the solution and not part of a
problem I'm for that I I think New
Hampshire takes care of themselves I
don't see a lot of cases so far uh we we
know how to take care of ourselves we
know how to put out fires we know how to
do some of the stuff that other places
have forgotten how to do uh but there's
floods there's national disasters I
think uh when I was looking at this
quickly Louisiana had the same issue
with no um National Gods communication
there's a lot of places that I think the
national God would fit in and they don't
have to be in New Hampshire and and and
and doing what we want to do uh you know
we we want we want to be first in the
nation we want to take care of ourselves
we want to take care of the rest of of
of uh the citizens too as well so I look
at at a big picture I have absolutely no
problem I have no problem if they're
outside of this country if there's a
reason actually that training code that
I barely look through says it's supposed
to be in our territories in in this
country it has nothing to say about
being outside of of the country however
I do realize they call up other codes
too and I didn't get that far into it
this is way too complicated and it's
it's it's time for a state to draw a
line and correct it and I'm not looking
at changing a lot but changing to me the
important parts which which were
mentioned very uh carefully by some of
the other speakers as well thank you
other
questions seeing none thank you
representative thank okay I have two
more cards from uh state representatives
which we will go to and I know some of
the folks that are here and some of the
folks are watching uh very much want to
hear from um Major General mtis who is
here so just FYI we're going to go to
the the uh two reps and then um General
mtis is here and I know uh he uh
certainly he is the head of the guard in
New Hampshire so he he will be on double
deck following uh these next two uh
representative Murray is in the house
there she is
welcome she supports the bill and has
asked for two
minutes thank you Mr chair and thank you
to the committee members for hearing me
today I don't want to repeat too much of
what my colleagues have already said but
um I do want to focus in on this part
around the financials and the
constitutionality of
this just based on the facts Congress is
unconstitutional uh unconstitutionally
delegating their responsibilities to the
president whether it's through the
author authorization for the use of
military force or through the War Powers
Resolution both of those are un
unconstitutional so that's an abdication
of their duties as our representatives
in Congress um that should not be
happening like Point Blank period
and for me this is so interesting to
look at especially you know being here
in New Hampshire I can't think of any
other case at least off the top of my
head where we're letting the federal
government coers us into upholding
unconstitutional law because they're
holding this money above our heads and
telling us if you don't comply then you
don't get these funds and I don't think
we should let those threats keep us from
uh changing what we know to be wrong and
what we know to be um unconstitutional
especially when we all took an oath of
office to uphold our Constitution and my
opinion they're coercing us to break
that oath and I don't think we should be
letting the federal government
intimidate Us in that way um into
upholding this law and like my other
colleagues have mentioned I think we can
really set an example as the first state
to take this step and by taking the step
and breaking the ice and being the first
ones we will Empower other states to
make the same changes then it will be a
lot harder for the federal government to
enforce um you know take away funds from
a billion different states that are all
passing this legislation if we all take
this step forward together um and I
wanted to read um one quote from James
Madison that I think really speaks to
this the Constitution supposes what the
history of all governments demonstrates
that the executive is the branch of
power most interested in war and most
prone to it it has accordingly with
studied care vested the question of War
in the legislature and I think that is
really crucial to remember we don't want
to have a commander-in-chief who has the
sole authority to both be enacting the
calls to war and calling us to war
because that's authoritarianism we need
to have balances and checks and balances
on Power and that is why our
constitution was written the way it was
but that's all I had to say I'm willing
to take questions are there any
questions for representative
Murray representative Mandel bomb
thank you Mr chairman um representative
maray you and um some of our colleagues
who've testified um on behalf of this
Bill had mentioned that if multiple
states were to pass similar bills um the
federal government potentially
withholding funding would be less of an
issue are there similar instances where
maybe perhaps for other issues where
because multiple States have asked a
bill the federal government has said you
know what we're not going to cut funding
as opposed to just is that is that clear
yeah no I definitely understand what
you're asking I can't think of like a
perfect example off the top of my head
but I think there's a lot of um
instances where we've seen States wield
their power either singularly or
together in Coalition when they see um
or when they have disagreements with the
government um for example um and maybe I
don't personally agree with this but uh
I believe last year it was that um the
governor in Texas you know wasn't
complying with the federal government on
certain issues regarding the border and
the federal government did not move
forward on forcing them to comply
because they had that kind of like
political power to um I mean kind of
being like what are you going to do
about it you know and if we have enough
states that are passing this kind of
legislation I think we'll be in a
similar position where we're like this
is unconstitutional we are no longer
willing to comply with something that is
clearly
unconstitutional and yeah what are what
are they going to do about it thank you
thanks representative you just mentioned
constitutionality and we've heard that
time and again uh there are some folks
who think that it is not
unconstitutional you think it is
unconstitutional I'm hearing both of
those my question for you is do we want
to take the do you think there is a risk
in defang our National Guard uh to make
a a larger point about constitutionality
and and executive versus congressional
power uh is that a concern to you that
uh if if you're correct on the
constitutionality is it do you think
it's worth uh degrading our National
Guard uh and I know there's an argument
that they would never dare defund us but
you get you understand my question are
you concerned about If This Were to move
forward uh that it would degrade our
National Guard in the in the local
missions that we depend on our guard for
yeah I I definitely hear that I
definitely think that there is a risk
that is being taken by passing
legislation like this but I think we as
a state would come together if we needed
to to find more funds to um continue
supporting our National Guard I am not
an expert on the budget by any means but
I know that we do not have the amount of
Guardsmen right now that we have
allocated funds for so in my mind and
again I'm not an expert but there's
already money that we're not spending
right now that we have um and I think
we've seen this happen with other
legislation I believe we have um uh a
law around not enforcing
unconstitutional um laws relating to
guns like from the AFT um like any
regulations around that and we are also
taking risks in that area by not
complying with those things and I see
this as a similar you know New Hampshire
has such a dedication to being like live
for your die State we live by the
Constitution we live by our state
constitution and we don't let the
federal government bully us and this is
such a clear in my opinion they are
coercing us into maintaining
unconstitutional law and we're really
not saying that we're not willing to um
send our Guardsmen into war or into
active combat we're saying that they
need to demand that in a constitutional
way and they need to follow a con
constitutional process um so I do think
there's a risk that in my opinion um
adhering to our constitution is worth
that risk other questions representative
Jones uh thank you Mr chair you know
what I thank you very much for being
here and for your points uh I just
realized I think my question will be
answered when the general speaks so I'm
going to pass I think there is truth to
what you just
said okay uh thank you representative uh
one more uh state rep uh sticking with
our our tradition representative Heath
Howard is in support of the bill and
he's asked for three minutes welcome
back
representative thank
you thank you honorable chair and uh
committee members uh my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington in
straford District 4 I support HB 104
because the purpose of the National
Guard is to defend our nation to be
blunt I failed to see how deploying
these troops overseas uh defends our
nation without an official declaration
of war we have become accustomed to a
practice that cuts corners and fails to
meet basic constitutional requirements
because it is in compliance with
aumf like my friend from pelum had said
uh this seeds constitutional
responsibility from Congress to the
executive branch this is about trying to
ensure proper constitutional process is
followed in my opin
funding concerns are speculative at best
uh in my life I have never seen the
federal government to fund the military
and the placement of our federal
delegation uh on the relevant committees
to National Guard funding makes it
extremely
unlikely we have infrastructure in this
state that the federal government will
not abandon and I also do not believe
that the federal government would
abandon a state and refuse things like
disaster Aid this legislation is not
only anti-war War an anti-authoritarian
but Pro constitutionality and I think
you should be placing the Constitutional
process uh first over shaky rumors about
reduced funding thank
you did you say questions uh yes are
there any
questions seeing none thank you
you okay at this time uh Major General
molus is the uh Adit General the head of
the National Guard which is the subject
obviously of this uh of this measure and
uh I'm sure there were many folks very
interested in in what the general has to
say and uh I'm sure he'll take questions
he's asked he opposes the
bill uh he's already submitted
significant uh uh testimony written
uh thank you sir uh for the record uh
Major General David melus the AG general
for the New Hampshire National
Guard so in front of you is written
testimony um I sent that uh in advance
but in addition to the back of that
document is what's called Public Law
10740 Congress passed it in 2001 which
discusses the authoriz authorization of
use the military
force so let's take a step back and a
lot has been said let's try to distill
this into two big buckets um one is my
first thing I would offer to you is you
know when you read that u u the public
law this bill being opposed is the wrong
legislation and the wrong legislative
body this bill is not so is not so
veiled attempt to circumvent federal law
and the federal legislative process
everyone here today has discussed their
upset with Congress and the president
and who has who has advocated the war
power responsibility
that is for Congress to decide that is
not for this venue this legislative body
and for us to try to interpret does the
authorization use the military force
with has allowed our men and women to go
into Harm's Way whether it's valid or
not so let's just cut to the chase this
is Romper Room right it's up to Congress
to decide that not us number two what is
a National
Guard I I chuckle when those who have
not served in the National Guard try to
tell us that we need to be defended we
do not
first and foremost i' like to say this
is the National Guard is the operational
Force the operational reserve of the
United States Army and reserves the
American Publican Congress does not want
a large standing army therefore they've
made us the combat Reserve that's why
you see tanks himars hoarders airplanes
in the National
Guard so let's look at P's P's are
International Guard base has the modern
KC 46
refueler as I told you earlier this
morning we're one of 18 International
Guard bases with a refueling Wing 17
have the old Eisenhower uh era KC 135
New Hampshire is the only one with the
KC
46 so now let's talk about funding and
how they're funding for these things you
know um the federal government funds us
to be the a combat reserve of the United
States Army and Air Force that's why the
federal government puts us and gives us
training dollars so let's is still this
budget thing where I heard a lot of
different things and um comment about I
don't believe it how much is it this and
that so let me give you a couple facts
when the state of New Hampshire
activated in state active duty 15
soldiers to go to the Southwest border
for 60 days the paying allowance and
$600,000 there's 2,800 service members
in the New Hampshire National guard do
the math the pay and salary for 2800
service members from multiple ranks from
private first class to myself is $200
million the state of New Hampshire
provides us with the state active duty
account
$110,000 on an annual basis if we need
to be activated in response to harms way
in the state of New Hampshire so you
have $200 million versus $10,000
15 soldiers State active duty 60 days
operation loone star Southwest border
$600,000 do the math and bring that out
so they say hey Congress is going to
take your money we're going to be in New
Hampshire you all understand we're the
fourth smallest National Guard per
capita in the entire
country with two Congressional members
and two senators we are not New York we
are not Texas we are not
California he decided go first I would I
would caution you with the the these
anecdotes from the National Defense
authorization act with Congress just
passed this year think of these two
little like this um
vignettes first one is
um everyone understands the space force
was established approximately 5 six
years ago and if you understand a little
bit you know uh the National Guard were
like a space National Guard why is that
cuz seven states have Air National Guard
units with a space mission which is
equals 1100
Airmen Congress just gave the
authorization for the Secretary of the
Air Force to take those units from those
states without a Governor's
consent so when you think you're going
to tell the federal government that hey
we don't want to play by your rules and
we don't need your $395 million that's
pay allowances equipment training
infrastructure support you know that's
what I would offer you too the second
thing is um in addition to the example
what the space National Guard is so
generally speaking we are super proud of
P's Air National Guard base and I told
you many times we're the only Air
National Guard wing with a KC 46
refueler conceptually each state in the
past has been given an air guard wing
with a flying
Mission over the last decade or two uh
airplanes cost a lot of money every
state now long no longer does has a
flying Mission and in state are vying
for that airplan or a flying mission
again Congress in this past National
Defense authorization act just gave the
f-15s and the DC National Guard to the
Maryland Air National Guard because
Maryland lost their a10s because they're
being
divested so if you don't think Congress
will move equipment across state lines
because the four small State's going to
tell them we don't like your your
interpretation of was that
constitutional unconstitutional I would
warrant you against that and my and my
closing argument is how does the money
work this is how the money Works our
Congressional Delegation cannot defend
our money Congress appropriates the
money to the Department of Defense
Department of Defense appropriates down
to this uh National Guard Bureau that
games it that appropriation to the Army
and Air National Guard
respectively why would I fund a National
Guard who refuses to do its primary job
which is to fight America's Wars
that is all I have subject to your
questions thank you General to your
point that you just drill down on uh you
explained that some assets were moved
from one state from one guard to another
uh due to uh that state not following
expectations now an argument we heard
last term we've heard today is that the
uh we've been told that the we shouldn't
worry about losing Federal funding that
the that the feds would never dare to do
that so you kind of just spoke to that
but uh uh do you think there's there's
some truth to to the notion that the
fed's push comes to shove would not dare
defund
us why would they want to fund us when
we wouldn't do our
job our job is to be the combat Reserve
United States Army and Air Force which
is fight our nation's Wars regardless of
how you think what War or conflict we
are in that is not by decision right I
follow the lawful orders of my
commander-in-chief whether it's a
governor or the president of this
country so the we have himars we have
refuelers we have Canon artillery what
domestic emergency would we use that for
what an argument with the Canadians if
we lose a hockey
game other questions representative
menal bomb thank you Mr chairman so um a
hypothe hypothetical situation for you
so if New Hampshire were to pass such a
bill and the and our National Guard
would not be deployed overseas unless
Congress passes a declaration of
war if other states wanted to use some
of our resources
to go to a foreign state for instance if
they were to use some of our refueling
capabilities on the way overseas would
this are do you know if this bill would
prevent that so like preventing us from
contributing in any way to
uh ma'am if I understand it correctly I
think the answer is yes okay um so think
like this is my uh I would offer to you
that this would close P their National
Guard base okay wow thank you other
questions represent
Hemingway Major General mtis thank you
thank you
chair so as we go down here and and I
know this kind of goes into your your
background a little bit
um Edward Coss Center how was that built
100% federal
funds um follow
on so uh when we redid the uh the
building one how was that funded uh 100%
federal funds yeah we redil the redid
the the airfield on in Manchester how
was that fun uh 100% federal funds and
so in your opinion if we were to go
ahead and pass this bill do you think
you would have the money for those
buildings and that the time frame
that no no
uh one more followup
Che the as I as I asked the other
representative um what would be the
mission of New Hampshire National Guard
if we were to go ahead and pass this
bill we wouldn't have a federal Mission
and we would be so so think of it like
this right um the federal government
funds 100% of the salaries for the
soldiers and Airmen in the New Hampshire
National Guard the federal government
funds either and there's a cost share
100% of our maintenance facilities to
maintain our helicopters and our wheeled
Vehicles 100% of the aircraft adps and
then there's a lower cost share for like
our armories so an Armory those 18
armories that we discussed earlier today
they have a 5050 Federal general fund
cost year I would offered to you you
know when we say hey the fiscal note is
vague because we can't sort of calculate
the significant ramifications here the
$55 million is really our operating
budget so think of it like this our
operating budget for this department is
about 32 million Federal $7 million
State our Capital appropriation is
generally about an 8020 mix where we
probably bringing about 30 to 40 million
of federal dollars with about a $10
million cost a state general fund cost
share but all the equipment and to
maintain it all the salaries are all
funded representative
Gagney thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question talking about the
money I imagine that you and your the
people working with you um put bring
forth a budget what you need right yes
to the
feds do you get 100% of what you ask for
we're in a continuing resolution right
now so uh we're in a continuing
resolution right
now there are significant um fiscal
pressures on the federal budget we're
generally given sufficient funds to pay
our service members and operate the
us representative Buddha talki uh just a
quick
question so we had uh HB 55 just before
and now we are talking about 104 SB 104
FN uh Major General do you think that we
are discussing how to dis disentangle or
get away from the federal government or
that was a short
answer other questions yes uh represent
Jones thank you um thank you Mr chair
and thank you gent for being here uh a
recruiting based
question why is it that certain people
want the National Guard instead of going
to another branch of the military uh I'm
sure your recruiters are telling people
certain things about I don't want to say
too much
about not having to go to war overseas
and stuff like that uh and that's that's
part of what they're looking for I think
mine so I would say this for like you
know say why does a a young person man
or woman want to join the National Guard
I would generally say what we discussed
earlier this morning was um a sense of
purpose or service um something bigger
than themselves and number two is those
educational
opportunities so a person can like so
you know one of our lines is you can
live lve and serve here in the state of
New Hampshire right and the beauty of
the National Guard is with the only only
service with a dual mission right with a
commander-in chief who's a governor of
the state of New Hampshire and obviously
when called to title 10 active duty the
president United States so you know our
soldiers when they do search and rescues
in the state of New Hampshire when we
had almost 800 soldiers and well service
members um supporting the state of New
Hampshire during Co people want to help
their Community you know and that's what
state other
questions representative Lloyd thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question um currently as it stands right
now if our um New Hampshire National
Guard is called over to serve overseas
or move overseas would the governor be
able to say no we don't really want to
send New Hampshire National Guard I I
think we have a difference of opinion
between the bill sponsor it's our
opinion based upon us code that the
governor does not have a say when you're
activator on title 10 active duty the
governor does not have a
say other
questions see thank you so much general
for your testimony for being here today
this morning and this in this afternoon
I have nine more cards and we'll stay
here as long as it takes for everyone
toh say what they desire to say again I
would just ask that you not uh spend a
lot of time uh reiterating points that
we've already heard uh next up is a
former rep The Honorable John Graham who
opposes the bill is uh the honorable Mr
back of the committee um for the record
I am John and I live in
Bedford and yes I did serve a couple of
terms here um truth and lending I'm a
retired army officer regular army and I
just want to put a couple things into
context when I first put on the army
uniform NG stood for not
going because at that time very very few
National Guard units were called to
active duty for
Vietnam and let's just say that the
guard did not have a recruiting problem
back then because you weren't going to
get drafted and you weren't going to be
sent to
Vietnam however with the end of that
conflict and the virtually concurrent
end of the draft a new Force structure
Paradigm was
developed with the rapid desizing
downsizing the Army at that point um we
developed what was called the total
Force Under This
restructuring some 70% of the combat
service support units of the army things
such as Medical Transportation
maintenance supply were put into the
reserve component of which the National
Guard is
part additionally it was understood that
these units as well as the combat units
and the guard would be deployed with the
active forces during any crisis in the
words of the army Chiefs of Staff Katon
Abrams they are not going to take us to
oreg again without calling up the
reserves just a reminder that this type
of
restructuring was possible only by AC of
Congress and every defense budget every
National Defense authorization act and
every uh series of National Security and
defense policies since that
time have reiterate reiterated this
total Force
concept from a personal
perspective I will say that as a theater
level planner for de Desert Storm that c
campaign would not have been possible
without callup of National Guard
units now let's just talk about the Dual
nature I I know General mid's kind of
touched on it he probably touched on it
this
morning yes the governor is in command
of Our National Guard in peace time and
when it is activated for State
emergency however once the president
calls a guard unit to AC of service for
whatever purpose inally known as
federalization that unit becomes part of
the active force and the governor has no
authority over it let me say that again
once called to active Federal service
the governor has no authority over the
guard units that are so
activated thereby making this entire uh
Bill moot since it's beyond the legal
powers of the governor to deny um the
deployment of those units that have been
called active duty now we can argue at
infinitum about whether or not Congress
has abrogated its responsibility you
know there have been court cases that
were taken during the Vietnam war about
that
issue um and the only way the combat
operations in Vietnam actually ended was
Congress cut off funding for combat
operations in Vietnam on a certain date
so um they have done
that and in conclusion I'd just like to
say something Dick Cheney once remarked
that to serve in the National Guard is
to accept a dual Mission you can be
called upon to defend the country
against enemies abroad or to protect
lives and property here at home in times
of
emergency with all that in mind I would
ask that you find this bill in expedient
to legislate and if I was still on the
floor of the house I would actually move
indefinite postponement thank you Mr
chairman would you take any questions
I'll take them I may not answer
them are there any
questions uh having heard that you
probably won't answer them there are no
question you know me Mr chairman I would
have answered them yeah of course
welcome back good to see you and uh
right Kevin Grady was here this morning
he's here this afternoon from uh esac
state federal uh state federal state
veterans
advisory committee uh welcome back Mr
Grady asked for seven minutes uh and he
is oppos to the Bill thank you Mr
chairman and in fact I could probably do
it in less than seven minutes now that
I've uh allowed General mtis and and Mr
graah to go in front of me a lot of the
things I might have told you uh they
have already uh brought forth and I'm
I'll just kind of gloss over them again
for the record my name is Kevin Grady I
am a uh 25 year Air Force veteran and a
27y year veteran of the town of hookit
New Hampshire and here I'm representing
the state veterans advisory committee
that we talk to you about uh this
morning um we discussed this bill very
briefly at our our meeting and to be
honest we're we're so tired of this bill
we could absolutely throw up okay we we
opposed this bill in it in its different
form as HB 580 in the 2021 session and
the HB 1092 in the 2022 session we got
to see HB 229 twice because it was held
in this committee and then in the 23 uh
22 session it was resurrected I'm sorry
23 session was resurrected last fall and
passed the house in January of last year
and so and then it was retained in
Committee in the Senate so this is a
fifth year in a row that we've had to
come and tell you why we don't support
this
legislation um first of all let me start
by saying I don't doubt the sincerity of
the sponsors of this bill of the people
who you've listened to today talk to you
about their experiences okay I've have
no doubt that these people who have been
to combat on the ground have seen things
that no person should ever have to see
okay I we don't doubt that at all okay
but we do take a few exceptions here the
first and it's been sort of walked over
a little bit about how Congress hasn't
declared war since 1942 and the two
other places were Bulgaria and Hungary
as well as Romania we were just clean in
fourth of June of '92 uh 42 we were
cleaning up the people that had declared
war on us and we had declared war back
on them but I don't I think that it
doesn't mean they haven't exercised
their Authority okay as Mr Graham told
you you know Vietnam pretty much stopped
because the Congress C the money off and
and Congress had passed the tonen Gulf
resolution which chairman Moffett
alluded to earlier in 1964 which
essentially gave the president a blank
check do what you want go ahead ramp the
war up we don't care okay at the end of
the war the Congress said man that was a
bad idea holy crap that was a bad idea
so they pass War Powers Act it
overwhelmingly in the house
overwhelmingly in the Senate it went to
President Nixon's desk and he promptly
vetoed it and they said watch this and
they overrode a presidential veto and it
became the law of the land does that
sound to you like they're abating their
War fighting Powers doesn't to me okay
and I we think that the the evolution of
the authorization for the use of
military force concept it of course it
came out of that that bill because you
have 60 days you have to notify Congress
within 48 hours and you have 60 days to
do things with a 20 a 30-day
redeployment period otherwise we cut the
money off that's essentially what that
that bill says and so if you if you
think about how George HW Bush before
what became Desert Storm went and got an
authorization for the use of force why
it's required to by the warw resolution
okay same song separate verse President
George W bush for operations in
Afghanistan and then later into Iraq
they're required to get this
authorization and congress's use of the
aumf in our opinion is an evolution of
the war making powers of the Congress it
is a a rep it is a recognition of the
fact that the founding fathers would not
recognize what the world looks like
today airplanes aircraft carriers stuff
happening in Space the US is has argued
Ubly the economic superpower of the
world and probably the military
superpower of the world as well in terms
of capabilities okay they would never
have recognized this place so back in
the 1940s when we had to do things like
draft people when we had to do things
like like like rations and we had to do
things like I know your factory wants to
make this but we need you to make this
for the war effort we don't have to do
any of that anymore to to to we don't
have to do any of that anymore to uh
make sure that our interests are
protected where ever we think that they
need to be protected now we've listened
to a lot of different article you know
things about at the Congress they're
they're doing this they're doing that
yes and it's all at the Congressional
level between the Congress and the
president we are not going to solve this
problem from around this table in New
Hampshire I'm sorry we're not it's just
not going to happen Okay when I was in
the Air Force back in the dawn of time
the National Guard got the airplanes
that the Air Force was all done with and
didn't want fly anymore and they they
did great work with them and they lasted
a long time now look around you KC 46 is
at at at peas there are captains All
Over The Air Force flying an airplane
that's older than their grandparents in
the KC 135 okay they would love to be
flying that airplane but we have it here
okay next door in Vermont there are
captains flying f-16s that want to fly
the F35 we've got f35s in Vermont in the
guard okay when we downsized after
Desert Storm and and and and Mr Graham
alluded to this total Force concept we
basically said we're going to transfer a
lot of the really great capabilities we
have to the guard so the guard is not
now not a nice to have anymore if it
ever was it's a must have we have to
have our guard forces okay
but our guard forces have to be
available to us okay if we need these
forces we at the national command
Authority level need to be able to get
them and the way we get them is we
activate them via title 10 so the so if
you were to pass this legislation okay
and and the national command Authority
said we need these guys what likely
would happen would be they just activate
them and when you said hey hey hey you
can't do that well what forces are you
talking about we activated those those
are active duty forces now they belong
to me if they ever belong to you to
begin with okay they belong to us now
the guard in New Hampshire is a double
bonus for every single one of you in
this room it's a great bonus for you as
a as a taxpayer that we have this
capability here but it's also a bonus in
that when we have a guard in our state
we can do things like man a covid
vaccination site if we need to we can
have helicopters go and pluck people off
of the side of mountains that shouldn't
be there right you have a search at
Rescue Mission and you can do an actual
search and rescue boy the government
will pay for that all day long
the the general already talked about
what exactly how the money works you
know the the truth is you probably
wouldn't see if you were to pass this
legislation you wouldn't see anything
right away because it costs money to to
move forces but uh as the general said
you know if you start to see a KC 46
size hanger going in at Cape cot or
Portland you can see that handwriting on
the wall okay and that Congress doesn't
really have once it gets down to the
National Guard level doesn't really have
a lot to say in the matter they just
don't um
so the complaint if there is one here is
with the Congress and the president it
doesn't really have anything to do with
our National Guard and this bill is not
going to defend our guard it's just not
going to okay uh it's it's going to put
us in a rather precarious position and
and it it also you know it
essentially the way this works and and
General the general molit has already
said to you that the governor doesn't
get a say okay when when forces are
activated using title 10 the governor
doesn't get a say he can't complain
about where where they want to go that's
the federal law you want to take that to
court the judge the the first thing a
judge is going to say is this is a
federal law this is your state law right
we still have a supremacy clause in the
Constitution right okay I we're done
here
so it the important thing here is we're
not going to solve this problem from
here this this is legislation that um I
agree with Mr Graham you know if there's
a way for you to vote this thing off the
island permanently we would love to see
it subject to your questions that's all
I have today are there any
questions uh representative Mandel bum
and then representative Lloyd thank you
Mr chairman so
um would you kind of character
um the the aumf
as like adapting or the National Guard
I'm sorry I'm trying to figure out how
to phrase
um based around kind of the national or
the progression of the National Guard
over history from you know mostly being
ready I mean it obviously is ready to
deploy but um um for active you know War
versus I I I think the aumf has less to
do with the guard it has more to do with
with active duty forces and things like
that the problem that you have and and
what you see especially you'll hear
these cases like for example there were
a lot of guard units uh from from
Louisiana area who were deployed
overseas during a hurricane Katrina and
so there were a lot of folks that were
very upset about the fact that these
guys weren't at home and where they
where they thought that they needed to
be well they were doing their their
their wartime Mission uh over in Iraq at
the time Building Bridges and doing
other things that they were doing over
there because that's what their company
specialized in now that said all you
have to do is sort of look at the at the
history and what you would see is that
we invaded Iraq in the spring of
2003 okay Katrina was in August of 2004
by the by the time that you got to 200
the summer of 2004 every active duty
unit and their brother had been there at
least once and maybe twice so now it's
going to be the guard's turn to pick up
in that rotation and it's not like and
general mtis would tell you this it's
not like we don't know when our forces
are going to be activated to go do a
federal Mission we know that the folks
that are over there in in h the Middle
East I'm sure we've known about those
guys for at least a year or 18 months so
it's not like it's a big surprise
representative Lloyd thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you for taking my
question so if we theoretically if we
lost equipment funding resources uh from
the federal level what impact do you
foresee this having on Veterans Services
in
particular that's that's a hard one to
measure because the with with the the
authorizations for essentially all of
davs are are being paid paid right now
you know uh helped out by the federal
government so that's that's a that's a a
tough question for me to answer probably
might be easier for for uh the general
to to answer that question but um the
the idea of losing the services would be
you know if you're if you're the
Secretary of Defense okay and I've got
Reserve forces but I can't use them why
are they in the reserves why don't I
just pull them back and make them part
of the active force or why don't I move
them to a state that's going to that's
going to follow the
rules that's that that's the attitude
you're going to deal with if you pass
this legislation up the channel towards
the Guard Bureau that's the attitude
you're going to deal
with ma'am specifically um generally no
impact so the veteran service portfolio
is 100% generally funded for the 990,000
veterans in the state of New Hampshire
what could be impacted is the
collaboration of the military
resources that we have for our service
members because we do a lot of like just
collaboration amongst you know the guard
the military the veterans to say hey
where there's efficiencies in economy of
scale thank you very
questions thank you Mr Grady thanks for
the assist General thank you uh Eric
breaker is still in the house welcome
back Eric is from do and he supports the
bill
there we
go hello again thank you all for
conducting this public hearing my name
is Eric brei I'm a resident of Dover New
Hampshire as I previously stated in the
last hearing I served uh three terms in
the main State Senate before I recently
made the move to the LI for your die
state where I'm happy to be uh now and
um I will mention as well that uh during
my last term in the main Senate to uh
the the most recent past legisl I was
the bill sponsor for this very
Maine so I previously mention I'm a big
fan of Daniel Webster and it was nice to
walk into um this building today it's
actually my very first time
participating in a public hearing here
in New Hampshire and it was nice to see
that statue to Daniel Webster out
front and as I think about Daniel
Webster and I think about this
legislation I think about what he would
have said about it what he in fact did
say on this very issue uh he did not say
that it was a good idea for state
governments to pass legislation like
these the exact quote was it will be a
the solemn duty of state governments to
protect their own authority over their
own militia and to interpose between
their citizens and arbitrary power
wielded by the federal government so
that's not not my opinion that's Daniel
Webster's opinion that it is the solemn
duty of this legislature to pass
legislation like this in defense of your
State National
Guard it's been well over two decades
now since the dawn of the war on terror
I find it very interesting sitting here
listening to some of the arguments
against this
legislation and the but what's
particularly interesting is the
arguments that I am not hearing I'm not
hearing from anyone arguments we may
have heard maybe even a decade ago that
these wars that our State national
Guardsmen from the various 50 states
have accounted for almost half of the
troops on the ground in these wars in
the Middle East I don't hear the
arguments that these are Wars for
freedom for democracy for some Noble
purpose I don't hear the arguments that
there are clearly defined
missions which we clearly owe to those
we put into positions where they're
risking their lives
I don't hear arguments in favor of the
merits of these wars that we're sending
our our our um men and women in uniform
off off to fight in what I hear is well
what about
money uh I think it's been argued well
that I think a lot of the threats to U
money are somewhat of a paper tiger um
but you know one thing I've always long
admired uh from across the border in the
state of Maine was even on what seems
like small almost trivial matters of
individual human Liberty New Hampshire
has always kind of stood strong against
the federal government and saying no we
will not make those sacrifices for
federal funds I think about even
something as trivial as mandatory seat
Bel laws for adults New Hampshire is the
only state in the Union that told the
federal government go take your Federal
Highway funds and stuff it we're not
going to infringe on the Liberties of
our adult citizens to make these choices
for themselves uh I asked grock how much
is lost a year about 3.7 million
according to AI I don't know if that's
accurate or not and um aren't the lives
of our men and women in uniform worth at
least 15 times of the little piece of
freedom on whether or not to wear a seat
belt if we're willing to say to the
federal government we're standing on a
principle for the Liberties of our
citizens in that case should that not
apply even more so here but let's talk
about the constitu because I think there
were a lot of arguments around the
Constitution made here I think it's very
worth understanding zeroing in on what
specifically the Constitution says about
this the Constitution says that the
federal government May mobilize the
militias which we now call the National
Guard under three circumstances and
three circumstances alone to suppress
Insurrection to repel Invasion to
enforce the laws of the union and to
take an example that was used previously
by the bill sponsor represent pres of
Tom Manion of Syria a war that we had
been engaged in now for over 10 years
without even a clear aumf or or clear
authorization what is the
Constitutional um justification for
having National Guard troops in a
conflict like that were we suppressing
an Insurrection actually the mission in
Syria was to ferment an Insurrection and
to ferment a civil war against the
established government there um was it
to repel an invasion now was an invasion
but we weren't the ones repelling it we
were not invited there was it to enforce
a law of the Union it very well could
have been if there had been a
congressional declaration of war as the
Constitution requires uh even if you
accept the argument of an aumf covering
that requirement which I don't accept
it's it's very clear there was no aumf
that covered this because um they point
to the 2001 aumf which was passed in the
aftermath of the 911 Twin Tower attacks
when we were attacked by Al-Qaeda
presumably this is
to fight the the folks who attacked us
on that terrible day and yet uh we
actively gave weapons and Aid and
comfort to Al-Qaeda forces in Syria so
it's hard to imagine how that aumf could
apply to that
situation uh James Madison spoke
eloquently about the need and when
studied care why they separated the
power to declare war from the power to
wage war because the executive has the
most gain in times of War this principle
has been totally lost in recent history
we've heard about the supremacy clause
and how the supremacy clause supposedly
means means we need to bow down in
deference to everything the federal
government mandates on us but that's not
how to properly understand the supremacy
clause they have Supremacy over powers
that are exp explicitly granted to them
the the specific enumerated powers in
Article 1 Section 8 of the US
Constitution which includes the power to
declare war if they declared war we
would be subject to the supremacy clause
but as so long as they do not declare
war that does not apply here the fact of
the matter is Congress won't do its job
because it's very convenient not to uh
the last time even even the aumf on the
war in Iraq when it was voted on there
was some mechanism for people to look at
people's voting records and to hold uh
Representatives accountable in election
season if they found that to be uh a not
very prudent course action and
politicians did lose their jobs in the
aftermath of that fact Hillary Clinton
didn't become president because of that
instead you got a rookie US senator from
Illinois Barack Obama on that particular
issue one one one the primary so there
was a a chilling effect sent throughout
Congress we don't want to ever vote on
war ever again but it's really nice to
keep collecting checks from the
companies that are making money on these
wars and so what we've seen over the
course of the last two decades are
situations like we saw revealed in the
Afghanistan papers of self-licking ice
cream cones forever Wars that just go on
and on and on with no clear Mission
whatsoever uh and the ex the price is
paid not just by the us taxpayers but by
our soldiers who we send off without
clear
missions I remember um a good friend of
mine um who I worked with on this
legislation in the state of Maine his
name was Sergeant Aaron Rollins he had
served in Iraq in the main Army National
Guard and on one uh one fateful day uh
they they were um their vehicle uh hit a
roadside bomb and his um one of his uh
companions was tragically killed that
day sitting in the seat where he
normally would have been SE seated
himself I remember um after the public
Hearing in Maine two years ago when the
agitant general made I think similar
arguments to what we've heard heard
today about concerns about money
after that Sergeant Rollins turned to me
and just saidou know I wish that the
agitant general would say that to my
mother my my friend's mother's face that
his death was worth it because the state
got a few extra Humvees out of the deal
I don't think that that is a um an
argument we would accept in many other
situations where there's there are
significant moral questions at stake um
if uh I know there are wide ranging
opinions on other issues like abortion
you know would we whatever someone's
moral conviction is on an issue like
abortion would we overthrow that moral
opinion be if the federal government
started throwing money around one way or
the other I I don't think so you need to
suspend for a moment yes we I think
we're all tracking your point about the
government's role in decision- making
and financing and in abortion we're
getting a little bit off off the uh the
focus on this particular measure uh
there may be a couple of questions for
you but uh I I want to give you a chance
to finish and we s of five other folks
that we want to give some time to
understood I appreciate that I will wrap
up uh trying to uh make an analogy but I
understand the concern there I'll just
close by saying
um you know we are at a point the the
incoming Secretary of Defense or at
least who has been appointed and the
incoming National Intelligence director
who has been appointed both support this
legislation or have been on record in
support of it um I think now is the time
to really lay down this principle on the
state level and and I I hear what people
say that wouldn't it be nice if this
could be solved on the federal level but
there's a convergence of interests that
don't want this to be solved on the
federal level uh and so therefore as
Daniel Webster told us it is the solemn
duty of the states to interpose and to
stand up for our men and women in
uniform and so I certainly as a new
resident of New Hampshire I would ask
you to do do your solemn Duty and to
support this legislation thank you if
there are questions I'm happy to take
them or to defer to others I I do have a
quick question I naturally am curious uh
you shared that you were a state senator
and you introduced a similar measure or
the same measure in Maine uh what what
happened uh in Maine when when you
introduced this in the Maine Senate yeah
there's a long history of this in Maine
it was actually um I'll give you the
short yeah yeah give us the short answer
all right Maine was the first state to
ever put this in in 2011 11 um two years
ago it received a uh uh a third of the
House of Representatives voted in
support of the bill with a with
bipartisan support but there's still uh
a lot more uh work that needs to be done
in Maine and other states but I think it
would be very poetic and also very
righteous if uh New Hampshire followed
Daniel Webster's call and was the first
other questions repr mle bomb thank you
Mr chairman um Mr Brey I don't want to
get too into the semantic Weeds about
your seat Bel law analogy um but
ultimately whether or not you wear a
seat belt you are the person who faces
the most proximate impact so if you're
in an accident you will likely either
stay seated or perhaps go through the
windshield but that's on you I'm
wondering um you do you feel your
argument holds up given that we could
have argued that the National Guard is a
Collective good so um it it's not just
about the person wearing this you know
it's the person wearing the seat Bel
isn't the only person affected it's when
you have National Guard members deployed
they're doing work on behalf of the
United
States would just say I think it's far
more important than any seat Bel law I
think that it is um I think that we have
a solemn duty to the men and women who
sign up to serve who are in a position
where they cannot speak up they cannot
question their orders they are given
commands to go it is our solemn Duty as
the citizens of the state and this
country to hold accountable the
officials who make these decisions when
those decisions are made poorly and
right now there is no accountability
measure because our elected officials
don't vote they don't do their jobs and
so I would say it's even more important
follow
up thank you Mr chairman so is the
difference in your mind more that Justus
as folks can choose to wear a seat belt
folks in the National or choose not to
folks in the National Guard do not have
decision-making power when it comes to
being
deployed once they sign up to serve
their state and the State National Guard
they uh do not have much say about about
these deployments therefore it is the
responsibility of the citizenry to make
sure that the system is function in an
accountable fashion thank you other
questions seeing none thank you so much
for that testimony thank you Mr chair we
have we do have another former
representative here uh we did yes we
geard who is a former member of this
body who supports the bill he's asked
for three minutes and yeah I'll make it
shorter than that thank you chairman uh
Just for future notice I I don't like
the honorable title any titles of
nobility kind of make me a little quey
but I want to so noted thank you so I
wanted to raise a few
points we we seem to be getting caught
up in this money argument and previous
speakers already talked about the
absurdity of trying to put a price on
the lives of our New Hampshire neighbors
to go fight Wars that are never ending
but also I would like to talk about the
suicides so this is an article from July
15th of
2024 from Boston University suicide now
the primary cause of death among active
duty US soldiers quick paragraph a
recent study released by The Pentagon
revealed a sobering statistic US US
soldiers are now more likely to die from
suicide than any other cause the report
which examined the deaths of 2530 active
duty army soldiers between 2014 and 2019
showed that soldiers are nearly nine
times more likely to die by Suicide than
they are in combat and I just worry that
we kind of focus on the combat deaths
which are horrible as it may as they are
but we also we need to think about about
the guys that are living on the streets
or other kinds of horrible situations
that occur from the trauma of combat
combat that I'm 39 years old now my twin
brother identical twin brother joined a
National Guard in 03 shipped out in ' 04
he ended up going active duty but he
went over to Iraq and we have we've
never been out of War since then I mean
I'm 39 I mean it's absurd when you
really sit back and you look at it we
it's just constant War for various
madeup make you know reasons let's look
at one of these that was raised earlier
which would be sorry phone's acting up
the Gulf of tonen this is from the US
Naval um magazine I'm sorry I'm having a
trou figure US Naval Institute magazine
the truth about tonen this lead
paragraph questions about the Gulf of
tonen incidents have persisted for more
than 40 years but once classified
documents and tapes released in the past
several years combined with previously
uncovered facts make clear that High
government officials distorted facts and
deceived the American public about
events that led to the full us
involvement in the Vietnam
War so like many other people I question
the motives of our federal government
and some in state government but I just
I I feel that we're giving too
much leeway to people who have blatantly
disrespected the Constitution which they
sworn oath to uphold and which all of
you have as well and I as well as our
military person
and another man who just this last
closing thing Major General Smedley
Butler who wrote War is a racket is very
quick pamphlet got to read it very good
but he Ser he was born in 1881 died in
1940 but he was a United States Marine
Corps officer and writer 34 years he
fought in the Philippine American war
box Rebellion Mexican Revolution World
War I and the banana Wars at time of his
death Butler was the most decorated
Marine in US military history by the end
of his career Butler received 16 medals
including five for har ISM he's the only
Marine to be rewarded the Marine Corps
brevit medal as well as two Medals of
Honor all for separate actions two
quotes from him very quick I believe in
adequate defense at the coastline and
nothing else if a nation comes over to
here to fight then we'll fight the
trouble with America is that when the
dollar only earns six 6% over here then
it gets restless and goes overseas to
get 100% then the flag follows the
dollar and soldiers follow the flag next
quote there are only two reasons why you
should ever be asked to give your
youngsters one is defense of our homes
the other is defense of our Bill of
Rights and particularly the right to
worship God as we see fit every other
reason advance for the murder of young
simple
and oh actually one last thing we we
were asked about has this ever passed
any other state hous and so forth but
last year representative Manion actually
had this passed at the GOP State
Convention and it was put onto the
platform so it is officially part of the
Republican Party platform now now what
that really is worth I don't know but I
just want to make that clear that there
is widespread widespread support among
the rank and file of well half of the
political part you know people in the
country I guess you could say and I I
really believe that we need to look at
this outside of the money aspect or we
have the newest flashiest aircraft all
these absurd things we got to look at
people in this country and how they're
existing right now and do they even know
where these places are that we're going
to send our soldiers off the diet they
don't it's fact I mean I can argue other
things for that reason but so that's all
I wanted to raise and uh thank you very
much would you take any questions if
there are any sure all right uh
representative mle bomb uh thank you Mr
chairman um so just to clarify when you
studied that statistic about um US
soldiers who are much more likely to die
by Suicide than any other cause um was
that overall was that broken down by
National Guard service members versus
someone who might be in the Marines
I'm just curious if there might be any
any differences it's from Boston
University I'd be happy to forward it to
the committee but at the same time as we
heard the general rise the National
Guard soldiers don't wear a different
uniform they are active Army so there is
no difference as far as I understand
Maybe I'm Wrong I only serve two and a
half weeks in the Army long story but
thank
you other
questions thank you for coming in and
thank you for your testimony I do have
did I say that correctly no you did not
close enough would you close enough okay
Peter asked for three minutes to oppose
the Bill thank you Mr chairman my name
is Peter Kowski I'm a retired US army
colonel with 30 years of active service
I served seven years as a regular army
officer and 23 in the reserves my last
two tours were advisers to the states
agitant general of Massachusetts and
state of New Hampshire I served under
Major General Kenneth Clark and Major
General Bill Rudell as the expert in
homeland security and Homeland
defense the following information was
taken from Supreme Court Justice Stevens
who delivered a unanimous opinion on
perit versus Department of Defense since
1933 federal law has provided that
persons enlisting in the National Guard
simultaneously enlist in the National
Guard of the United States a part of the
greater US Army
the enlistees retain their status as
state guard members unless and until
ordered to active Federal Duty and
revert to State status upon being
returned from federal service the
authority to order National Guard to
Federal Duty was limited to periods of
National Emergency until
1952 when Congress broadly authorized
orders to quote to active duty or active
duty for training unquote without any
emergency requirement but provided that
such orders could not be issued without
the consent of the governor concerned
after two State Governors refused to
consent for federal training missions
abroad for their guard units the
gubernatorial consent requirement was
partially repealed in 1986 by the
Montgomery Amendment which provides that
a governor cannot withhold consent with
regard to active duty status outside of
the United States because of Any
objection to the location purpose type
or schedule of such Duty article one's
plain language read as a whole
establishes that Congress May authorize
members of the National Guard of the
United States to be ordered to federal
act of Duty for the purpose of training
outside of the United States with either
the consent or without the consent of
the governor or any de Declaration of
National
Emergency the interpretation presented
recognizes the supremacy of federal
power in military Affairs and does not
significantly affect the state's basic
training responsibility or its ability
to rely on its own guard in emergency
situations in my opinion the national
New Hampshire National Guard cannot
support and defend the Constitution of
the United States and New Hampshire law
if they are in Conflict if the conflict
exists by implementing
hb04 dfn the Department of Defense will
cut funding to the New Hampshire
National Guard and move it to states
with similar mission capab abilities and
no conflict the net result will be an
annual loss of $395 million and the loss
of 2700 jobs soldiers and Airmen and
women in New Hampshire will potentially
lose their military careers or suffer
the inconvenience of relocating to
another state I stand in opposition to
questions are there any
questions uh yes I'm sorry
representative V go ahead thank you um
could you just say again uh what the
name of that case was that you mentioned
at the beginning of your testimony
perich versus
dod.
496 us
334 open parentheses 1990 close
parentheses thank you other
questions uh go ahead Senator I go ahead
I'm getting tired uh representative
Hemingway go ahead thank you Mr chair uh
sir um thank you for coming in your
service um so I had asked this to two
other people where do you see the
training and the fs of the National
Guard If This Were to pass If This Were
to pass those High valued assets that
the general had previously mentioned
would go to other states who would
happily take them and in Pete's opinion
who did serve in States down south um
they value their their military assets
at a much greater level than we hear in
the National in New Hampshire uh by
virtue of the size um as the general
appropriately mentioned we're the fourth
smallest um those other states which
have very large National Guard units
would more than happy to take the
refueling Wing would be more than happy
to take the high Mars uh because they
are high valued
assets other
questions thank you for your testimony
and thank you for your service you're
PR welcome Derek Derek supports the
measure he supports the bill he's asked
for three minutes and he has a handout
thank you chairman Moffett members of
the committee my name is Derek PR um
from Derry New Hampshire I'm a uh
veteran sergeant of the New Hampshire
Army National Guard served for six years
there and I'm also on a volunteer basis
the state director for bring our troops
home which is a veteran run organization
that is advocating for this defend the
guard legislation um I kind of just want
to take my time to just go over uh some
of the things that have been uh you know
said today um so defend the guard
completely within Constitution right
Article 1 Section 8 we're trying to come
back to the Constitution we've moved so
far away from it that's what this
legislation is trying to do it does not
conflict with the United States
Constitution it does not conflict with
us code um any reference to defend the
guard legislation with 32 activations
just ignore it completely right in in
the bill text it is specifically uh
talking about title 10 so anything about
title 32 just completely ignore it um
title 10 section 12301 subsection F
which we've heard which is that
Montgomery amendment that only deals
with um uh where was it right here
um uh type schedule uh purpose and
location of a deployment uh defend the
guard does not deal with any of that uh
it deals with uh Congress uh not taking
action and declaring war in accordance
with the United States Constitution so
to argue that the government you know
doesn't have a say in the matter that is
not what title 10 uh section 12 through1
says it specifically says that the
governor does have a say in this matter
um so if if when they introduce the mtom
amendment like representative Manion
said if they didn't want the governor to
have a say then they wouldn't have left
it in there um they would have just
taken it right out um authorizations for
the use of military force um as it's
already been said these are turning the
whole War making process on its head and
Congress abdicating its
responsibilities to the executive branch
um since the 2001 aumf um 88% of
Congress has has lost their seat um and
new people have come in um but now these
new people where we've passed this AMF
it has been repealed and it's been used
in in over 20 different
countries um over more than you know 25
years uh you know there's no
um bra which is base realignment
enclosure um since uh 2014 the
ndaa
um it right here sorry I got my notes a
little messed up right
now H right here uh National Defense
authorization act for fiscal year 2014
specifically prohibits authorization of
future Brack based realignment enclosure
um again another bullying tactic that
you shouldn't fold to um closing and
moving round guard units uh we put a
significant logistical and financial
strain on our military it's easy for
someone to threaten these things it's
another thing to actually do it um and
you know that goes along with the
funding threats um you know we continue
to to to hear these funding threats um
you
know no member of Congress no DOD
official has ever said that if a state
passes this they will lose funding right
the language that is always use is at
risk or at Jeopardy right these are
coercive measures
um defunding a state's national guard
would be politically unpopular and would
also risk the guard's ability to respond
to real national uh and and state
emergencies whether that be a military
emergency or a natural disaster it would
put the guard's capabilities um at R and
they they won't do it because we need
the National Guard um the National
Guard's
purpose as part of the uh the militia
Clause is to repel Invasion suppress
Insurrection and uphold the laws of the
Union um that's the reason that they
that they exist um and so
um you know what would be the guard's
mission right continue to go along with
that uh representative haming way uh
what does that look like it looks like
what it would look like right now you
know ready combat Readiness we do our uh
our uh our fire tables oh was uh
artillery High Mar's unit we do our fire
tables we do it in Littleton we do it in
Nashua uh we've done it in Michigan for
gring we've done it in Hungary right we
can continue training for combat should
the need arises um that's what training
with the National Guard would look like
before this bill and after this bill
this isn't saying that we'll never go
into a combat ever again this is saying
that when Congress does its job and gets
fully
behind the National Guard then New
Hampshire will send
uh our troops and again this is
referring to overseas combat um I
believe it was representative manle bomb
you asked about um uh the refueling um
you know overseas combat combat being
shooting at or getting shot at so
refueling you know wouldn't fall into
you know that definition of combat um
you know I think you also representative
man bomb you said you know what other
states are doing things that might be
contradictory to what the federal
government wants um I mean like it's
been saying seat belt um also cannabis
legalization that would be like another
thing that's going around the country um
you know it's the general mades he
referred you know that this is not the
body to make these kinds of decisions uh
we've already heard the Daniel Webster
quote um that it is our solemn duty to
actually do this right here but you know
we also you read Federalist Papers um
you know the Federalist Papers was a
real discussion between the Federalist
and the Anti-Federalist before the
ratification of the US Constitution and
there was a lot of concerns brought up
and our founding fathers The Architects
of the US
Constitution they specifically said that
if the federal government starts acting
in ways that are outside of you know the
ideals of the Revolution that they just
fought outside of the Constitution then
the states should and it is their duty
to act to bring Congress back to the
Republic uh should it move away this
this was the conversation that was going
this is what our Founders said um you
know we've talked about uh Madison uh
who talked about you know uh the
executive branch being most prone to war
you know a lot of that has to do with
you know like I said they just fought
the revolution um you had the French and
Indian War where the crown had robbed
the treasury and uh through you know all
these wars and so when they wrote the
article one section 8 putting War Powers
with the people they specifically wanted
to keep War away from the executive most
prone to it um and um well I mean what's
the state of our treasury uh since we've
kind of moved away from following our
constitutional uh War making
responsibilities um it hasn't been great
um Purp versus DOD um if you read the
the Supreme Court summary only relates
to training uh has says nothing about
combat it only says training so perp
versus dad has nothing to do with this
bill this bill doesn't say that we can't
you know go over to Hungary or El
Salvador or Cabo Verde uh to continue to
train with our allies um so it is not in
conflict with uh perit versus
DOD um widespread support for this bill
uh it's already been mentioned this is
in the nhgop party platform this bill
has been supported by the ACLU of New
Hampshire as well as tons of other ACLU
chapters around the country it's also in
uh multiple other uh State GOP uh party
platforms um last year the Texas GOP put
the question of supporting defend the
guard in the uh uh during the na the
Texas GOP primary as a ballot
proposition 84% of Texas GOP voters
supported this bill so that's 1.8
million people voted for this measure
they want the Texas GOP to pass this
kind of
legislation
um yeah I'm open to uh any oh um right
it's been mention Pete hegseth our
incoming Secretary of Defense on Fox and
Friends National Television after the
New Hampshire house passed this bill
last year came out in full support and
endorsed this bill and our guys met with
Pete hegseth two weeks ago for very
lengthy conversation multiple hours he
has reaffirmed his support for this bill
he has said that he will direct the
Department of Defense to be in full
support of this legislation do
everything in his power to get this bill
passed in every single state and uh he
says that he finds uh opposition within
the Department of Defense to this bill
uh very offensive to him in his words so
um open to any other questions so
representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question and if I heard you
right you're an active member now a
sergeant in the National Guard former
former a former you're no longer part of
the national that is correct okay
thank
you representative
mom uh thank you Mr chairman um so I've
heard a number of people who've
testified today talk about the
constitutionality of this bill and
candidly I am not a constitutional
scholar um so when you say that this
bill does not conflict with the US
Constitution is that based on your own
reading of the Constitution or from
experts in constitutional
law uh my reading
constitutional Scholars and also the
opinions of The Architects of the
Constitution founding follows James
Madison right thank
you representative
flos so I've been taking a list of stuff
I need to look up before I make up my
mind on this um when you said you were
talking about Brack and then you said
something that sounded like it might
have been statutory language or a quote
or something afterwards yeah so Brack is
base realignment enclosure right and the
2014 National Defense authorization act
uh permanently bans future
you it's my turn representative uh I
actually a TW for I seem to hear clearly
from you that the incoming likely
incoming secretary of defense is all on
board with this type of measure uh am I
hearing you correctly that is very
correct yes and it you know it's very
you know I think as of today he has the
votes and I think you know even some
democrat Senators right I I I'm assuming
that he's going to be a confirmed so
assuming that so support we met him with
him for multiple hours that's a very
powerful statement and you're you're
confident in saying that the SE def is
for this yes that is correct okay and my
second question uh has to do I'm looking
at the handout that you gave us again
thank thanks to anyone who takes time to
give us a handout which he gives us a
chance to review uh the congressman from
Arizona wrote or said that uh the
federal government needs a well-prepared
guard the house would never uh cut
funding for the guard the house controls
the pur strings uh so Congressman said
that other people a lot of people last
year this year have said that they would
never dare defund us uh I I keep hearing
that but I also heard the the the
colonel your predecessor who spoke uh uh
said that they would and uh the agitant
general said that our asset assets would
be moved uh if if we if this passed it
it sounds like our guard would be
eviscerated so how it's it's a little
bit to me S of a little bit like a game
of chicken uh you know you're saying if
this passes uh they wouldn't there cut
our funding and I how confident are you
that that would be the case are you are
you 100% confident that I am 100%
confident so you know liking my hand out
we got multiple members of Congress and
you know representative goar and uh
Congressman Massie they went around and
asked all their colleagues about this
bill would if this happened would you be
in favor of voting of defunding Estates
no member of Congress would it's
political suicide no one would ever dare
do that um and also one of my handouts
is actually from uh Kansas um and their
fiscal report from their agitant General
uh who said that there would be no
fiscal impact so we've got one adant
General saying one thing another ad
General saying a different thing we get
member of Congress saying that you know
it won't be
defunded I think we can just throw this
funding concern out the window cuz it's
not clear we just need to focus us on
the Constitution uh what's been going on
uh in terms of our foreign policy um in
terms of uh losing our morality as a
nation as well as losing Financial
stability in this country because of our
conduct um and you know it's up to to
this body it you know like that Daniel
Webster quote it's up to this body to to
protect our National Guard and to make
sure that Congress does its job first
before we send s them into Harm's Way
okay represent manal bomb and repres
represent cyber do you have hand up no
she had it up first well it's your
turn oh okay um no I just a question um
about the this particular fiscal note um
just I would feel more comfortable
actually seeing one from this one is
just it looks like the adjunct General
is cced on this message after it has
been written up and sent it is from the
Kansas Division of the budget but it's
essentially kind of like I'm guessing
our LBA because it's a letter from the
chairperson um on the senate committee
that's our you know similar committee
there whatever but for their Senate so I
would actually like to see that and
possibly I'll try to get in touch with
them how about that actually get their
opinion on that and the similarities
between our situation sure okay I I
think you know like it says highlighted
there right the ad General's Department
states that the enactment of their
version of this bill would not have a
fiscal effect yeah I would just have
feel more comfortable hearing it from
them sure directly thank
you manom uh thank you Mr chairman so um
you mentioned congressman goar and
Massie have noted that there wouldn't be
defunding for pass to such a bill in a
state I'm curious what New Hampshire's
Federal delegation has said about this
bill I haven't heard anything from them
right other questions uh repr
Hemingway thank you chair uh welcome and
thank you for your service um so you
mentioned Brack and bra does that
include National Guard units because I
don't believe so I think that's only for
for the uh
Federal I I'm couldn't answer that
question I imagine that Brack would
include like things like peas
but p is p is kind of a National Guard
unit it's an air guard right and uh I
can tell you that within New Hampshire
that they have closed down bases and
realigned forces to meet the to meet the
uh training requirements are the are the
mission so Brack in my opinion does not
qualify as part of a National Guard uh
regulation okay follow up follow up uh
the other thing is and I I do believe
you say you continue doing training with
the himars and other things and in
different areas yes I've been there done
that and um the only thing is that there
is
nothing that will take more serious and
than someone that's actually going over
there to use the equipment that they've
been trained on that is what people are
are look forward to and not everyone a
agreed um but you you want to have a
purpose for that mission and when you
say that you may the only reason why you
don't get called up is by the by
Congress
and you haven't been called up in by
Congress since
1942 I remember when I came under the
guard back in the 90s we were running
around in equipment from the from the
60s and we went overseas that equipment
went overseas twice once with Desert
Storm and once with Iraq um oif2
thin skin no armor in a combat zone but
when we got back because he kept that
equipment there because it was no good
we got our brand new equipment and
reason being is because we went on a
mission we defended our country and this
is why we got the money so you
you sit there and say 100% that the
funding is not going to be
denied I I kind of
differ okay I mean so I mean training I
I'm not willing to throw away uh lives
of national Guardsmen
or uh throw the constitution in the
trash bin uh just for experience right I
think I don't think anyone should
experience combat um I think we can
train to it uh to meet it if the time
comes and I don't think that this bill
conflicts with that um but I don't think
that we should be throwing lives away or
the con stitution uh just for the
experience of
combat other
questions s thank you so much for that
testimony and for taking our questions
thank you so much okay have three more
cards I have actually now I have a
fourth card from a representative as is
our custom we do want to uh give
courtesy to our sitting Representatives
uh representative Kelly Penza is she
still here yes she
is uh has asked for five minutes to
bill welcome
representative thank you
chairman so uh for the record my name is
uh representative Kelly Venza I'm
representing straford District
19 um so I'm so thankful to be here
today uh in strong support of this
legislation um I was thrilled when this
passed the New Hampshire House of
Representatives last term um um and was
honored to help in that
endeavor it seems like a lifetime ago
that I was enlisted in the Armory
Reserve in
1991 uh and due to my Massachusetts
reserve unit that actually uh
deactivated after I was trained under my
first M which was a 77 whiskey I was a
water dog in which I missed the first
Iraq deployment only by two weeks um
because my unit wasn't fully trained it
wasn't in a state of Readiness yet um I
was actually transferred into the
Massachusetts Army National Guard for
the next 6 to S years and retrained
under a new MOS so that was in
1992 um I was a 94 Bravo at that point
uh NBC decontamination unit and
subsequently I missed the next Iraq
deployment by a very slim margin of time
as
well the amount of Massachusetts Army
National Guard injuries that I witnessed
firsthand um in 19 1992 and 1993 alone
were
atrocious we all know what took place
over multiple conflicts under multiple
presidencies all under false pretenses
US
security you know excuses weapons of
mass destruction Etc but most
importantly um all really to line the
highest level of people's pockets from
political powers to NOS to corporations
in regards with oil and more with
everything happening in our country
right now the focus I believe needs to
be on the United States of America and
our state um if you just look at what's
going on um in California the horrible
fires and and if we didn't have our
National Guard because they were out
fighting some endless war that's a
problem and I believe that we have to
come first so if you just look at the
three operations in Iraq which included
operation Iraqi Freedom operation New
Dawn and operation inherent resolve uh
4,600 US troops died the war officially
ended in December 15th of
2011 but the majority of deaths actually
occurred between 2009 and
2012 48% of those deaths were caused by
explosive devices
IEDs um my very a very good friend um
that I went to high school with with was
blown up by one of those
War without a formal declaration of war
from commer stems from legal ethical and
practical considerations tied to the
rule of law the separation of powers and
Democratic principles and here's why it
matters Constitution Authority article
one section 8 is crystal clear and every
single one of us here took an oath to
the New Hampshire Constitution and the
US Constitution that's it that's clear
as day this ensures that the decision to
go to War reflects the collective will
of the people through their elected
representatives I don't work for myself
I work for the New Hampshire citizens
and we all do and that's where we should
be taking everything from the War Powers
Resolution of 1973 was enacted to preses
this was really because presidents were
basically unilaterally just going off
and that was put in place to present
presidents from unilaterally engaging in
prolonged milit Ary conflicts without
consulting
Congress it allows limited Military
action we know that that has that's far
gone now in emergencies or prolonged
deployments without Congressional
approval and of course um so that we
don't have any more violations of
constitutional principles two prevention
of e executive Outreach accountability
to the people that's probably one of the
most important things um because we are
all accountable to the voters declaring
war is a serious decision we know that
it leads to tons of loss of life
billions of dollars and so many
long-term cons uh consequences by
requiring Congressional approval the
Constitution ensures that such a
decision is subject to debate public
scrutiny and accountability most
importantly accountability when Congress
debates and votes on war involves the
public in the whole process reinforcing
Democratic and constitutional Republican
governance just just like our
legislature we took them both to both of
those precedents in rule of law I think
that actually we have set right now um
what has been going on for decades
ignoring the requirement for the for
Congress has set the most dangerous
precedent eroding constitutional Norms
over time because that's what happens
right when we don't follow we follow one
part of it but we won't follow another
part of it it doesn't work like that
National Guard's roles and
limitations um deploying the National
Guard troops without Congressional
Authority undermines the balance between
federal and state Sovereign Authority
moral and ethical considerations and
then I'm going to end with historical
content the framers were deeply
influenced by the abuses of unilateral
military power under monarchies and
sought to ensure that war would be a
collective decision to protect the
nation from costly and unjustified
conflicts by adhering to the
Constitution and seeking Congressional
approval for war the US honors its
founding principles reinforces the rule
of law and ensures that decisions of
such magnitude are made responsibly and
democratically thank
you thank you representative would you
take questions sure are there any
questions at this
time seeing none uh I thank you again
for your testimony we have uh
just a handful of folks still looking to
speak uh Aubrey is still here yes are
Bridgewater uh Aubrey fredman
Bridgewater um Mr chairman committee
members I I definitely speak in support
of this bill most of what I was going to
say has already been said today so I'm
going to vary from my uh notes a little
bit so um there was talk about assets
the most important assets to this are
the men and women who serve in the
military and why have we been sending
them
overseas fighting
Wars
that just you know obviously endless I
mean wasn't it weird how we went from
Afghanistan 20 years it ended not too
well then suddenly it was uh excuse me
Ukraine then it's the Middle East 40,000
at troops uh in the Middle East we know
a good chunk of those are National Guard
and then there's talk about Iran and
China I mean this just goes on and on
with no defined purposes isn't it
obvious this whole system is not working
and people say well it's up to Congress
to fix it they're never going to do it
if they haven't done it in like at the
last 20 years uh or longer I mean it the
system is just it's set up wrong the
military contractors Lobby them that's
how they you know they get elected
they're not going to vote for cutting
the funding and they're and they
definitely don't want to be go on the
record as uh you know declaring war so
we have to change the
system and do something different and
let New Hampshire should take the lead
and and force the issue and then that
will
probably uh you know other states are
already working on it be nice if New
Hampshire would be the first one but it
doesn't really make any difference I
think once it starts it'll start to like
an avalanche and it would be a good
thing we need to have public discussion
before troops are sent
overseas um and as far as the New
Hampshire guard themselves I think their
primary purpose is here in this state
and then helping other states in this
country we have natural disasters or
whatever things might happen that's
their primary purpose and I think saving
lives and saving property is much more
beneficial than being deployed overseas
and killing foreigners so that's um
that's why I think we should pass this
bill and those are my thoughts thank you
thank you for those thoughts questions
or will you take any questions if
already Yes uh representative menal bomb
uh thank you Mr chairman so on your card
here you noted that you have written
testimony would you care to share that
with us for the record yeah I I'll leave
yes thank you you can bring it right up
to the CL yeah
okay representative
cyber um so I completely agree with you
on that but do you see much like would
you like to see legislation that has
more value and actually
maybe I know I'm going to say go after
but you know maybe hampering or taxing
or maybe not allowing such special
interests such as mil those that
contract with the military to make
weapons of
war so you're talking about
lobbing not even just the lobbying I
think the size of government when you've
got big government you got lot of money
at stake it's going to be
the companies and and individuals
they're going to Lobby so I you know
they've been trying how do you get
lobbing out of government big money you
make it smaller so I yeah I I think that
cut off the money and lower it and then
then you you won't have as many
lobbyists I think that's the only
solution to that thanks other
questions senan thank you for your
testimony twice
uh I have just a couple more uh Ron
carallo if I said that correctly is Ron
here yes yes he is from from Bedford New
Hampshire opposes the bill I do and
you've asked for four minutes or so Mr
chairman committee so my name is
Commander Calo United States Navy
retired 24 years of active duty
service I was a tier one
deployer been shot at by the Soviets and
others
worked in Navy uh office Naval
intelligence worked with JCS on
deployment of
forces work budgets and
funding right and I retired out of Nair
running acquisition
programs I work for one of those big
defense
contractors uh and I am very concerned
about some of the comments and
impressions that are unsupportable by
evidence we have a lot of what seems to
be um commentary and opinions that are
unsupported by current facts I have a
personal interest in this bill my son is
in the Army National Guard here and he's
Hampshire so to me what we have here is
a difference of opinion on foreign
policy of the United
States and we're going to solve it at
the New Hampshire
level it sounds like if Secretary of
Defense uh gets confirmed here he withth
he's going to solve this for us because
he's going to go in and he's going to
remove or change or deauthorize the
authorization for military force and
this matter will be done with and we
will go back and use direct uh you know
adherence to the Constitution under the
perception some people have
year this has come up as we've said
since uh prior to World or after World
War II uh Vietnam uh we've heard about
President Nixon in the War Powers
Act the authorization uh military
force has been questioned but nobody in
the department of justice has ever ruled
against it no one no one has said this
is in the Judiciary has said this is
unconstitutional
but a lot of trained legal experts here
are saying that it's
unconstitutional I think I'm going to
rest with those who've made it up to the
federal level and have the training and
position this is a national level effort
as we've
heard um it's to end endless
Wars I deal with foreign policy every
every day the threats to this nation
they're
huge and they don't get talked about
because we can't talk about but every
day I go to work
wondering what are we going to do to
handle this situation with a demission
diminishing manufacturing base uh
underfunding of the
military Readiness issues
potentially fortunately not in the guard
here we have a fantastic guard in the
any mil uh and not every conflict is a
war I deployed many times to prevent war
from breaking
out a lot of these things particularly
for
Syria that's we're not there defending
just oil interests we are there to
prevent the rise of Isis one
Administration grossly underestimated
League a president who is now coming
back into office put troops under the
aumf into Syria to handle
Isis they are still there because what
starts there will
grow Wars are not fought where
isolationism is not a valid foreign
policy right you need to only look back
to 1936 what was the net effect of
isolationism of not defending Europe at
the start it was an Nexus of 25 million
people so fighting battles of foreign
policy on shaky speculative uh
constitutional grounds that have never
been uphold held by the Department of
Justice makes absolutely no sense
particularly if it puts at risk the
funding for our guard this bill should
be
renamed not defend the guard it should
be really named defund the guard because
that's what going to happen now having
built budget exhibits for the hill I can
tell you our priorities go to those who
are trained ready and at the tip of the
spear as general melodus stated the
funding for the guard is not set by
senators and congressmen to allocate to
their states it goes to the guard
department and the Bureau of the
National Guard makes those allocations
of where that funding goes and my buddy
Colonel Pete Kowski back there already
told you how those allocations are made
right
so I don't really trust anybody who has
not built a military budget to tell me
how the military funds things I was
weren't any military officer will tell
you training in a real world environment
with forces that you'll be working with
in Wartime environment are essential to
the safety of any of our military uh
soldiers Sailors Marines and Air Force
personnel loss of training opportunities
should we lose those High Mars
battalions or those tankers or anything
else to Massachusetts Maine or
Vermont is going to place great risk on
those troops that still remain in the
guard provided we find a way to fund
them I don't want my son deploying
without proper
training I want him training with the
people he's going to be working
with our
country has not faced threats of this
II we have four major
opposition or Oppo opponents going on
right now and when I joined the military
in 1982 under Ronald Reagan we had to
reconstitute a followed out Military we
had to be able to hold back two sets two
Wars
simultaneously and then under uh as the
funding went down we went to win and
hold and win so we would hold one uh one
theater where it was currently uh and
prevent uh the opposing forces from
taking over or achieving their
objectives while we fought one war and
then we would have to move all our
troops over and uh win it you know win
the second
second
conflict the guard became an essential
part of the force structure in order to
do
that and every Guardsman that signs up
signs to the same oath that I took when
I signed up at the age of
18 support and defend the
Constitution We Trust in our leaders
that we elect the
thing and now we're questioning their
morals their values and we're accusing
them of weakness because they won't
stand up because of a few individuals
interpretation what
constitutionality uh consists of I'm
sorry I don't buy that because otherwise
we'd be removing them from office and I
level as I said I have over 24 years of
military uh experience
I have uh experience in building budgets
I have experience in the acquisition
Community right I've read the federal
acquisition rules I have to live by them
I have to live by them as a contractor
if you honestly think that we sit in a
back room and negotiate sweetheart deals
make you are unaware of the legal
ramifications for anything like that I
would be spending most of my time time
in jail from here
on we have so many rules in effect of
who we can talk to during Source
selection and Source selection is run by
needs and needs are generated all the
way up the chain all right they're not
negotiated in back room deals so
contractors like myself can get rich in
fact the amount of profit or fee that we
can take on a contract is very limited
most cases 10% or less think about that
for a minute if you're a small business
markup 30 40
10% why are things so uh costly you know
that's a whole separate argument but
basically we build in small numbers
so
um all right as a retired naval officer
as I mentioned uh I can assure you the
funding decisions are made
by prioritizing forces that are ready to
go and those that are not ready to go
but have Capital Equipment that's very
valuable tankers uh or the high Mars
those will go to other
units loss of our guards funding and
resultant reduction rightness because of
a political debate in Washington by a
few members of congress with our own
agenda by the way Rand Paul is firmly
behind this and for the record I am a
republican once funding is lost it may
never be uh restored and our guard would
end up watching on the sidelines or what
remains of our guard while the rest of
the country goes off and supports their
original
Mission I can think of nothing more
humiliating as an American or a military
officer or a
member uh of the State of New Hampshire
than watching other people defend my
freedoms and I don't have the
opportunity to do so nor my son a third
generation
military
member
so I also have questions in removing uh
our Governor's ability to uh make
decisions regarding her guard which she
is in charge of uh between title 10 and
title 32 uh I think some of the comments
have relaxed that when when the guard is
called up she does not have a a say in
that anyway uh they are federalized at
that point in time
uh I realize there's I touched on a
number of different topics uh
acquisition intelligence how decisions
are made uh addressing them in three
minutes is not necessarily uh going to
cover all the bases or provide you with
all the uh uh information that you might
need however I am more than happy to
follow up uh and testimony before this
uh committee or in private uh or
correspond by email um and answer any
questions that you may have
thank you for that uh I see you have
some notes is this something that the
clerk can file or or not um there's two
sets of notes here sir uh one is online
was filed as the uh um on the on the
site so you okay okay so we can look at
that right and the other I can forward
to the committee um which goes back into
the history of aumf and how uh I think
Colonel kosi pretty much described
pretty well it its Origins but um it's
more testimony on that it was based from
last year's Bill okay are there any
questions see none thank you for that
that testimony and for your service and
for your son service have two more cards
uh Ben we is Ben yes that's I thought
that might be Ben there you've been here
before maybe yeah you're right welcome
back uh Ben is asked for five minutes to
support the
measure good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Ben we um I'm a
former 11 Bravo infantryman in the US
Army um I was a previous candidate for
marac County Sheriff I'm a cancer
survivor I'm a father and ultimately
that's why I'm here today I want to
protect the future of my
son um and I'm also the founder of the
nonprofit punks for
Liberty I'm here today to tell you guys
I support defend the guard I'm a huge
supporter of defend the guard um because
as a veteran I've seen firsthand the
Devastation uh and the consequences that
these endless Wars has caused uh I've
watched many of my friends come back
permanently
disfigured uh mentally shattered we
heard somebody earlier talking about
suicide rates I've lost five friends
that were veterans to
Suicide two of them were in the National
Guard we live in a world today where 20
million people over the last 24 years
since 9911 have been displaced of their
homes we live in a world today where
over 2 million people have died from
these wars these endless Wars
overseas to put that into
perspective that's more than our entire
State's
population these aren't just numbers
these are human lives that we're talking
about here obviously you you probably
get a sense that I'm passionate about
this because uh I'm talking about people
who are literally people I I I looked
across the room on and these are my best
friends that I'm talking about many of
them lost their
lives now imagine looking me looking
into the eyes of any of their families
and suggesting that we haven't been at
War this entire time that's
ridiculous um Congress hasn't uh you
know obviously done its due diligence by
upholding the
Constitution um you know which requires
them to make an official declaration of
war we've heard this many times today I
think the two words of the of the day
are probably Constitution and funding
you guys might want to play a drinking
game later to to work that one out um
but uh the last time Congress declared
war was 83 years ago it'd be absurd for
me to look uh in the eyes of the mother
of of my best friend and tell her that
her son wasn't at War because they just
never declared it that's
ridiculous and I'm sure no nobody would
disagree with that um but it's your duty
as lawmakers to uphold the Constitution
it it that is the number one priority
defend the guard is about just that uh
it ensures that New Hampshire uh
Guardsmen won't be sent overseas until
they do their constitutional
responsibility and declare war if that's
what they deem is
necessary now I know there's a lot of
concerns about funding uh and that's
something that just keeps getting
brought up and mentioned over and over
uh but let me remind everybody here that
the military-industrial complex is one
of the most bloated and overfunded
entities in the entire government uh
they have received over $14 trillion
since 911 that's over half of our
ballooning uh uh National debts um
amount so the Constitution does not care
about funding concerns and uh neither
should you when it comes to the lives
and the Liberties of our national
Guardsmen and our residents here in New
Hampshire if we're not sending our
Guardsmen overseas it just
mathematically checks out that it's not
going to be as
expensive uh you know how much money are
the lives of those 2 million people that
died overseas worth as well or the 15
National Guardsmen that have died since
9/11
we paid out probably almost $10 million
to those families we can start with
budget cuts right there instead of
sending them the money you know that
that it's it's it's all absurd to
me but this is so much more than just
dollars and cents it really is it's
about upholding the principles that this
country was founded on something that
every single one of you guys has a duty
to to
do it's about protecting our neighbors
and our families and it's about
protecting the granite Staters uh from
being sent off to die in wars that
haven't even been formally
authorized you don't just have a
responsibility you have a fiscal
responsibility
too this is our moment to stand with
veterans uh all across New Hampshire
across the country vast majority of them
do support this type of legislation uh
to bring our troops home and to not just
our national Guardsman eventually
hopefully we can protect our troops by
having them right here at home instead
of sending them everywhere
else now we had talked about Congress
having a duty as well to uphold the
Constitution and we can't we can't
dismiss that but that's not you guys's
problem that's our problem we need to
all vote as taxpayers to vote the people
who are voting for these NeverEnding
Wars you know we need to vote them out
but Congress is incentivized to keep
these wars going they're being funded by
Ron even Joe Biden's secretary of
defense for the last several years Lloyd
Austin he tripled his
portfolio because of the contracts that
he uh sent off to other countries
selling them missiles and bombs and all
this stuff but we can close that door
permanently we deserve State autonomy
states have rights and you guys have a
responsibility to look after New
Hampshire first the people who are are
voting you in to represent
them if our state ever has an
emergency they're going to be here to
help with that we're going to have
abundant resources I have no doubt in my
mind that there's not going to be any
funding cuts for the military this is
it's just not going to happen
they transfer things around it's all
money games you guys know how budgets
work this is your moment to take a stand
with veterans like me and in the in the
in the crowd and many of you guys are
veterans as well which is I I
appreciate this is your moment to stand
with the
Constitution and with the people of New
Hampshire I hope that you'll do the
right thing and I hope that you'll pass
defend the guard I hope that we can lead
the nation in this and everyone can look
at us as the examples for what doing the
right thing looks like thank
you thank you for your testimony Mr we
there would you take questions if there
are any sure are there any questions at
this time representative saber thanks
for taking my question um um so one of
my issues when we EXA this bill the last
time was that I kind of have a hard time
seeing just because well there's the
requirements that are here that are
saying that okay well it's all fine if
the if they just you know if Congress
declares war you know and to me it seems
like the special interests will just go
in there and buy up politicians even
more than they already do right now just
to make sure War gets declared to keep
doing what they do do see that as they
are certainly going to that I mean I
have no doubt in my mind that they're
lobbying against this bill right now and
we might not see it in this room but
they are absolutely against the defend
the guard bill because they are I mean
their their interests are are uh
benefiting from this um so yeah sure
APAC Ron they're going to they're going
to go on the other side of this and and
try to keep incentivizing things even
more but truthfully it's not our
responsibility what Congress does they
are supposed to be representing us and
it's very clear that they do not they
have not for 83 years so uh you know
they they need to uphold the responsib
is we need to uphold the Constitution
and that's ultimately what this comes
down to We Can't dictate what Congress
does we can only influence our state's
politics and that's why I'm urging every
single person here to uphold the
Constitution because that is what they
do other
questions thank you again appreciate
it I have one more card before I call
the uh the final uh speaker
testifier uh I just want to thank the
committee for your time today for being
here we have some folks who could not
make it we'll be in touch with those
folks I expect
them uh to uh review uh all the
testimony that we've received because we
are going to exact this a week from
today so uh I'll be looking at material
that uh that has been shared uh I'll Pro
I I'm sure I'll go back onto the video
um and uh
we will exec this in a week so folk I
know there's a lot lot of interest in
this uh have no idea how this will go uh
we haven't even finished the sharing yet
but uh again thank you for your time and
thank everybody who has testified so the
last card I have is uh just came in from
another uh state representative serving
representative who asked for one minute
I think we can do that for
representative
Granger and if you need more than a
minute representative we're flexible
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Michael Granger I'm
a former Specialist of Al company second
108 infantry in the New York National
Guard if we pass defend the guard and
it's signed it is super easy to get the
National Guard to do whatever just
declare war which is what they're
supposed to be doing anyway it should be
really easy if the war is just if the
war is just and justifiable it should be
easy to get a war declared because the
representatives in Congress will be more
than happy to do such a thing if it's
unjust we should not be playing ball we
should not be involved in these wars if
they are not just Wars we are Unown
under no obligation to help in unjust
Wars and if we should not be bought off
easily with rockets because it is an
insult to the dignity and morality of
the New Hampshire people to be bought
off with rockets especially when the New
Hampshire people are paying for those
Rockets these are not gifts from on high
the high Mars are paid for with tax
dollars those tax dollars are paid for
by New Hampshire taxpayers it either
comes from their pocket in which case
we're just giving them their own Rockets
back to them or it is taxed via their
savings which is money taken from their
savings through inflation by printing at
the Federal Reserve it's not free
Rockets there's no such thing as a free
lunch so I am pleased with New
Hampshire's traditional manner of
bucking the feds and doing what we think
is right regardless of the carrots and
the sticks and if you think that federal
law can override the con
as may be considered the case based on
some testimony that was provided it
stands to reason that New Hampshire law
can override federal law because we're
doing everything backwards now so I
didn't swear an oath and neither did you
to uphold and defend Federal funding I
swore no to the
Constitution please OTP this Bill thank
you thank you representative questions
are there any
questions if thank you again that will
[Applause]
wrap up our hearing today thank you to
all concern all con as we say in the
military and uh we will uh be back a
week from today Mr chairman yes may I
remind the me members of this committee
to make sure that you put in a so you
can get
paid do your little doad
right the the the mile the mileage the
mil put in the last four numbers of your